Who's JF?
Wait, did you just say who's JF? JF Gary?
You don't know who JF Gary is? Hold on.
Hold on. We need a little a little pallet cleanser to see who
>> essentially the conclusion of this part >> uh
I don't think so. I think Oh, I see. Yeah. Nice. Okay.
I think we're both going to react to uh some JF stuff here. >> Is
it working? >> Uh let's see. Try it out.
Speak into it. Yeah, it's working. >> Okay. Yeah, based.
All right.
Oh, the nice part about having an actual audio setup, you can
just plug a microphone in and it's working out of nowhere. Let's
go. We love PPP. Okay, let's watch some clips. Okay, we're watch
a couple clips of JF just so you guys can get a sense. You got
to remember who this guy is. If you remember the Ethan Klein
video that came out recently where I think Destiny argues with
this guy, JF is the guy who had the wife. All right. Who he dropped
off in the woods. Yes. Didn't this guy kill someone? He is. Many
people believe he killed his ex-wife, Mama JF. All right. Claims
to have dropped her off in the woods. Who knows if that even
happened. He had multiple stream comments afterwards that explained
how you would create an alibi if you needed to murder somebody
about creating like a digital alibi and then talking about bleaching
his whole household to get rid >> the day after >> to
get it like clean. Yeah. >> No, like the day after he dropped
her off, he talked about cleaning his entire house with bleach
or something. Yeah. Um, other crucial context. Yes, he is also
high IQ, but actually high IQ. No, no, no, no. He is actually
probably like in some ways high IQ. He has a PhD in genetic biology
or something like some form of genetics. Okay. And he received,
yes, $25,000 from Jeffrey Epste himself in order to study genetics.
He got a grant from Jeff Epstein.
Okay. More time goes on and she never shows, the more likely
he killed her. Well, I mean, probably if he just dropped it off
in the woods, it's not like that would have gone well, right?
Anyway, let's watch a clip or two. >> Your personality,
there's nothing that will change it. We looked at every possible
worlds in which you could be educated. The thing is, if you're
a you're going to be a
it's like this is a feeling that I do have. >> I don't
think my mother could have done anything
to help me. I don't think my mother could have led to a JF.
>> Sorry. I'm laughing at PPP's reaction. Not necessarily
like JF even. I'm just laughing at PPP throwing his arms up like
what the [__] are we supposed to do with this guy?
>> The are we even supposed to do with him?
>> You show the right video. >> I show the right
Oh, is it not showing in the Discord? The correct one? >> Okay,
I'll fix it. One second.
>> Main stream.
this guy.
Okay, should be the correct one now. And
>> pause this music. All right, so with all that set up,
guys, we're moving on to the video. Please play a clip of Mama
JF. Okay, I could try to find a clip of Mama JF.
>> Yeah, Cherry can just do
>> that. Being said, it says >> this is the wife
who went missing. Okay, >> that I really love it. is the
original orange shedder.
Now people are saying, "Jeff, why don't you share with uh
with Mama Jeff?" Well, do you want some? >> No, because
we went to his mother house and also I drink so much this morning
and then I feel like Oh my god. >> Okay. You feel like
Oh my god. So you see she doesn't want to >> also I eat
only cheese since two days. Only cheese. Because give me Why
you give me so much cheese? You're like a ninja titan.
You is it like a blood? >> Now, correct me if I'm wrong.
In the old debate where he was arguing for why he should be able
to be with his wife, I believe that was a different woman with
mental impairment who did not have custo like who could not be
her own guardian, right? I believe that's a different woman than
this one who people also argue likely had some mental
that she could not take care of herself, right? So JF went from
like Yes, he has a type. Okay,
we're on the third woman, says Riyle. >> Yeah. No, because
he likes them like uh like a female George,
right? He likes them big and to kind of
match his >> which of course is why he famously approached
Pearl to have kids with him. >> Yes. Yes. >> Yeah.
Just Pearly. >> This white woman is talking about she should
not be allowed to vote. I should breed with her.
This is perfect. >> One second. I'm gonna see if I can
find this tweet really quickly. I'm trying to find the JF the
JF tweet. Ah, I can't find it. If somebody can find me the JF
tweet at Pearl, would love to see it. All right, >> I can
probably find it, >> but I'm going to I'm going to keep
going. Let's actually check this out. So, I think we've done
enough of the leadup for this. This is going to be exciting.
I'm I'm going to enjoy this. All right.
>> Well, that's okay. You can be an Alberta housewife.
I'm not married, so you can still be an Alberta house by even
though you're back in the States. Um, so you and I went over
some questions and we're just going to jump right into it just
so we can because we have so much to cover. >> Um, so you're
you're the mystery woman that's been identified as the 10 out
of
>> How does it feel to have that title?
>> Is it is that why truly I'm just curious. Is that why
you preferred not to show your face today? Well, yeah, because
like he set me up like when you tell people, "Oh, my girlfriend's
a 10 out of 10." If I go on there, >> you know, they'll
be like, "Oh, you know, you know, >> yeah, people will
because people are." But it's okay. Don't worry. I get criticized
every every stream. There's usually somebody and that's usually
c somebody that that's usually I assume they're with JF talking
about how fat I am. Like,
>> we zoom into the Discord image she has. Notice anything
weird about her head
Um that it is like supremely cone- shaped I suppose.
That would be the only thing. Okay. That it's like far skinnier
than his. His his head is very large.
>> I no matter where you go though, I did think that was
why. And I think that's so
that's okay. You don't have to show your face, but you can when
you're ready. Um and you are beautiful, so don't worry about
it.
>> And also, I just want to pat us on the back. First of
all, Holly. us detective ladies. Um because we were right in
our information we got from the homeowner. The pregnancy tests
that were in the garbage were >> 10 out of 10. So 10 out
of 10. Congratulations, you have a baby.
>> Okay. So apparently these people talked to what the
homeowner of like one of JF's homes or where where were they
getting info about the pregnancy test in somebody's garbage or
in somebody's possession? I'm There's like a lot of lore that's
going on here that I'm intrigued by and we'll probably never
know the answers to. >> How How old is your baby? >> He's
about a month old. >> Oh my god, he's so cute, too. The
pictures, he's like, he is actually >> Yeah, thank you.
>> Mostly looks like you.
>> Thank god. >> So JF is obviously the father.
>> Well, you know, I have heard he's a amazing dad.
>> I'm being very sarcastic.
Yeah. Well, when he talks about family values, think Manson family.
>> Yeah, I will. I will. I I I believe you.
>> is is this your only child that you have? The one >> a
Okay. >> So, JF is the one who started this public he publicized
your breakup. He mentioned that you kidnapped the baby stuff.
Can you do you want to tell everybody how that happened and then
we'll go back to how you met him after we talk about your breakup?
So, how we got here? >> So, how the breakup happened.
>> Okay. Um, so while I was with JF, I noticed like I I
loved him there. I still have very strong feelings for him. I'm
emotionally, you know,
>> I'm going to call Cap on that. You know, stop the cap.
I don't believe that. Okay. I don't believe you could show up
to like dump all of this guy's secrets. I've not actually like
watched any of this yet. I just heard basically she describes
like the state of his house, how he takes care of his kids and
you don't care about somebody if you're going to go and dump
all that stuff on the internet. Okay, that's up. How he takes
care of his kid. Dude, come on.
>> it's it's hard to just like when you're in love with
someone, you don't just overnight stop loving them, >> right?
No, of course. And I still like part of me is like, "Oh, I hope
he changes and all, but you know, I know logically he's not going
to." But um so after I gave birth, I had been holding a lot of
things in while I was >> Hold on. Hold on. She seems like
not a great person to me, but what do I know?
I mean, I just feel like probably anybody who sought out JF after
the Mama JF debacle. I'm just gonna That's gonna be my only heristic.
That's the only heristic I need. Okay.
Yeah, she's probably not very nice. She might be kind of dumb,
possibly.
10 out of 10 was her IQ. Okay. >> Was pregnant >> because
like when you're pregnant, you're not supposed to stress out
and argue and >> so just, you know, I put on a happy face
>> held a lot of stuff in. And after I was pregnant, um,
you know, I didn't put his name on the birth certificate.
And I didn't realize he would react like he did, but he went
totally ballistic. And >> was he there in the room with
you or >> Oh, no, no, he's I um left Canada
a week after I found out I was pregnant. >> Oh, okay.
>> I've been in the US for my entire pregnancy because
I didn't want to have it in that environment. It was very
>> Good job. Good for you for take care of you first. >> Good
for you. >> So, you had the baby. You didn't put his name
on and he So, he's texting you, I guess, while you're in the
hospital. >> Well, it was after I got out of the hospital.
Um, I got home and one night, I think in the middle of the night,
he texted me and he was like, "Did you put my name on the birth
certificate?" And I was like, "Well, no, I'm, you know," and
I didn't want to I, you know, that's when all hell broke loose,
right? >> How did he react?
um he became very emotional
and crying and stuff and I felt bad you know I didn't want to
be in that situation.
I wanted his >> not cool man >> name to be on the
birth certificate but the reason I couldn't bring myself to put
it on was because he has mental health problems. >> Right.
Well, yeah. And I mean as we carry on >> Yeah. And I don't
trust him with kids. >> Weird. It's weird that you don't.
>> That's I mean that's a pretty up reason to not put somebody's
like a parents name on a birth certificate by the way. Just to
be clear that'd be kind of up like it's still the father of the
baby. >> Trusted with kids. >> I mean honestly I'm
seeing a pattern here on the internet. No, I I think that's great.
So that's awful. So you now you also you were sick too after
you had your baby, weren't you? >> Yeah, I had postpartum
preeacclampsia and I had to be hospitalized for it. >> What
is that? Just for some of the people who are watching. Um, it's
like a condition that arises when you're pregnant or after you
are. >> Um, your blood pressure goes up. Mine was going
up to over 183. I was my feet were swollen. Um,
>> yeah, it just depends on the person what symptoms you
have. But it is very dangerous and you know, it's a very serious
thing. So tell me at least tell me this while you're dealing
with the the postpartum. >> Oh, you almost died like as
you're having your kid. Okay. Well, now tell me this. I really
hope this is a relevant question and not just like
now tell me this. How big was JF's? I if it's something like
that, I'm I will get a perfect vibe check for this whole >> Crap.
Yeah. Uh he's the least being supportive then. He's not bombarding
you or upsetting you then, right?
>> No. Oh, he's not a class act. I thought he might be
for five seconds. What What How did he handle that? What was
he up >> So, he was um upsetting me just arguing about
the name on the birth certificate. And um he I was like, "Look,
I I really don't feel like arguing about this right now. I need
to focus on getting better." And the nurses that were coming
in my hospital room noticed they're like, "Every time you're
talking to your boyfriend, your blood pressure is going
>> Oh my god. >> And I was like begging him. I And
I was even video chatting with him. I was crying and I was like,
"Please stop. Just, you know, be nice to me." I was begging him,
"Be nice to me. I can't handle this right now. This isn't the
time." And he's like, "I'll be nice to you when you put my name
on the birth certificate." What a self-centered.
>> Wait, what?
I mean,
I don't know. Like, okay, he should maybe try to be nice, but
it seems like that's an appropriate place to get upsets. Like,
yeah, he wants to be a part of his kid's life. I don't know if
she's never heard this guy talk in his life. JF Gary, the one
thing I know about JF Gary is he takes his breeding very seriously.
Okay, that is like the only thing he cares about in the entire
universe is breeding. Okay. And you're going to deprive him of
that? Deprive him of that child. Probably the best shot at reasonable
adult genetics he's ever going to get in his life. Yeah, of course
he's now. He should probably be nice, but but damn, you taking
away his one thing, the only
>> Wow. And he was also um talking to other girls.
And uh >> he was like,
"I'll I'll be uh faithful to you when you put my name on the
birth >> Oh, so he's making you insecure. He's trying to
like he's doing what he did to Allora. Like, oh, there's going
to be other women in the queue. Is that what he's doing? What
a [__] So, you've just given birth to >> Is
that a real threat? Is that a from JF? Uh if you want to me to
stop other women, you will put my name on their birth certificate.
>> This child, you're sick and it is like a very high risk
sickness, >> you're all of this. And it's all about JF.
That's all he cares about. >> Yeah. And like >> he
admitted to me, he's like uh one in particular, he's like, "Oh,
I had to um confide in another woman." And >> is that the
panda? >> Yeah. And he said, >> "The thing is, she's
not even a woman. She's a child." >> Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. What's the name? >> Um, confide
in another woman. And >> is that the cringe panda?
>> The cringe panda.
>> Who is the cringe panda? >> Yeah, a child. >> What's
that? >> Apparently a child.
>> The thing is, she's not even a woman. She's a child.
>> No, I check I did check. I I did deep deep check. She's
25. >> Oh, really? >> Oh, why' this call her a child?
>> She's gonna be like, "Yeah, Jay has kids." Uh, wait.
We checked. She's 25. Oh, well.
Oops.
Oops. My bad. >> Technically not. >> Do we know the
IQ of the of this lady? >> Um, it can't Listen, I'm not
getting good vibes off the bat. Okay. >> Also around 25.
>> Yeah, I'm getting like room temp indications. Okay.
>> All right. One second. Just We found the tweet, guys.
We found the tweet. Okay. Jeff Gary epi. This is how seriously
he takes breeding. Okay. Pearl Davis tweets out in 2023. Real
men marry and squirt out baby. You have no victim. You no have
victim mentality. Find good woman. Squirt out baby. And JF Gary
responds, I am hereby offering to squirt out baby with pearly
things. Insemination claimable between the months of September
to December 2023 for birth around June to September of 2024.
Travel fees may apply.
This is like his one passion in the world. >> may apply.
Well, listen. She catches him in, you know, December. It's a
depressing time of the year to spend alone. Maybe he makes an
exception. Pays for his own ticket. I don't know. >> I
don't know. >> Chad, I did check. I I did deep deep check.
She's 25. >> Oh, really? She's >> technically not
a child. She likes to
>> uh Everybody point and laugh at Destin Suggs. Okay.
Dustin Suggs, point and laugh at this guy. This is an unacceptable
opinion to have. That's pretty gross to say. >> Oh, that
is a fat black man. That is an obese black man. >> Destin
Suggs. How do you respond? Destin Suggs, you've been called out.
How do you respond?
What's going on there? Oh, this is apparently the cringe panda
person that JF was threatening to cheat with. Okay. The cringe
panda. twitch.tv/the
cringe panda. Wow.
All right, hold on. They're apparently on kick, too. Kick and
Twitch, the cringe pad. Let's see if we got a clip. I'm going
to check for a clip. We'll see if we got a clip. Check out the
the the top clip if it's there. Clips. Clips. Clips. Top. All
time. All time. Greatest clip from the Cringe Panda. Let's take
a look.
>> I don't know. I don't even know what I'm talking about
anymore.
But um
but like um comment down below if you like Skippy Riz Ohio Gronk
and if you think it would be so ried up if we could go to Skibby
uh if we could uh go to Skibby Phantom Tax Land.
And
>> this was four months ago. By the way, >> this
is giving me Turkey Tom's going to fly out and do a video on
her. >> Except she's already like way older than Turkey
Tom, so it's a little weird for her to be doing it this way.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But like this will be his next video.
>> Yeah.
I I That's rough. You You for Turkey Tom and you land
in JF Phil. That's That's kind of tough, man. That's not great.
Boulevard Broken Dreams. >> Cosplay as a child, >> which
is weird.
>> That's weird. But yeah, and it's also weird. It's weird
that he would do that. >> So she cosplays as a child. She's
not a child. She cosplays as a child. >> And it's weird
that he would send you those text messages. Right. And he was
like, "Oh, she's telling she's calling uh she was calling him
professor and like she was like, "Our babies would have my blue
eyes."
>> And it's like I looked her up. Apparently, she's like
supposed to be a conservative Christian, but I wasn't aware like
that it was a conservative value to try to be a home wrecker.
>> No. Well, >> Oh, dude. The ADBL stuff is so weird.
I saw like two seconds of content on that. Maybe we'll try to
go down that rabbit hole at some point. That's uh adult diaper
boy love or something. Like it's like a >> I don't want
to know anything. >> It's like some diaper fetish thing.
>> Don't want to know anything after >> Yeah, I know.
I know. >> Sounds like um Sounds like her JF though might
have been talking for a few years from what >> baby love
just to be clear. >> Four. But it just that's just okay.
So that's just a bag thing to do. Yeah. So so I mean good for
you though for sticking it to him and saying no you absolutely
not because a lot of women in that in that moment they would
have felt insecure and they would have maybe crumbled and they
would have maybe just you know done what he wanted and and whatever
gone against their own will. So that's impressive though that
you just you went got through it and you said [__]
you made me >> right and it made me dig my heels even
>> dig my heels in even more because I was like do you
think that you're helping your cause any like why would I put
your name on the birth certificate when I know if I kick off
that you're going to move in one of these
crazy women and like they're going to have access to my child.
Yeah. No.
>> Uh,
someone just linked a cringe panda tweet. What a dying society
looks like.
Wow.
Crazy.
I Oh, the race mixing. I see what they're upset about. I see.
Yeah, I get it. I see it.
I I can I'm already I Listen, I'm So many things get filled in
so quickly nowadays, don't they? >> No, I'm not. >> Nope.
Well, I I mean, as I'm glad it happened just because it mean
I really think it saved your ass a lot.
>> Besides that, I know that you have a very very good
relationship with your mom who also lives with you in the >> And
uh I just want to say a shout out to your mom because she is
so good. She is
>> that 10 out of 10 can come on and talk and tell her
story. And her mom sounds like she's just been like over the
top supportive. And so you're so lucky that you have that support
and I think it's
>> So, all right. So, we've gotten to how you broke up
because that's quicker than getting to >> the rest, but
people really do want to know uh how how did you first discover
>> Um, so I was uh reading a blog post by uh this guy called
Vox Day. He's like a
commentator and stuff and he just kind of briefly mentioned
uh that JF's partner had disappeared and um he kind of he described
JF as ner
>> so she was just reading an article okay about how JF's
about how Mama JF disappeared all right and she was intrigued
all right her heart was all a >> neurologically unique
and I thought that was kind of funny because I have autism and
I would consider myself a little bit you're neurologically unique
and I just um on >> oh my god a guy who's only attracted
to I'm a
oh my god >> whim contacted JF and uh we ended up talking
and he he says he has autism too I don't know >> he's got
a few things he's got like I don't know he's like a narcissistic
>> yeah I don't know what he is totally
But um you know he >> Do you remember when you started
talking to him? Like I'm just trying to keep track for when she
went away and >> October of 2023.
>> That's when you first started talking to him. Not when
you Okay.
>> Okay. And she was born missing in October 2023, >> right?
And it was before like a lot of news had come out and
it was before I think he really >> When did Mama JF go
missing? Uh, I don't remember the the date. It would have been
not that far before that, right?
Would have been I thought it was fall. I don't think it was summer.
Uh, when did Mama JF When did
>> Oh, I read that your wife is missing and you're super
into what it do. >> Yeah. Yeah. June 2023 is when Mama
JF went missing. So, it was within 3 months of Mama JF going
missing and basically all of the content that would have been
made around Mama JF being like murdered by JF >> and she
was like, "Yeah, what's up? What's up, bro?" >> That's
crazy. >> How's it going, buddy? >> Done interviews
about it. And I kind of I just assumed she would show up at that
point. Like, >> yeah. Well, what did he tell you about
his uh in the early talks when you were just talking online,
you hadn't come out. What did he tell you about and the family
situation?
He said like that she was crazy and
like this hippie woman and
that she wanted to leave.
>> That's Oh, so it was similar story to what he's continuously
said.
>> Okay. Um >> there was a rumor someone saw her
in some kind of monastery somewhere, but I don't think it was
super credible or verified. No, it was also definitely JF like
posting that on 4chan or some [__] Yeah, posted on
4chan and then JF is like, I reported this to the police. I'm
so glad they found her,
>> is totally fake. >> Did you ever see uh
I don't even know how I wrote that one down. That one sounds
dumb. Um what made you believe him over the stuff you were reading
online? That one I'm curious about. Like how did you read something
from like a lot of people in a forum? Because I knew we'd have
checked some things out and then he
>> does his what? His magic. like is it >> Is he
just good?
>> Well, I would say I was kind of depressed at that point
in my life and
vulnerable and I felt like um
>> I I wanted to believe him, >> right? I wanted
to believe him. >> That's what I think. I think a lot of
people don't realize that that that is exactly what happens to
us. so good at brainwashing ourselves into >> it's just
uh I just feel like sometimes I think of like co and people had
like the craziest excuse people got into the craziest during
co with like that same thing like I was kind of depressed I was
kind of bored and you know I just I figured I'd try something
new >> things that we see really we can see it and we just
we deny it and we justify it to ourselves it's crazy >> so
I mean I get it how you could do that but I wanted just >> other
people to maybe hear it Um, so when you started talking, how
quickly after you guys started talking did JF invite you to Canada?
>> Um, like pretty much right away and he
>> like he didn't try to get to know you at all first.
>> Yeah. No. Um, he so I didn't actually I hadn't even
watched one of his streams in full ever and I didn't know about
him doing the incimination stuff. And like one of the things
he said to me when I first emailed him was he's like, "Let me
know if you want to make babies." And I thought he was just being
kind of cute. I didn't realize it was like a deepseated.
He's a weird weird >> he uh I don't know. You didn't you
didn't see it, but I mean he advertises it. He's not hiding it.
>> No. Very boldly. He's got that like Nick Cannon thing.
I need to knock up every beautiful woman. But for Jup, it's every
large woman that I can, you know, convince to come to Canada.
>> He's trying to build a basketball team that could compete
in the Special
>> Okay, that's weird about it. Yeah. No. >> So,
so right away, so he invited you. What what I find shocking and
concerning and thank God you weren't a creep. >> Okay.
You could have been a creep. There are a lot of like you guys
look at the news. There's female all over. Okay. You do not.
Who the invites some woman they just met online?
>> There's female.
>> There's female pedophile. Thank god you weren't a creep
cuz there are female
all >> He said that to her or she said that to >> No,
I think this person, this Rocky person top right. I think she
just said that apppropo of nothing.
I think she's saying like JF didn't make sure you weren't a creep.
He's got kids. She didn't make sure he didn't make sure that
you weren't a And there are female
>> Are there? Uh yeah. Uh assuming you believe all women
are prof.
>> Are they?
>> I mean there's an argument. >> Is there? >> There
really is. >> There. I don't think that there is. >> There
really is. >> I don't think there is.
>> Listen, Zirka is very rarely wrong. >> Come and
stay in their home or visit. >> He's very often wrong.
What the is going on right now? >> Stop. Stop asking questions.
you know, at their home with their small children that they,
you know, they don't they didn't even talk to you for a long
time. Like so irresponsible.
And I'm so glad that you were who you were because it could have
ended up way worse.
>> they could have. Um, so when did you make your first
trip to Canada then? Like when did you decide, okay, [__]
it. I'm just going to go see him. >> He was pressuring
me to come very quickly, but I like I put it off because I didn't
feel comfortable with it. I put it off until March of 2024. >> That's
pretty good cuz I think he would have been I can only imagine
uh how much pressure he was putting on you. >> So March
of 2024.
>> Okay. I just cuz because we've seen the house. So people
who are watching right now if you have um
>> if you haven't seen the house it's in
>> real quick. Don't ever slander Zurka. I like Zerga.
Okay. I'm a fan of Zerga.
I don't agree with most of what he says. He's only done me wrong
one time. Zirka said, "Cherry, you have no curves. Any guy attracted
to you is a
>> And I've been upset. That that just lives in my head."
Rentree. >> My ass up the playlist on YouTube and uh Rumble
under JF Garupppy. Um so when you got there, I'm just dying to
know what was your first impression when you saw JF like did
he pick you up at the airport? How did that work? Or >> Yeah,
he picked me up at the airport in Charlotte Town and um it was
like I don't know an hour or so back to the house in Ori.
>> What did you think of JF when you first saw him? Honestly,
just be honest. It's >> Little bigger than I expected.
>> By a little bigger, you mean like 200 lb >> Oh,
rough.
>> Holly, will you pop up that one picture of him with
her? Uh she's walking in front of him. I'm sorry. Le >> after
this question, we're just going to take a quick break. We have
a bunch of questions that uh people have posted and we have a
rumble rant. So, we need to go over those. >> Okay. Wait,
we can't do the questions until after we get to the the
just before we get into the Allora part >> because we're
not even there yet, Holly. We I've got to keep these questions
in sync. Okay. So, this is the man that you saw, the man on the
screen here. The one that definitely should be wearing a
What are they doing? >> Those are Oh, >> poor JF.
Poor JF. Dude,
listen.
That That beard only looks good from one angle. Okay. The camera
angle he uses. All right. It kind of makes it look like he's
got a jaw there. It looks like he's been hiding a little bit
more than a jaw. Not ideal. >> It's so crazy cuz you know
that for women when their camera is facing down, it's because
they want their cleavage in the shot or something like that,
right? >> Not just that's not the only reason. It's mostly
the reason the cleavage
>> I don't know the other reasons,
>> but for guys when they cut off their camera right at
the shoulder,
I'm starting to think that
all of them are just pear-shaped.
>> I'm starting to think every guy who cuts their camera
off like right at the shoulder and just does a head shot
>> There's probably Well, here's your angle. It's probably
not like proof positive or dispositive of anything because it
is just the best shot to have, but yeah, you could easily hide
whatever you want by doing that. Like there is no reason like
why do you need your like what for what reason would you want
your nipples in the shot as a guy like or your cleavage or chest?
>> Well, you don't have to have your nipples showing you.
>> I'm just saying that like there's just no reason. People
only care about your face. It's not like you express with your
chest or something. So, it's like no reason to have it. But,
I do get that you could easily hide whatever you want >> So,
that's fair. But I I just don't see I can't think of a reason
I need to see a guy's whole torso when he streams. Unless it's
Kaiat and he's going to do like back flips or some [__]
Like that guy's going to go do some back flips. He's going to
do some crazy. Yeah, I can see a wider shot. >> I mean,
if you think about um some a lot of podcasts now, they're just
they're doing full seats where you see the entire body. >> Like
it's the chair. You're not at a table anymore. You're not at
a desk.
>> Uh that's a bit more bold.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I uh I I feel like I have some
people who caught me off guard with how they looked after I saw
them just from the face shop, but it would be rude to point them
out. So,
>> wow. Well, yeah, because you're a supermodel, you see,
and she's >> so So, so he showed up like that. Okay. So,
when you got So, that would have been like shocking, but good
for you if you're just, you know, I mean, what are you going
to do? You're there.
>> did you So, then he get to the house and now he's talked
himself up. I know he has cuz he talks a lot of [__]
all day long. He talks about what a provider he is. So when you
got to that house in Ori, I need to know what were your what
what happened in your brain. >> Um I was like I can't wait
to pop an ambient and go to sleep.
>> It was just too much to think about. I just wasn't ready
to process. >> You got hit with the whammy. Okay. She walked
in. Smell was off. >> Did she describe the smell? >> She
did not describe it. I'm talking about the smell. She Everything
was wrong. Okay. She realized she basically just went to like
the house from Texas Chainsaw Massacre and >> and she was
like, "You know what? Holy I just I need to get on drugs. Where
are their drugs? Get me drugs now."
>> Yeah, cuz that uh so you and I know, listen, I know
we've talked a lot of about how the house wasn't clean and you
have said that you've cleaned a lot in that house. I believe
that you cleaned a lot house. My my talking is not about your
cleanliness or whatever. It was about the fact that JF is I'm
such a provider and I've done all this and you know I'm I've
done these renovate. He talks himself up. It's like he's just
such a man. But then we see it and you're like no no dude you're
disgusting. I'm sorry. Yeah, there were things about the house
that made me really uncomfortable and I tried >> uh so
we were sleeping in the upstairs part and >> I had some
concerns about the exposed insulation and he was like >> dismiss
it. My first concern was like does it contain asbestous and I
hope it didn't because I slept up there for a few months. But
um the exposed insulation like if you sleep in a room with that
it's going to make you sick and it started causing me to have
asthma attacks and I didn't at the time realize that it was causing
that but I would wake up like I almost >> Is this the same
one that disappeared or a different one? This is a different
one. Give me a second. I need to reset these headphones. these
headphones.
I don't know if you guys can hear me
A 10 out of 10. Now, what is that on JF's scale? It's hard to
say. Okay. It's very difficult to say what a 10 out of 10 is
for JF.
The less intelligent they are. I can't tell cuz she seems to
be able to talk at >> Seems more coherent than Mama JF.
I feel like he's the type of dude to get more attractive the
taller they are.
>> Uh maybe maybe she is quite tall. I'm trying to think
from the picture. How tall was she in this picture that they
showed?
Is she she looks to be almost his height, right? But she might
be have she might have some tall shoes on. She might have some
shoes helping out there.
But yes, he does. >> Her shoulders are higher than his.
>> They do seem to be. Yes, they do.
Is there Maybe it's perspective. Maybe there's some perspective
going on. She's a little further away. >> He seems like
the type of dude to wear the shoes with a little bit of the hidden
heel. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Some lifts. >> Those
um what is his name? >> Ronda Santis. >> Yeah. Some
D Santa shoes. Ronda Santis went next level. Okay. Ronda Santis
had like engineered shoes that he had to walk in. He had a full
wedge shoe in the >> like it's like actually impossible
to deny that that's what's going on when you look at him from
the side like waddling out during the debate >> and you
could see the crease women >> you could see the crease.
Yes. Yeah. You could see the crease. It was crazy.
>> Wow. Well, yeah, because you're a supermodel and she's
>> so So, so he showed up like that. Okay. So, when you
got So, that would have been like shocking, but good for you
if you're just, you know, I mean, what are you gonna do? You're
there. >> Yeah. Um,
did you So then he get >> God, I'm so triggered by the
Hassan stuff still. Please don't say shocking. So now >> he's
talked himself up. I know he has a >> Oh, JF's 54 >> and
she is 5'6. >> There's no way JF is 5'4 and he talks about
genetics all the time. Bro, why is he studying genetics? He should
hate genetics. God cursed him.
That's tough, man. That's That's a tough one to come back from.
It's not impossible, but it's hard. Tell him [__]
all day. >> 54 NK Beckqua. Okay. There's some divine entity
that hates whatever is at the essence of his soul. Okay. And
is is torturing it for all of existence. >> Long talked
about what is. So when you got to that house in a li I need to
know what were your what what happened in your brain. >> Um
I was like I can't wait to pop an ambient and go to sleep.
>> It was just too much to think about. But I just wasn't
ready to process it. >> Yeah. Cuz that uh so you and I
know listen I know we've talked a lot of about how the house
wasn't clean and you have said that you've cleaned a lot of that
house. I believe that you cleaned a lot house. My my talking
is not about >> Oh, I forgot to go back to the time. Oh
>> cleaniness or whatever. It was about the fact that JF
is I'm such a >> asthma attacks and I didn't at the time
realize that it was causing that but I would wake up like I almost
died of an asthma attack one night and later I confronted him
about it and I was like did you know exposed insulation can cause
respiratory issues like this and he's like no
>> and I'm like but you claim to know about fixing up houses
you know >> you're supposed to be a man I can Come
>> Yes. Okay. Um, really I've just got two more questions
this section, Holly, and then we'll take a break, but don't ask
any allure questions cuz we haven't gotten there yet. >> Okay,
Holly.
>> Okay. Um, so I just really quick too. So, you met the
kids. We're not going to use their names. We're going to do anything
identifying. Was that overwhelming for you? Because how old were
the kids when you met them? Like, so your first Welcome to Charlotte
Town. I'm fat. Here's my dumpy house. And these are my children.
What?
>> This This lady's got the the snarking soul. Okay. Holy
[__] She's not She's not going to let JF leave this
interview >> What was it like for you? Like that must have
been overwhelming. >> Well, I like kids, so I was excited
to meet them, but when I did, I was really let down because immediately
I noticed something was off.
>> they didn't act like normal kids >> because from
what you from what I gathered they they to you they seem severely
like disabled almost like uh like if okay we can throw out a
lot of oh she's stuck in the toddler >> wild labels but
like nonverbal
maybe other stuff is that what you're saying like kind of like
that >> well so to be specific when I went there the girl
was three And she didn't even speak in complete sentences.
>> Like I want water or I want >> Yeah. Wait, wouldn't
that be like fairly regular development to not speak in complete
sentences at three? >> I'm pretty sure that's normal.
>> I was three and didn't even use grammar properly. Like
this. What is going on >> I handed this kid a recipe for
baking me like an omelette or for making me an omelette and he
up at three. What if
a couple
>> No, it was, you know, and I would try like I wanted
to work with them and teach them to do things. I had to teach
her to wear clothes. She was naked in the house. Totally naked.
>> Had never >> You can speak at three. Yes. But
do you speak in full sentences at three? >> What does she
mean? I had to teach them to wear clothes. Do you mean you had
to just put on clothes?
>> Uh, no. Oh, she is a She had to teach them how to So
she she was like, "Oh, well, I'll get naked and then I'll show
you how to put the clothes on." >> I feel like if the child
is three, you have to put the clothes on yourself.
>> I think kids can know how to pull clothes out. You probably
do have to dress them to go out, but like they could easily put
like a like a top on or something in the house themselves.
>> I think if they're at the age where they're wearing
a diaper, they're not going to put on a shirt if they don't have
to.
>> Yeah, but are you wearing a diaper at three? You should
be potty trained at three, right? >> I really don't know.
>> I feel like you you're potty trained at >> Worn
clothes inside the house and so I had to like try to >> That's
weird. That's so inappropriate to invite somebody into your home
with your kids naked. That is so inappropriate, JF. Jesus. >> I
mean, no, you just I mean, it's probably inappropriate to not
go dress the kids if they're just meeting the woman you're bringing
over to. Like, you should probably throw some Hey, this girl's
coming over. I'm going to try to smash. Yeah. Throw some clothes
on the kids. Throw a t-shirt on the kid. Okay,
let them Donald duck it. But like, come on, man. You got to make
an apple.
>> And they had this armchair and like she >> go
to the bathroom and then like go sit on the arm of it and like
the chair was >> She didn't wash and and she didn't have
like the proper hygiene obviously that [__] is wrong
with him. Okay, so that's that would have been overwhelming.
And listen, we're not making fun of the children at all. This
is not their >> No, not at This is just the reality of
you need to understand what 10 out of 10 walked into. >> And
imagine, you know, like that would
>> that'd be awful cuz you can't go home either. Like what
do you do? And you don't have people there. >> Yeah. And
like the the I would try to work with the kids and teach them
things. And the boy is now three and he like is just learning
to say like he'll hold up a ball and be like ball like he
>> That's maybe a little regressed.
>> Can you stop snarking on his kids?
>> Can we just snark on JF? Like JF's like a father. >> You
could even Yeah, you could say he's a father. Doesn't take care
of his kids. doesn't dress as kids, but then just be like, "Yeah,
you wouldn't believe how these kids are." >> This kid's
going to grow up and watch this podcast and just listen to this
woman talk on how, "Oh, he just started learning how to say ball
at three." >> A few months ago, JF was like, "Oh, he says
about 10 words >> at three." >> Yeah, that's not
normal. But >> he's not potty trained. He's not potty trained.
Like, he's not he doesn't even
>> seem aware. Yeah. Now, does JF does he he he kid was
himself holding this ball of his ball?
Good lord, man. >> This is reminding me of that there's
like a movie or uh Yeah, it's a movie I watched on vacation one
time and it's a bunch of
raising a normal baby. >> Mhm. And they just sit around
and talk about how this bab this smartest baby this baby was
a fast walker. And it just Do you know what movie? Does anyone
know what movie I'm talking about? >> Are you talking about
Three Men in a >> Is that what it is? >> I don't
know.
>> It might be. >> That's a movie I've heard of.
>> The The woman who births the baby, she dips and she's
like the normal one. So it's the the
left raising him. The duck dad says, "Is it I am Sam?"
>> Maybe. I have to I have to figure it out. Either way.
>> This is what it feels like just watching these people
talk about this baby. >> Very strange. >> He's obviously
aware that his children have some like some something going on.
Uh he must and because he's got his PhD and he's really good
with, you know, education and all that. He probably he spends
a lot of time helping. He understands that there's some issues
or >> Uh he told me I'm the problem. All right. Well, that's
not helpful.
>> And he said their IQ's are at least 115,
>> but can't say all at three. >> And don't use toilet
paper.
>> Use the chair of the arm. I mean, whatever. I guess
that could be just lazy kid, but I mean, also, you would expect
that he would be correcting that. >> Wait, why? How is
he judging his three-year-old toddler's IQ at 115? Is he just
like averaging IQ's? My IQ is 155. My wife's IQ is 75. It's about
115. Is that what he's doing here or
>> that behavior? >> Yeah. And when I got there the
first time, the girl, her hair was like in dreadlocks. It had
It looked like it hadn't been brushed. And I started trying to
brush it and I had to cut out like 3 in sections of hair that
was
>> The poor little girl. She did. She must have hated getting
your hair brushed
>> Like it I would hurt >> at first. Yeah. But she
did to some degree to the extent she could. She did bond with
me and I'm very fond of her.
>> to the extent she could.
>> She's, you know, I did volunteer with special ed kids
at one point, so I kind of like I like them, >> right?
You know, >> good. Well, that is lucky for
>> Why? Why does that sound not 100%.
>> I don't I don't uh >> she volunteered. So, I hope
you like them. So, I kind of like them.
>> So, I kind of like I like them.
>> Like I volunteered with a bunch of kids and you know
they're okay. >> So, I kind >> they're all right.
You know, it is what it is. >> That's good. Well, that
is lucky for JF because you could have been somebody with a short
temper. >> You could have like he put them at such risk
by brain by inviting the stranger at home.
>> It's like especially with the difficulties they're having.
>> Okay. Um Holly, I'm going to let I'm going to jump off
for a second and let you do the talking and you can read some
comments. I'll be right back.
>> Come back. We're going to go into lean into start leaning
into the Allora stuff. Okay. >> And you're okay. You're
okay. 10 out of >> You're feeling comfortable. Okay. All
right. Okay, I'll be right back. >> Okay, sounds good.
So, we do have some questions from the a >> Wait, has Holly
been talking this whole time? I feel like it's >> Yeah,
I feel like it's been that other girl the whole time has just
been like totally snarking on JFK. I figured >> I need
a friend like this. >> I need a friend like this >> so
I can have a a podcast like this where I can literally snark
on people's kits or some [__] >> Just trick
people into coming on
the most like >> inappropriate [__] Yeah, >> keep
them
while you were talking not to interrupt the flow of conversation
because I mean we're all
>> this woman does this woman know anything about JF. It's
like, sorry. It's like you just came into something you're not
qualified to handle. It's like, I don't want to interrupt the
below of conversation.
And uh >> Oh, no. She does know. These are the two women
who covered the monastery thing. >> With her before. They've
been following >> I'm just laughing at how she came in.
It's just like she's just like putting the accents on every word.
I I just feel like I I read uncomfortable, but I wouldn't be
shocked. Okay. This is the Real Housewives of Alberta. They probably
know. I mean, there's there's not many cases, not many cold cases
in Canada, okay? They have they have the slim pickings, and of
course, they're going to be familiar with every detail of the
JFK case. >> 100%
locked in on what you're talking about. It's really interesting
to hear your interpretation of what happened because you're a
person that actually was there. I mean, we're just seeing tidbits
and we're just watching uh things on the internet and then of
course our interview with him and and all that stuff. So, we
only have a very
>> view, right? So, that's why we're so grateful that you're
here.
>> Um, so first uh question or comment is from Savage Machines
and they said 10 out of 10 is a great screen name. So, I would
keep that.
>> Uh, and then this is back when you were talking about
the birth certificate.
>> So, is the reason why you kept his name off the birth
certificate so that he had no legal recourse to the child?
>> Well, I just >> some of the questions get really
inappropriate. I'm guessing they do. Yeah, but we're on kick
and I mean, we could just cover this whole thing. So, even if
they do get really inappropriate, I see no reason to slow down
or stop. Um, we could just we can just, you know, chastise, shake
our heads. Disavow that question. That's a very disturbing question.
just um didn't want the kid to end up with him if I
>> Okay, fair fair enough. Because I I don't either.
>> Yeah, because he neglects his kids. They have cavities
and >> he doesn't brush their teeth.
>> Well, and you were talking about how the children they're
they're saying one word sentences and they don't understand communication.
Would that partially be from the fact that they were neglected
and ignored and not spoken to?
>> Um, you know, I don't know. I think there are different
reasons people can have something like that. >> But yeah,
neglect can cause
things like >> Yeah, because from what we understand, he
spends basically all day and night online or coding >> and
then sleeping during the day. He's mentioned that he's trained
his kids to kind of sleep during the day and >> be up at
night, but if they're up at night with him, he's on the computer.
>> He's got his kids on a night shift. Did I just hear
that correctly?
That sounds like abuse.
>> Uh yeah, >> that sounds like child abuse. >> My
kids work the night shift. You know, they don't hate it. They
don't hate it. I mean, it could be Yeah, I guess it could be
child abuse. I don't know. Um does he not have a kid who goes
to school? How does he manage that? Like, do do none of these
kids go to >> I have no idea. Right. You would think if
he's trained them to sleep during the day that they're being
homeschooled.
>> And that sounds like some sort of psychological experiment
that you're doing raising your kids nocturnal.
>> Somebody said night school. >> Night school. Jeez.
>> H
Jesus. >> So, what kind of interaction is that with your
father? So, that's to me horrifying. Um, so first major takeaway,
JF's baby mamas would not trust him to take care of their kids.
Noted.
>> That's true. How many him? >> How'd she open her
legs for him? >> Um, Stockholm syndrome.
>> I'm already feeling like
maybe you're also kind of abusive.
>> To his children. Why did you stay in that situation?
Why are you like 2 years later coming out and being like, "Oh,
yeah. He's like a horrible father." Oh, it would be like two
years later, isn't it? It's like exactly two years later.
I didn't think about that. Yeah, it's a weird timing. Wait, it's
2 years later and she's had the kid for a month. She was with
this guy for like 19 20 months. 23 months.
>> quick maths. >> Yeah. What the What? What the
wait? She was just a part of that situation. She's been a part
of raising those kids. >> She's like, "Wow, I want to have
a baby with this guy." >> I Yeah. And had the baby at the
end. And then at the end she's like, "Oh, this is the reason
I didn't put his name on the birth certificate. He's a terrible
>> All the things you've been living through for a year,
two years now. >> It's called love, you idiot." My bad.
That's true. >> That's weird. That's very bizarre. >> Just
10 out of 10. You do have because you had documents from immigration,
right? He had >> I didn't have documents. Okay. You But
you did. You You know for sure he had >> Oh, yeah. I had
documents from He was going to immigrate to the US. Yeah. I had
those. So he had three wives, right? >> Or like legal wives.
And then he had kids with one of them. >> Um Yeah. He had
a son with uh the woman he was married to in North Carolina.
>> And then a daughter too, right? >> Yeah. With
after he left
>> North Carolina with a big legal thing. Can he get
>> Can he be responsible for this?
>> The answer is no. Uh, Loki Koko asked, "Wait, did she
say earlier that she left after getting pregnant?" Yeah, she
left him after getting pregnant after being with him for 2 years.
Essentially, she left about a Well, hold on. Wait, wait, >> They
did not put him on her birth >> Hold on. I screwed up the
timeline. So, there' be like 14 months and then the 9 months
of her being pregnant thereabouts. And then the kid is one month
old as of their when they're shooting this, I believe. >> So,
one month then minus 9. So, about 14 months she lived with him
and then she got pregnant at the end and then she left. Yeah,
>> she went and was pregnant somewhere
>> Yeah, she went back home to the US and she's pregnant
in the US. >> After she had the baby, he wants to know,
"Did you at least put my name on the birth certificate?" And
she said, >> Yeah, she did not. And then he was like, "Well,
I'm going to keep from other women until you do." And I assume
I assume she took that under advisement. >> North Carolina,
he went back to Quebec >> and he met a woman online and
um had a daughter with her. >> Okay. Just want to make
sure that Okay. So, so there's those two kids, your child, and
then the two that he has. So, the only child he has contact with
is
with a missing mother.
>> Uhhuh. Yeah. >> Yeah. That's shocking. Okay. Continue
on, Holly. Sorry. >> So, this comment here um was about
when you were talking about having preeclampsia.
Uh there was a lot of support saying, "We're really sorry to
hear that you had to go through that."
>> I'm sorry. That's just a weird thing. Maybe they just
don't get I don't know if there's like They must get some viewership.
Just to me it's like weird that they're like, "Hey, this was
like when you were talking about your medical issues." Somebody
said sorry to hear that. I just want to let you know that that
Okay, that's a weird thing. >> Yeah, there was a lot of
comments about that. So, everyone in the chat really >> Let's
take it back to where you were telling me about how you almost
died after your pregnancy. >> Feel awful that you had to
go through that and then have it exacerbated by a lovely partner.
>> Comment. Uh, good move not giving JF any leverage. That
would be the during the birth certificate conversation. So good
for you for for doing that and digging your heels and standing
ground. >> Jacock can't even imagine how that's a wholesome
moment. He's like, "Did they just air out the fact that she had
a hard time?" >> No, I'm saying on her. >> They brought
one chat comment up from like 20 minutes ago to be like, "When
they when you were talking about how your life was, people are
like, "Oh, that sucks." >> Yeah, the empathy. >> Yeah,
letting her know. >> I I I feel like she either would have
been watching the chat or it's just weird to bring it up 20 minutes
later. But hey, >> you know what then? >> Whatever.
uh when you were talking about how he was threatening that he
was talking to other women, that's his normal pattern of behavior.
Uh going back to the queue of you know women. >> So uh
>> and when we were together I asked him I was like do
you have a cue of women waiting if >> you know something
happens between us and he was like oh no I'll never be with another
woman after you. You're the one you're special and >> God
is so gross. And I believed them
kind of we we have all everybody everybody watching has eaten
somebody's because it makes us feel better about our situations.
>> So that's terrible though. >> Okay. And uh so
they were talking about the gift or not the gift the birth certificate.
Um JF doesn't strike me as a guy who would have been this big
on government documentation of having his name on the birth certificate
because he's such an edgy guy and
>> It's interesting to hear that he was so passionate about
something like that. Then tying into that, Jeff, this is all
the birth certificate conversation. Jeff sounds like the issue
is ownership. That's why he wanted the name and that's in from
Tom C2.
That's his personal opinion. >> And then there was the
Oh, damn. You're interviewing his ex. >> Yeah, we are.
Then there's a question here. I think you I don't know if you've
answered already, but what was JF's
>> Um, well, I have autism and he claims that he has a
>> Mhm.
Mhm. >> What made him so attractive? What made him so appealing
to you? I'm >> Well, he he displayed a love for
>> Yeah. That's So, he loves that.
I don't know. Listen, nobody would deal with her autism. She's
apparently a 10 out of 10 supermodel. Nobody would deal with
her autism. We're supposed to believe this. >> We're supposed
to. She wanted to be with somebody who fetishized her. That's
kind of weird. >> Probably. Yeah. She wanted to be with
somebody who she found out about because he had apparently
like allegedly murdered his wife. So, we're not dealing with
like a normal, stable, awesome person here. There's a lot of
things stacking up. Okay. >> I find out a dude murdered
his wife potentially
and that he's got like a fetish for BPD women. Probably not going
to go meet up with him. >> Probably.
Maybe not. Might be a bad
>> Autism. So, we kind of bonded over that and um I like
that he was intelligent.
>> well, he does listen, I mean, I would not hate on him.
Like people I think some people think I'm just like I' I've got
like tunnel vision. I just hate this guy. No, no, no. He inserted
himself into our stream. First of all, we were just looking at
the case very lightly. One time we would have never talked about
this guy again after that day if he had not join inserted himself
into the comments and started to, >> you know, make it
into something it didn't need to be. Um, and then the more I
looked at it and the more I looked at everything, I just thought
the way you talk about is disgusting and the fact that you don't
care where the mother of your children >> is. And then
that's my obsession. That's my obsession. I want to find the
truth out for Laura and for her kids. But um, also to protect
other women, and he just keeps putting himself out there and
talking about how he needs to >> mate with people and spread
his semen all over. He needs to stop. He needs a >> You
know, I was when I was with him, I was just kind of thinking,
>> did you just hold up scissor fingers >> A vasectomy.
Oh, no. It was a It was a little karate chop. Okay. I thought
she hand held up like the scissors there. She did not. >> I
was when I was with him, I was just kind of thinking, well, his
love for me will win out. He'll let go of all that stuff and
just realize that it's silly. But, you know, >> yeah, but
you are you are you should be loved like that. So, it's don't
it's not too silly. He's the idiot. And he did lose a really
great woman. >> Um, so that that actually is a good segue
to Mr. Scott Awesome sent us a Rumble rant. >> This is
all his fault. >> That says, "This JF series was not my
fault." It was all your fault. You literally started it, >> Mr.
Scott. Awesome.
>> Yes, it is fault.
>> So, 10 out of 10. Are you taller than JF? I think we
saw that. >> How How tall are you? >> Well, I'm actually
5'5. >> What? How do you look so pictures? >> I had
heels on. >> So, how tall do you think he is in real >> He
says >> not what he says. >> No, no, no. I knew that
was weird. Stop with that. >> Wait, what does he No, I
got to Hold on. I need to know what he says. I don't just need
to know what she actually thinks he is. I need to know what he
>> It's important information how >> incredibly important
>> about my height. >> I see these little They're
all little always. Okay. >> So, 10 out of 10. I don't blame
you for never finishing one of Jeff's shows because very few
people can.
>> I've tried. It's It's hard. And that's why we have people
who watch for us and take notes and then give us the notes because
we can't stand him. >> No. Um
>> uh then when we were talking about the house when you
first showed up uh the comment is is he a freaking [__]
There were children in that house. >> We thought the same
thing. >> That's why we did the we posted that video. It
wasn't because it wasn't we're not making fun. Listen, if you're
poor, right? Like if you're poor, we get it. That's fine. That
part's fine. He sits there and says like I'm this big. I'm a
provider. And that's where I'm like, "Oh, okay. Let's look at
what you're providing." Yep. But >> well, and one of the
ways that he won me over before I went to Canada was he told
me that he made like seven or eight thousand a month and he started
lovebombing me with money. >> Love bombing or
>> or did do you just like money? >> Well, also like
is that I'm sorry. Is that like crazy $7 or $8,000 a month? Like
I that's a respectable living. That's not a bad living. But it's
not like that's like worldbreaking money. That's like that's
like okay. That's I don't even know if that's like raising a
family comfortably with two like on a single income money. That's
like kind of running it tight on a single income with that amount
of money amount of that amount of money. >> It's like not
even crazy. >> Do you call that lovebombing?
You're just saying he showered you with what gifts or he showered
you with financial stability?
He showered her with saying, "I make about $7,000 a month. >> I
pay all my bills. He lovebombed me with
being a financially stable adult
who's horrible at raising kids." >> I don't think he love
bombed you. You were sleeping with the asbestous or whatever.
How do you say it?
>> Uh the the the insulation, the exposed insulation. Yeah,
that was a part of the love bombing. Okay. That was the hot and
>> So much money that he didn't cover it.
>> Like he would send me
way you just said that sounded real gold to agree. I'm not going
to lie. >> Oh, hold on. He would send me $1,000. Okay,
that's No, no, no. That's okay. That's love bombing. That's a
lot. That's a pretty big financial
>> Apparently, he sent her $1,000. >> That's love
bombing.
>> Hey, in this economy, >> it sounds like he probably
sent her $1,000 to buy a plane ticket. Listen, if you're in the
chat right now and you want to send me $1,000, I will tell you
I love you. Okay, that you will be sufficiently lovebombing me
right now. Okay, go ahead. Send me a,000 bucks, >> you
can send me $1,000 and I will humiliate you and call you poor.
>> Uh, gross. But also, hey, if somebody's into that, speaking
of guys, if you want to not be humiliated or called port, you
can go ahead. You could sub to the channel. All right, you buy
a sub on kick, you can give some subs on kick, you can buy a
TTS message. You can go over to the Patreon. patreon.com/jdlk.
You can sign up there. Okay. Appreciate all of the help, all
of the support. Let's continue on with the stream.
>> Sent a woman $20,000.
>> That if Darius sent a woman $20,000, that is love bombing.
>> Darius did not send her $20,000.
Well, I think he spent 20k on the the vacation. They went on
a vacation together and he spent $20,000 going on that vacation,
>> I think. Yes, they went to Canada. in that situation.
That might be like a love bombing vacation. >> That was
definitely love bombing. And it also didn't work. And she also
just left him immediately once they finished.
>> Oh, you didn't you didn't get a chance to see it. I
covered all this on stream. >> Is it the Is it the Hannah?
>> It's the Hannah. Yeah. And it's like the second time
in a row. >> Getting piped all the time. >> Yeah.
Hannah's getting piped right now. Yeah. That of of getting piped
fame. Yes. It's that Hannah. And he was just he was like crying
about how she like used him and left him. But he he was like,
"No, she wasn't just using me for money. I would just like sometimes,
you know, she'd message me and say, "I'm hungry." And I was like,
"Yeah, I'm trying to [__] you, so I'll pay for your
food." And he's like, "But she wasn't using me for money at all."
>> Did they
She would message He would send her money to get food or he would
go out and get food with her. >> No, he would send her
money cuz he was living in Texas and she was in Arizona. So he
would send her money to get her food and he just don't It was
so funny watching him not put it together in this video where
he's complaining about how >> did Barry's become rich
>> uh when he was doing those those shooty streams with
Zena and he was getting like 1,500 viewers sometimes like 2,000
viewers. That's a lot of money. That's like a couple hundred
bucks an hour. >> The thought would never cross my mind
to message Darius in hopes for money. I just imagine if I'm like
hungry, I'll message Darius and then he can like show me his
room and I'll lose my appetite.
>> And that's how he can help me fix that >> It should
strike you though because poor people happen to be like people
who can't don't know how to manage their money at all are exactly
the people you could go to and say, "Hey, give me some money."
And they'll like hand you over a bunch of money because they
have no concept of it. >> Yeah, that really sucks for him.
I'm sorry that happened. >> He uh I think he kind of bankrupted
himself. He was going to get that glider anyway and probably
kill himself. though. Thank god that she bankrupted him. Okay,
you remember the hang glider thing, the paraglider that he was
going to get? Like he probably was just going to end his life
if she didn't bankrupt him. It was altruistic fining. Okay. White
hat fin.
>> Yeah. I He's very lucky that she cared about him that
much to take all that money to drain his bank account. Yep. >> Cuz
Okay. The way you just said that sounded real gold diggy. I'm
not going to lie. But when you told me that you you said you
like the fact that he was secure financially,
but he wasn't you weren't literally gold digging. That wasn't
actually >> No, he just made me think, oh, he can take
care of a family and he's like, I can take care of you for the
rest of your life. >> But as the relationship progressed,
he started cont. >> Miracle says, "Don't let JF's ex know
about Darius."
>> I think that's exactly what you guys should do. You
That would be very funny. >> You should specifically show
her in the direction of Darius. basically like try to find this
woman's contact info so you could get it to Darius for the content.
All right. >> I think Darius absolutely makes more money
than JF then if that's the case, >> Yeah, Darius definitely
makes more money than JF if he streams any amount. >> No,
I'm just Don't do that. >> He definitely does >> predicting
that. Like
>> I would ask him questions about like adult things we
need to deal with like how about a life insurance policy so I'm
taken care of when you die of a heart attack from being fat,
you And he's like, I he said he doesn't believe in life insurance
policy, >> but he believes in birth certificate. He believes
in He believes in everything when it when it works out for him.
Speaking of fact, you did send me a video. I think we should
just real quick while we're getting into this. Send me a video.
Oh, okay. Couple more. So, when you're talking about sleeping
in that horrible room, the the chat lit up. You are 100% right.
Maybe not asbestos, but definitely um >> that pink fiber
glass fibers do cause breathing problems, emphyma, asthma. And
then of course, no vapor barrier. That's disgusting. That's one
thing we noticed in the video. >> And then uh the final
comment. >> Oh, wait. She had a video. Are we going to
see that video in this podcast? I hope if there's a video of
the inside of Jeff's house, I get to see it. Very would like
to see that. >> Reviewed it before on their stream. >> Okay.
Well, we'll have to go find it. >> That was concern about
the insemination over here is >> Yeah, that's good. Good
comments, chat. Okay. Sorry. All right. Can I go now? >> Yeah.
Now, go ahead.
>> I just want to make sure. I feel like I'm panicking
a little bit because I'm like I don't want her baby to need her.
Not right now because she's it's newborn so I don't know how
long we're going to have her. Um so you were saying you did tell
me that JF did have one weird habit. Uh what does he do? And
you did send me a video and I'm going to I'm going to show that
video after you explain. I want you to you don't just just tell
us what his habit was. It was weird. Right. So a lot of nights
he would like wake up in the night and go cook himself a meal
in the kitchen. And he reminded me like if you've ever seen Charlotte's
Web, if you've seen the scene where Templeton the rat goes to
the fair and eats everything, that was
in the kitchen at night.
>> That's terrible. >> And he um he was had no shame
about it. I can't You know what? I did I did upload it, but is
it
>> and uh that there would be dirty dishes everywhere for
me to clean up. >> Oh, it's so disrespectful. So, he did
like to pig out and gorge on food. Um, did he did he have good
eating habits? So like he liked vegetables and stuff. Did he
>> dishes every
she's never lived in a house with kids or with a man? >> Uh,
with like other people that she wasn't dependent on probably.
>> Yeah, people in general. Oh my god, there were dirty
dishes.
>> Yeah, there you kids. Yes, there's going to be dirty
dishes. One of them doesn't put clothes on themselves. Like absolutely.
They're expecting her to like clean up and and she's like, "Well,
where where like where are your where are my parents? Like who's
cleaning up? I feel like that's what's going on >> Why
do you think he was sending you
Maid service, >> right? He like made a little bit of an
effort to lose weight, but it didn't
>> That's okay. What about the kids? Did they Does he did
he feed them really well or like good >> No, they eat like
McDonald's and buttered noodles and he he buys them those. the
boy won't eat meat and stuff. So he buys him the Herabibo gummies
and he's like I was like those aren't healthy and he goes they
have protein in
>> He doesn't actually think that. So he thinks that does
he actually think that? Does he actually think that that's is
a good source of protein? Is he serious? >> Uh well he
presented vitamins >> uh like gummy bears, not even gummy
>> Gummy bears. >> Haribo gummy bears where apparently
he's like, "Oh, it's got protein in them." Okay. There are gummies
uh like fruit snack gummies that come with real fruit juice that
have
>> I don't think there's any such thing as a protein gummy.
>> Otherwise, I would have been on that. >> I checked.
There are two grams of protein per serving. >> Yeah, probably
not a good calorie to protein gram ratio. Okay. >> Absolutely
not. >> Gelatin. Yeah, gelatin almost certainly has some
uh some protein in it, but if you're having a sweetened like
candy gelatin, it's probably not going to be that good.
>> Presented it to me as like a serious >> What the
is wrong with him? >> My god. Speaking of gummies. >> Hey
guys, it's May time. >> Gross. Why? Why did they do that?
>> Why? Why did they just do this?
>> That's horrifying.
That is horrifying. >> I didn't like that.
>> Sorry, Holly. I had to do it because home really hates
it and I love it. Um, okay. So, back to the questions. You got
me all distracted now. Let's get back to the part. All right.
So, wait. So, okay. So, we now we know that this house is disgusting.
We know your reaction. Um, and everything. That's got to be a
lot. So,
we're going to lean a bit into the Laura. So, what when you got
to the home, was there any items that clearly u belonged to Aurora
in the home? >> Yeah, her wardrobe, her clothes, and everything
was in the closet and it looked like she was still living there.
It never been touched. So, so when he said he took three days
off, uh, 3 days off to clean the house and get rid of all your
stuff, that's a lie.
>> I think so. >> Well, obviously if your clothes
are still there and everything's there, what a weirdo, too. What
a weirdo to invite you in the home like that. Okay, so that's
that's uncomfortable. What did Okay, sorry. Sorry. Uh, >> there
was cameras in the pictures in the photos that we have from the
homeowner that bought the house. There's cameras in the living
room and a camera in the bedroom, right? >> You were aware
of these cameras. Now, did JF tell you why those cameras were
He said they were there because Allora was crazy and he was afraid
she was going to kidnap the children. And I was like, why would
anyone kidnap those two? >> Okay. Well, well, I mean, she's
such a
>> Why would anybody ever kidnap your dirt kids, your dirty,
filthy, disgusting
>> They don't even put on clothes. That one only says ball.
Just now learning how to say ball. >> Ain't nobody want
those things. I mean, well, it wouldn't be kidnapping to her
kids. Like, he's weirdo. But
that house is tiny. >> He didn't
>> he us he gives words his own definition like kidnapping.
And
>> he says, >> he says, "I stole Bitcoin."
>> Well, um, let's talk about what I did. He gave me Bitcoin.
And then when I didn't, uh, put his name on the birth certificate,
he asked for the Bitcoin back. And I said, >> I said, "No,
I'm not giving it back to >> Yeah. because he already know
he's not going to pay child support. He's made that abundantly
clear on other streams over and over for years. He won't pay
child support. So, okay. So, that's crazy. So, okay. Question.
During the rel um >> did the kids ever mention Allora?
Do you They ever talk about their mommy or >> The boy's
not capable. He doesn't know what a mom is even or >> he
was he was just 10 months right when >> Yeah. And he doesn't
he doesn't know his own name hardly. The girl um JF. So the girl
started calling me mama right away. And JF said, "Oh, she wanted
as in mama >> No, just like >> like mama. That's
so >> as in her mother and um you know, >> right
away. >> Yeah. And JF said, "Oh, she likes you. She wants
to call you that." But I kind of wonder if he put her up to it.
>> What a weirdo. That's weird. And he was fine with that.
He didn't think there was any boundary issues. Like
it's fine.
>> No. He was like, "You're their mom now." >> That's
crazy. Um,
did JF ever give you like a a warning? Like, did he ever say,
"Hey, listen." So, Laura's like, "She's obviously taken off.
I don't think she'll ever come back, but if she does, this is
what we're going to do." That's weird. See, cuz I feel like any
normal person in that situation would have had a plan like um
>> Okay, I'm back. >> You know, because she could
>> she could have returned, right? If she if that was really
if she really just ran away. Um, I did want to show you this
and this video here, I think. Oh, >> right. Before you
do that, we did get a $10 Rumble rant. >> Thank you from
Swampy Boy. Uh, shout out to the
Oh, do we have to get on Rumble? Are people Are there a lot of
people on Rumble now? >> I told you that >> we're
going to have to get on Rumble. Okay. All right.
Listen, we're already I We're already multireaming with Twitch.
We might as well have the Rumble. >> Here's one donation
on Rumble. Do I have to go there? >> $10. Listen, they
put super chats on Rumble. There are still are not super chats
on Kick. Okay, they added kicks. Why would you add, by the way,
>> can somebody explain to me why you would add kicks >> to
the platform and not super chats?
>> Okay. All right. I get it. Yes, that is >> That
is me. But >> the Wance, Andy, PPP, and the casino. RIP
Mama JF. >> Yes. Thank you. Um, okay. So, I'm going to
play this video. Um, where JF's talking about Allora. >> I
don't remember where I was going with this question. I'll ask
you the question after we watch it just because it's I can't
remember what the question was. So let's see.
Oh, and here's a question. I think you >> not that one.
It's >> left like how was how are things emotionally in
the house? >> Oh, it it was always a good uh good relationship
between her and I and so things were not different. She had already
left for trips like this. So uh it was not the first time and
it was something that she was planning many weeks in advance.
I remember in the last month uh in the last month before she
went she we constantly went at Canadian Tire and other places
because she wanted some stuff for her trip. She wanted a little
seat for the forest. She wanted a knife. She wanted this and
that. So we we were shopping a lot and she she were really she
was really intentional about this trip. >> Okay. So that's
what he told us
>> about disappearance. Um and he says in there that that
she's done this before. Has he told you that he she had um gone
on these trips before? trips like uh going away, running away.
>> Well, okay. So, see so he said that he ran she ran away
from him. He didn't say they're like planned adventures of
>> Okay. Can I ask um what he told you about the experience?
I I I know you were like do part two. No, we can't. We got to
get it. What did he tell you? Um everybody that's watching, get
ready. You're about to get upset. What did he tell you about
>> Okay. All right. There's been so many upsetting things
said so far. I just can't imagine what is this that is going
to apparently be earthshattering. >> Well, actually just
tell us about that drive. Tell us about that drive and then you
can tell us about what he told you about where she went.
>> So when you were driving in Alberta, he you'd been here
now. This is your second trip here, right? Or was that still
first? And he and he >> he it's late at night. You're driving
down a railroad. >> Maybe Hold on. Maybe they went to
>> I I told Sherry about Drumheller last night and she
was just not impressed. Yeah, the place with the fossils. >> With
the what? with the fossils. I was like, "We could go we could
go to Drum Heller. We could like look at these f you're like
good. Oh, you want to go for a hike? Why would I want to go for
a
>> I just I didn't even know what you were trying to do.
You were like, "We can find fossils." And I was like, "Are you
telling me I need to work out?" I I had no idea what the rhyme
or reason. I'm like, "If he wants to take me somewhere, wouldn't
it be a cruise? Wouldn't it be on a beach?" This mother showed
me like the the bads >> brownest
mountain and then was talking about works. It's like the badlands.
They going down a big valley. It's kind of like the Grand Canyon
but really >> this said we can go hike and dig. >> Okay.
All right. Yeah. >> I want to do something special with
you. Like what the
>> I Okay. I did not say it was going to be special. She
improvised that comment. That was not me. >> I am improvising
cuz why? I don't know >> that was not me. I didn't say
that [__] Okay. I just thought it was funny if JF
took his
girlfriend to do this. >> Yeah. Evil. I think you're supposed
to dig if if this talking about fossils, find fossils.
I'm like, we're going to go hiking and digging.
>> Um, hold on. It's not like the same though. Hold on.
Let Let me Let me find this in uh Let me find this here real
>> You want to You want to know another fun thing that
he said we could do?
One time after going through like one of those automatic car
washes, he's like, "Oh, we could do a really fun thing and go
find like one of those vacuums and like vacuum my car together."
>> Shut up. Oh my god. Okay, never mind. I thought I was
going to go look up the the what do you call it? The Badlands
in from how I'm just going to play on the >> Convince like
your you know how you convince like your little sibling. Oh my
god, it's going to be so much fun if you go like clean my room.
Like >> this wasn't even this wasn't even a crazy thing.
I was like, "Oh, I remember my family used to go with like four
cars to the same car wash and we'd all wash our cars at the same
time and play music and like >> No, I know what >> and
jam. I was like, "Oh, we could go do that. I haven't done that
in so long." And she was like, "Did you just ask me to clean
your car? [__] you." >> I like the way I said
it.
>> Okay. It wasn't weird. It wasn't weird when I said it.
Okay. >> I swear to God. >> This man that you like,
you know, kind of still getting to know, >> right? and
he decides this is a good moment to tell you what >> he
said like it was silent. It was really eerie out of nowhere.
He's like I used to beat the Lord.
>> Your family had car cleaning parties. No, like every
two weeks we just go to the the what do you call it? The car
wash and we just all do it together cuz then you have like four
people like vacuuming or something at the same time. You could
use like two of the vacuums at this place. It would just go like
way faster and it was just something we all did at the same time
for whatever reason. I don't know, man. He got a big >> It
was good.
>> He used to beat Laura. Yes. And Okay. What did you >> Also,
I don't discount the possibility that it was a way to get the
kids to actually be interested in going and helping with like
cleaning. So, is like the kids who are vacuuming and >> I
had to explain to him how Oh, it sounds like your parents convinced
you guys to clean the cars for them. >> That's basically
what it was. Yeah. >> You do like terrifying.
>> I uh acted calm. >> And you did. Did you say how
or why or >> I I did start asking questions. Um I was like,
"Well, how often?" You know, how hard and he said as hard as
he could. At least once a week. I think more than >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I missed I missed critical contact,
right? >> And he
he it's late at night. You're driving down a railroad. >> With
this man that you like, you know, kind of still getting to know,
>> And he decides this is a good moment to tell you what
>> he said. Like it was silent. It was really eerie. Out
of nowhere, he's like, "I used to beat Allora."
>> He used to beat Christ. >> And Okay. >> Used
to beat Mama JF. What the >> What did you do? Like is that
>> I uh acted calm >> and you did you say how or
why or >> I I did start asking questions. Um I was like,
"Well, how often? You know, how hard?" And he said as hard as
he could. At least once a week. I think more than
>> How hard? >> That's a wild thing to say.
I beat I beat Mama JF. How hard? As hard as I >> which
I'm sorry, but you know that means that he hits like a [__]
>> I guess. So, yeah, Mama JF never came on stream looking
marked up at all. So, yeah. I don't know. Very strange. >> Driving
down a rural road at night that he beat Laura severely at least
once a >> Did he tell you why though? Like, why? Like was
it just like hey it's Tuesday time to get your feet on. Like
what what what was the reasons behind that? >> He said
because she would call him a >> Wait, what? >> Okay,
there's that big that was a big drop right there. >> There's
so many questions I have. First of all, when did you find out
that he beat her?
Did you get pregnant and like did you [__] him and
get pregnant after finding that out? Like >> I don't think
so. >> Do we know the timeline?
>> No. And what did you do after finding out it's because
she called him a >> and why did she call him a and now
you have this guy? So like realistically is this why you don't
have your name on the birth certificate or or his name rather?
>> Right? Like like why? Hold on. She called you a and
you beat the out of her. Like why did she why did >> why
did you leave him with children? >> Listen it was them
or me. Okay. It was it was them or my kid. He gives them gummies
with protein on a nocturnal
sleep schedule, taking them to night school. Not concerning at
all. >> This is a crazy situation. >> You thought
they would calm her down, right? Is that what you said? >> He
um
so he explained he would beat her like that. And um I was like,
"Oh, okay." And he was like, "I knew you'd >> What a creep."
>> And he said he's like, "I had to do that. I had no choice."
And at that moment I was like, "Oh, he killed her." Because I
think he was telling me that to test my reaction to that. And
the next thing he was going to do was tell me he and be like,
"I had no choice. That's what I had to do." Holy, I'm so glad
that you got away because that is terrifying. I do believe he
was testing the waters. That to me seems like it. I mean, I've
done that. Not with murder and not with missing people, but I've
admitted like, you know, some you're not proud of with your new
partner and you're like, "Hey, you test the water, right? You
say something without going full crazy." So, okay. So, that is
really upsetting. So everybody in the chat I can see the chats
like now. Yes, this is now confirmed that JF has admitted to
beating her repeatedly because she constantly called him >> and
this stuff she'd been doing that for years. That wasn't something
new. She did that back when he his dad died. She >> Yeah,
at his dad's funeral.
>> Wait, what? >> Are we saying Mama JF accused him
of being a for years? Cuz I didn't watch JF content. I don't
know about this. >> I am so lost right now. Yeah, apparently
Mama JF had called him a for a long
That seems odd.
Yeah, I >> um he was looking at his niece and I guess Allora
started saying he was a because of the way he was looking at
>> They had to go back
felt like that. >> No, I don't know. >> Um but but
so that that's that's a few years ago. So she'd been doing this.
She knew she knew obviously his reaction is probably not going
to be favorable now. So when I was thinking about that, I was
thinking, okay, well, what the [__] Laura? If you
flat this, why would you leave? Right. So you and I were talking
and you told
>> what the Porter Beller. So real Porttoella, how do you
not know who the real housewives of Alberta are? Okay, >> I
am I'm so mad that I recognize that that name is Portortoeller.
Now
that stupid ass goes back to Porter Beller. If it ever does in
the future, it's actually going to be disappointing to all of
us. Okay, >> hold on. If I look at the leaderboard for
gfterters, does it say, "Yeah, my my first my number one giftter
is I drink bleach nine and then it's mRNA go exploder." Okay,
that's uh very interesting. Good times will >> be that
he said that had gone the trip before the last time she left
when she reappeared on the stream um before she finally disappeared.
>> You he told you what? Where did she go? Allora um went
to a shelter for battered women I think in Montreal and she got
kicked out because there was like a trans person there and I
think it was a man that turned into a woman and she was like
you're not a real woman. So they kicked her out. >> Just
hold on. I just need everybody to hear this. So okay, so Laura
has escaped. She had to leave without the kids because he had
some cameras in the house. So she had no choice. She had no choice.
She had to leave the kids. She goes to a woman shelter. She goes
to Montreal where she knows, you know, she has a little bit of
a base of support there. I think that's why she would have picked
Montreal. She goes there and and then the the woke politics the
woke
>> caused her to get kicked out of a woman's shelter because
a man with a skirt on took priority. His feelings took priority
woman that's actually. So if if Allora does turn up dead, >> that
woman's shelter, you guys, you're just you're on alert now because
you're going to have to answer to that >> there. If that
is true, that is
>> And I love that you I appreciate that you told us this
because I think it would be really hard for you. I If it was
me, it would be hard for me to admit that he'd said these things.
>> Because it did put you in a bad spot. >> No, this
is real as this is real as you cannot kick a woman out of a homeless
shelter because she's freaking out at the sight of a trans woman.
I >> she's literally
>> But like I actually feel like that's a really that's
like maybe one of the most complex questions of like trans discourse
is how do you handle a woman's shelter where the site of somebody
with masculine features may be like very triggering to women.
Like that might be one of the few women's safe spaces. There's
like actually a real
talking about a real conversation. And we're talking about somebody
who isn't very intelligent. >> Yeah, I know. >> And
she's been brainwashed, right? She she got
brain right now. >> And she's just in that woman's shelter
where she needs to be. And they're like, "No, you got to go.
That's really
>> You just kicked a out
>> cuz she's not woke."
cancel culture is everywhere, okay? Especially the women's shelters.
>> You ja for putting um 10 out of 10 in that spot, too.
So disrespectful on so many levels. >> Yeah. And you know
it's like I'm just
Well, I'm going to have to go to therapy now. But like in my
mind I compartmentalized the stuff he would do. >> Yeah.
You had to probably. >> Yeah. And you know because like
there was a side of him I thought was in love with me and like
>> Well, he wouldn't have been all that bad. He would have
you know like he couldn't be all evil. I understand that you
fell for him and I do believe he probably has some charm or something
that he does. So that's really blocked though. Um >> and
we just we did get just another rumble rant.
>> So uh from Bond D3, thank you again Bondie for support.
>> Vondies are Bundy's our sugar daddy. >> Yeah.
Um so for $10, uh he said, "I got to match the or I'm going I'm
going to match the rumble rant JF that greasy parasite running."
>> Jesus Christ. >> Reuben donated.
>> they got kicked out. They [__] now.
Stop. Stop. Reuben. Ruben. That's enough. Okay. That's enough.
That's It's
It's brother.
>> Yeah. Thank you. Thank you, Vond. Um Okay. 10 out of
10. I have a question. Okay. So, so when you your visit, um
JF was going to go to the States with the kids and you, right?
That some point that was going to happen. That was the plan.
So the first time I went to Canada to meet him, my plan was only
to stay for two weeks and he was going to drive me back to the
US and um so we packed everything up and
>> uh drove to the border of New Brunswick and Maine and
um we tried to cross and uh they when we tried to drive through
>> they told us we were going to have to pull over and
go into the building. >> So like get questioned or whatever.
>> Yeah. Uh, and they ended up interrogating him for 8
hours. >> Holy. Oh. So, and you No. But you were stuck
with the kids, right? That whole time or what? >> Yes.
And they were screaming.
>> It was terrible. >> What did Border Patrol say
to you? This is, I think, amazing. And it makes me wonder what
Border Patrol knows
about the whole situation that RCMP here are not uh really focused
on. >> So, while they were interrogating him, they sent
one.
>> Um,
I mean, they could know about it. I just wouldn't this be I I
guess this might be really close. She hasn't gone through timeline
very often, right? But I guess this could be really close to
Mama JF's disappearance. Maybe this is around the time they actually
started questioning him about it cuz I think he went weeks or
months without getting questioned about it really. Like I think
it was like a while before the cops talked to him, wasn't it?
>> Um
yeah. Do you think the fact that he was crossing the border made
them very >> I Yeah, that's what I'm thinking is like basically,
oh, you're going to another country. No, no, no, no, no. >> Very
interesting. >> You literally have a missing person's case
right now. >> Another country with a new woman >> and
your kids.
>> Not the last one, buddy. >> An agent over to talk
to me. And at one point, one of them who was talking to JF turns
to me and he's like, "Do you know about his history? Do you know
about his >> Like, what the dude? Why are the RCMP not
like this is what me off? It takes simply like we we are we are
like what? Holly and I are wants numbered. I can't even put air
in my own tires for God's sakes. Okay.
It's not like, you know, RCMP could have figured this stuff out
and they should have him in interrogation or something. So So
they wouldn't let him in at the end. Is that what happened? They
said he's not allowed. Yeah. And it wasn't question the authentic
authenticity of his PA.
>> I think of like the notary or whatever. But like when
uh they were talking to me at the end, they were I feel like
they were trying to do an intervention because at the end they're
like, "Well, I guess you're going to go with him." >> Oh.
Oh yikes. >> They didn't want you to go, but they they
have to watch. They probably have rules. They have to stick by.
>> They can't they can't um do anything unless you say
that you want help. >> And I was like saying they're kind
of like why are they acting like this is so dire? It was like
they wanted to tell me to get away from him immediately. >> So
at that point that is before the whole he tells you he beat Aurora,
>> right? Yeah. >> Okay. So just so everybody's clear.
>> Two weeks after I arrived in Canada for the first time.
>> Yeah, that was what he did. What? That's Well, shout
out to the main border patrol people for not letting JF into
the states and for trying to warn you even though you weren't
ready to hear it. That's What did your mom say when you told
her that part? Did she say Did she say anything? Was she freaked?
She She must have been flipping out. >> Uh well, when I
they took our phones away for the eight hours when they were
interrogating him when I got my phone. >> There's no shot
this got a mother who loves her or gives a [__] about
what she's doing right now. I'm sorry. You don't make these decisions
because there's a mother with your best interest in mind out
there in the world. I mean, could it just be that she's like
rich, like super rich or something? I don't even know >> her.
She said that she was impressed by him from earning 7 to $8,000
a month. >> That's true. I thought like maybe she had rich
parents or something. Like maybe she was super sheltered, but
yeah, I don't I don't think so. Oh, this is this is tough. >> Found
back my mom had called me like 20 times and left messages and
she thought he killed me.
>> Oh my god. That was her That was her her reaction to
you being missing was that
put you down. >> Wow, that's really
good instincts, Mom. >> I got goosebumps. It makes me sad
because I panic like that with my kids, but I mean like that
is terrifying. God damn it. Now my it's gone foggy. Um okay.
So when you're in the US, so you came back or whatever. Now when
you were at the house, this is obviously the second trip back
is when when did you return again? >> In September of 2020.
Okay. So, you went there and you guys were hanging out the house.
Uh, just sort of like I don't know,
living, I guess. What were you doing >> Um, surviving.
>> Really? That's fun. I can't believe you came back. Okay.
So, you came back and that's when you got pregnant. Is this the
trip? >> No, actually, I didn't get pregnant until um December
December of 2024. >> Okay. So, you came back in December
or you came here in September 2024, >> right? And I stayed
until January of 2025. Was that the plan for you to stay that
long or did
>> was it because of chaos? >> I was allowed to be
in Canada for six months in a year. So I had been there 3
>> earlier in the year and then I was going to be there
like another 3 months or so. >> Okay. So that's her second
trip there. >> And we just had a big big thing from Fonti.
Thank you so much. >> He gifted memberships to our rumb
rumble channel. One is Fam Kazzy. You got a gift KV or JV. I
always get that wrong. Pat got your tongue. Mr. Scott. Awesome.
Even though >> this is, by the way, this like gives me
like hope for like boomer content creation that this could be
like something you do for a long period of time. Is like there's
always going to be people like everybody is used to being on
the internet now. So like there are people who've just been on
the internet their whole lives that are going to want to still
watch content on the internet like podcasts or like that. It
won't like for a while it was like oh this is something you could
do until you're like 30 and then you just hang it up, right?
And now it's like, oh, it seems like there's just going to be
content creation at every age going forward from now on where
this is going to be like a normal way of consuming content on
the internet. I think >> are we going to be like 70 in
rocking chairs
doing this? Hopefully yelling at each other. >> I hope
so. Yeah, I hope so. That'd be cool. You just have like conversations
on the internet for money all the way through your life. Yeah,
that'd be cool. >> Snarking to our 60s.
>> Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. Yeah, for sure. Dude, snarking in your 60s would be funny.
Would be hilarious. >> Oh, he's snark. >> Will you
start like Yeah. You start losing any concern for for maintaining
decorum with people. Yeah. >> This I just want to >> That's
so nice.
>> Thank you, Vondie. Okay. So, when he So, what happened
when um just were you guys planning to move when you guys I know
you the move seemed sort of spontaneous to everybody else, but
was there a plan for you guys to move right away?
>> So, so how tell me what happened that day? like child
welfare and the police come to the house in Oly PEI knock on
the door and what happened? >> Yeah. Um
JF asked them he's like do I have to let you in? and they said
yes
and
they came in and they were looking around kind of horrified
and they started talking to us and they kind of they were talking
to me and
um I don't know something I don't even remember exactly what
was said on our part but then the the social worker was like
the kids are so young and like response to how he had moved me
in so quickly
>> and did uh did did they meet the kids Um, the kids were
sleeping. Oh, >> okay. So, they didn't get to see their
development or anything. >> No, they were going to come
back like Monday or something. I think there was a Friday night,
>> right? You're going to come back Monday. >> Okay.
So, tell me how So, so, so they leave. That's obviously stresses
heightened at that point. >> What happens? How does JF
react? What happens? Like, cuz you guys left pretty >> Well,
he um started crying and he wanted to go upstairs with me and
we laid on the air mattress and he >> in the insulation
room. >> Real romantic day.
He coiled he he wrapped himself around me like a coiled snake
and was crying. >> Oh god, that's so unattractive. Okay.
>> Man up and figure out what you're going to do. Uh-huh.
>> And then what happened?
>> was like, did you make the plan like we got to get out
of here or was that his his idea? >> No. Like he decided
pretty quickly that we needed to leave and he wanted me to pack
everything up and >> Well, that lucky
like so. >> And and what did he do? Did he go is that when
he got a new car or like swap the cars? >> No, he didn't
swap cars until I think May of this year and I was already back
in the US at that point. I haven't taken a ride in his minivan.
>> Oh, okay. Good. Um, okay. So, so you guys, so you're
going to leave. He packs up. How many days is it till you guys
are on the road to Quebec? Is it like a day or two days? >> It
was that night. >> Oh, you guys. Oh, he he didn't even
take like a full day or two to pack. He was >> No, just
like a couple hours. He was like, "We have to leave now." Guys,
everybody think about this in perspective. You know, you >> This
is bizarre. Was he Was he actually trying to get away from something?
>> We have a weekend because, you know, the government's
closed. >> Uh wouldn't you You would think you would at
least take a day and pack your [__] up a little bit.
He was like, "No, right now we're leaving. We're running
>> I don't like that at all. I think he [__]
freaked out cuz he did not want them anywhere in that property.
Not just because of the kids. I think he is >> because
of whatever happened to Allora. I think he would that freaked
him the >> cuz that's not a normal reaction. That just
isn't. And if you've got nothing to hide, you hide nothing. So
he goes, you guys drive to my >> Wait, how did he pass
a CPS visit with the kids? This like >> Montreal to his
mother's house, right? >> Yes. Um he didn't tell her we
were
>> He's such an
>> He was like He said, "My mom always takes me back."
>> Yeah. I bet >> they were sleeping. Wait, does
he Wait, hold on. Hold on. No, no, no, no, dude.
CPS just walks away.
They just go, "Oh, the kids are sleeping." Yeah, never mind.
>> Yeah, never. We don't have to check right now. >> If
they're overworked. >> That's wild. Okay, hold on. Ry saying
no. Let's listen. >> That's See, such a He's such a
>> All right, so poor mom's now bombarded with JF on the
run from child welfare. You welcome to the welcome to Montreal.
>> And the kids who are like, you know, that has got because
kids like that definitely need a routine and structure. So that
would have been stressful for
>> And so how so how long did it take for the cops to show
up in Quebec?
>> Um like a month. >> A month. I thought they came.
Oh, so you guys stayed at his mom's for a month. >> Oh
my god.
>> Okay. I thought the cops showed up right away and that
was why people were freaking out. Okay. So about a month and
then Wow. So they showed up and what did they say? >> I'll
just point out the issue with this interview in my opinion is
I think you run a timeline. And if you want to get if you want
to catch up on somebody's story, I think you just try to go chronologically,
right? And it sounded like she kept going around
like like they went to the the them going to Alberta. Tell me
that story about you like beating the wife and then >> they're
just kind of jumping back and >> Um they said they wanted
to >> Well, maybe maybe there's a strategy to it. If you
don't make her feel like she has to get everything in order and
all her ducks in a row, she'll feel more free to like jump around
and jot her memory and it won't feel like an
>> Yeah, it could be smart. Could be could work in some
cases for sure.
>> and that's you already gone to Albert at that point,
had you? >> Well, this was the first time when we were
at his mom's. Um
>> they the cops came. They said they gotten a call from
inside the house and >> was that his mom? I think it was
his >> I don't know.
Right. >> But um
so they they came and the police just looked at the kids to make
sure they were physically there. Like they didn't interact with
them or anything. And JF quickly started saying, "We have to
go. We have to pack up." And he kind of bribed me to do it because
I was so tired. I kind of wanted to go home. And he was like,
"You know what? I'll take you to um what is that?" >> Wait,
is he is he running again? What >> hotel I told you about?
Well, the Fairmont
get money again. >> Sorry. Say that again. >> Did
she get money again? What does she mean? He bribed her. >> I
don't know. But actually, I have no >> You to um What is
that? >> Sorry, I got to back it up just a little bit more.
>> And he was like, "You know what? I'll take you to um
what is that hotel I told you about?" >> Well, the Fairmont.
He's took her to the one guys. She got
very he >> he was like, "Let's go to the Fairmont. You
can go to the spa there." And you know, like I guess he was just
trying to get me to stay so he could inciminate me
>> inciminate me. >> Jesus. Uh, gentle whale, thank
you very much for the 2,000 kicks. Let's go.
2,000 Wait, 2,000 kicks. 2,000 kicks. 3,000 kicks. 1,000. Wow.
Just emptying breaking the bank on the kicks right >> Thank
you so much. 3,000 kicks right right there. Thank you so much,
Gentle Whale. Really appreciate it, buddy. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. >> Um, So disgusting. There's nothing grosser,
dude. What? >> He he started.
>> So So her assertion is, okay, just to follow that through,
the cops show up in Montreal again, and he's like, "Let's run.
Let's go." And he's going to take her to a fancy hotel so he
can make one last stitch effort to make one more baby
is what she thinks. Okay. >> Panicking. He's like, "You
have to get your stuff packed right now." And I was really tired
and just like, "I don't know if I can do this." And so like within
an hour, he said we have to leave within an hour and we fled
his mom's house and drove to um the Fairmont in uh Tremblant
or something, I don't know, the mountains.
>> And we were kind of I guess hiding there. And um while
we were there, I was stressed out and he was like, "You can go
down to the spa." So I took advantage of that. and I went down
and spent the whole day in the spa and ran up $1,000 bill for
him.
>> Well, that's good. So, when did you What? When did you
guys decide to go to >> Did you say a $1,000 bill, by the
way? >> Um, while we were staying at the >> There's
no way she said that, right? I >> Do you guys have $1,000
bills in Canada? >> No. $1,000 bill from the spa.
>> To the spa and racked up $1,000 bill. I took advantage
of that and I went down and spent the whole day in the spawn.
Ran up $1,000 bill for him.
>> Well, that's good. So, when did you >> That's
not good. That doesn't sound like it was relaxing. It sounded
like she was trying to do like the most expensive. >> When
did you guys decide? >> Bro, don't make me don't make me
defend JF. Don't make don't make me take JF's side. Come on.
>> What? Alberta.
um while we were staying at that hotel and I was in the spa,
he was in the hotel room like I guess trying to figure out what
to do and he was like I think I can
you know get away to Alberta or Saskatchewan and you know like
he was
>> inappropriate in too soon.
>> I guess it was a last ditch effort, >> right?
Because he just really didn't want job offer to come talk to
his kids. >> Yeah. And I agreed to do it just because I
was like well I kind of like to see Western Canada.
>> you know what? I'll be your I'll be your Bonnie. Not
Bonnie and Clyde. Yeah, I'll be your Bonnie. I'll be your Bonnie
Clyde. Okay. I'll help you abscond with your kids evading CPS
cuz I just want to kind of see what Western Canada looks like.
I don't know. The prairies might be cool. A lot of lot of weed
out there, you know. >> YOLO. Okay. Well, that's fine.
Whatever you did, it's probably good because honestly, uh it
probably made it safer for the kids to have somebody who's there
was >> Yeah. and for not panicking and >> right and
I loved him and I thought I was going to be with him but you
know it's it's all very complicated. >> No, of course.
So you guys okay so you take this this long journey to Alberta
what a pain in the ass because that is a long trip. I know even
just going through Ontario. >> Oh I will say guys listen
if we want to we want to do two more hours so we could finish
this whole podcast.
All right. I don't know how far we're going to get in this. We'll
see. Um I think we're four subs. Four subs. Four subs from two
more hours. Right now we got $30 in kicks. We got one sub and
we got $3 in donations from Ruben Ruben. That's four subs for
two more hours. Okay, we got five minutes. So get the subs in.
Let's go. >> That was a [__] >> Yo, maybe
Rocky was on to something.
>> Rocky the brunette that's been uh snarking right now.
>> maybe she's on to something about Oh, good thing you
weren't a female. There's a lot of those out there cuz the way
this woman sh on his kids and just dipped as soon as she got
impregnated.
Maybe she has a
>> maybe she's projecting hard and she's a
Why else would you want to get bred with this dude? I don't think
she bonded with him over autism. Maybe she bonded with him over
>> How have you evaded the police for so long? Uh, holy
xray asks, "What about love? What about what if it could be love?
You idiot."
>> But after listening to this so far, I actually feel
super uncomfortable with either of them having children. >> H
I mean, I would have always been uncomfortable with JF having
kids, but
>> but I don't like this woman anymore.
>> I just can't believe she keeps making it sound like
she doesn't know what's going on or she like didn't do anything.
Also, Private Huff, thank you for the gifted sub. She keeps making
it seem like she was totally like she had no agency here. There's
nothing she could do. But she's like following him across Canada
as he picks up his kids and evades the cops and CPS. Maybe just
CPS. >> The lack of agency
combined with just completely on everything that she knows about
him makes me think of that Asian
>> who slept with what is his name? Walter. >> Yeah.
What was that girl's name? >> Was it April? No. >> No.
Oh, what was her name? >> Somebody. Fresh's Fresh as Sugar
Walls. >> Daisy. Thank you. Yes, >> that was her
English name, right? >> Two people just followed up with
Lingling. No, that's just the racist name that Myron gave her.
Okay, it's not actually Lingling. Stop. >> Spruce Willis
just tipped $5.
>> That's a huge >> Wait, what? Am I the only one
who heard >> Heard what >> was that? A soundboard?
I don't know where that came from. Did you just use a soundboard?
You just use a soundboard. You're didn't >> No, I'm not.
I'm not even I don't have Discord open.
>> can you change your avatar to just be you? Why is there
two versions of me on
>> Um, wait. Are there two versions? Oh, wait. There are
two versions. What the >> To the side. >> I didn't
even see you over there in the Discord thing. Oh, what the Okay.
Uh,
>> what the hell? >> What the Where's my FBI guy?
There we >> Also, why does Rocky kind of look like Queen
with makeup on? >> What? Okay. No, I don't see it. I don't
see it. Uh Ryan, if you said now, if you said Ryan Beard, then
you might be cooking with gas a little bit. Okay. I don't know
about Quman, but Ryan Beard most certainly I could see that.
Hold on. >> That's [__] up. That's not [__]
up. Quan's never going to have makeup on. He's fine. >> Oh,
for some reason I did not. Oh, >> he can handle it. >> I
think she's cute. I'm not saying she's not cute. I'm just saying
if Quimman had put makeup on, this might happen. >> Okay,
stop. because you're feeding into some things that his chat does
a lot that aren't cool and you don't want to feed into.
>> Yeah, there's a there's a little bit of a disturbance
there. We don't want to put any >> anything behind that.
Okay, so we got the five from Spruce Willis. We've got what does
that put us? One we're $5. Any $5 donation or sub away from two
more hours, guys. We're right there.
>> It's so long. So, you get here, >> the first house
he finds falls through, whatever. Fine. You find the second house.
You don't have to say where, but just you found the second house.
You move in and he leaves you. Is that how he leaves you to go
back and get his
>> That's awesome. So, that must have been great for you
to be left to two special needs kids um in a freezing house.
>> I was ready to kill him
back. >> So, once you were there though, the police and
child protection did show up. >> They did. There were two
police officers who showed up and
>> uh they just um kind of looked at the kids and they're
like, "Well, they seem happy." So, you know, we're used to seeing
kids who are like chained up eating from dog food bowls on the
floor. Everything seems fine.
>> They They're used to seeing that.
>> Very odd, very weird,
>> very strange.
Uh, so >> you win. >> Also, Private Huff, Critical
Rad, thank you for both gifting a sub to Abby Blackbird. Kick,
of course, have no concept of concurrent programming, whatever
their backend's doing. Apparently, you both gifted a sub at the
same time. Hopefully, that lasts two >> Let's go. >> We'll
see. But that's two more hours on the stream. Thank you guys
very much. Just under the wire. 2 hours 5 seconds. Let's go.
>> So, the kids seem fine and uh >> Oh, yeah. So
basically they're like, "Yeah, we we expect like savage children
like little literal Neanderthalss in >> eating out of dog
bowls >> in nothing eating out of dog bowls." You know,
you beat that bar. Okay. >> Is it just that it's dog bowls
or is there dog food in the bowl?
>> Your kids are You basically can't fail. Okay. Usually
people take totally normal kids and they ruin them. You're You're
just like ruining kids. We can't be asked with the paperwork.
>> Do you feel like she's saying that because she's talking
to CPS? Like this one doesn't even speak in sentences and she's
like it's fine. like this is better than some of the other things.
Like they're convincing her it's not a >> We're doing our
best. >> So they just left. >> Yeah. They didn't
look at them. They just were like, "Oh, she's cooking for them.
She's keeping the house." >> Yeah. Because that's basically,
you know, when you guys see like animal rescue, as long as the
animals got like the basic need, the very basic needs, you know,
they're not going to interfere. So they were and they were doing
this as a favor to Quebec or PEI RCH welfare. Okay. So it's probably
also why they didn't take it seriously. Uh so they did that.
They checked, left, everything's good. Eventually JF comes >> Yeah.
And he thinks that he's a hero and
>> Oh, this is huge, everybody. This one's huge. Sorry
about the house. >> When he bought that house, you told
me something amazing. This is up. Everybody listen to this. Amazing.
>> Rocky's enjoying this way too much. This is so up. This
is amazing. Wait until you hear this, guys. She's like losing
>> I'm serious. If you told me this was like Queenman's
mother, I would believe
>> Uh definitely there's there's a spiritual kinship there
that I I get it. Yeah. Like this is her, you know,
you switch it over to like aite or something and for queen and
you would suddenly it would all make sense, right? >> Yeah.
It's just like a visceral hatred there that's difficult to imitate.
>> He bought that house. You told me something amazing.
This is up. Everybody listen to this. He wanted you to put the
house in your name, right?
>> Even though it would have been paid off, you still said
no. Because why?
because
I well I didn't want to be legally responsible for anything he
might do to anyone in that house. >> Yeah. Well, also >> like
if he lures some girl there and I don't know ties her up in his
basement, I could get sued if I'm the homeowner. My father was
>> wait is that is that true? I feel like that can't possibly
be true if you have no knowledge of it. Like unless you're somehow
facilitating or being negligent. >> Yeah. Unless you're
somehow Bonnie and
>> Yeah. Well,
basically, yeah, if you had proof that they moved across the
country to to keep their kids away from CPS. Yes. Then maybe
maybe there's some argument. I don't know. >> My father
was an attorney, so I think about these things, >> right?
Smart. Okay. So, uh >> my father is at an attorney, so
I make up various random situations where I couldn't be sued
and then I pretend I could be sued in those situations. >> I
think it's called a guilty conscience because we all know that
DF wanted somebody else's name on it because he didn't want that
asset. He didn't want the asset all in his name because he has
debt collectors and child support he owes in the states and and
in Canada. So what what my question is um how did he how did
he get around that? What did he
>> He went to a lawyer and he said that he found a loophole
in a way to get the house put in Laura's name. So the house Okay
guys, so like think like think about this rationally. If Allora
had any any if there was even the tiniest risk of her returning
to come get those kids because everything's his, right? He's
very everything's his. >> Is he going to [__]
risk his biggest asset? Is he going to risk it by putting her
name on it? No. He would only do that if she was not ever a risk
of coming back. The fact that he put it in her name is still
mind-blowing to me. The house he lives in right now has Laura's
name on the title. >> I mean, that's what he told me. >> And
that's f and I tried to find out. I did try to verify it, but
you can't, Alberta. They won't tell you current uh title owners.
They won't give you that information unless you have like credentials
and I don't have >> Wait, are we to Am I to understand
that JF lives in Alberta now? Really? >> I don't know.
>> Oh, I I kind of understood that they went to Alberta.
I didn't realize they went to Alberta to find to get into a new
house.
>> So, I I think that that was stunning. That was terrifying
to me. What did you think when he told you he put it in Lur's
name? Did Did that give you Was that a red flag to you or No.
Um, it was just such a crazy time. I was like,
>> You know,
it but you know, but honestly thinking about it, it's like, well,
if she's as crazy as he said she was, then you know, why would
why would he put in her name, >> right? And during this
whole hyper stressful time, did he ever say, "God, I wish Laura
would just come. It would be good if she could take the kids
for a day." Or, "Where the [__] is Laura doing?"
Did he ever like because like we all would do that? That would
be a normal thing to have mention um you know the missing mother
of your child and stress about it. Did he ever do that? >> See
like these are not normal in my opinion these are not normal
reactions at all. Like he should about her or >> The only
time that he would mention her warmly is if he was mad at me
and like wanted to manipulate me into thinking or doing something.
He'd be like you know used to do it this way and >> cuz
he wanted you to have a res
>> that's a little weird >> towards her. Yeah, he
did make me resent her and I felt >> I know he did. When
you and I first started talking, you were pretty spicy and I
we did like we did talk for about two weeks and I did say hey
whoa whoa whoa whoa. I I hear you but I also you are listening
to a man who's like if you can't verify it and and I really appreciate
you coming on here and not repeating the same garbage he said
because she isn't here to defend yourself and and maybe it's
true, maybe it's not. I don't know. But you've done really well
at um everybody on the stream should know from the first day
that we spoke to today night like just in your where your anger
was towards Laura because you did you were angry and I mean I
don't blame you. I would have been angry too if I had that [__]
shoved in my >> and it does nothing for the majority of
renters who aren't in >> the is happening
all the time. >> My bad. >> So you've done really
well. Um, okay. I just really quick, so you before you can get
to comments and questions here after this, um, these next four
things, I just want to ask you,
>> do you believe truly sincerely in your heart like in
deep down inside, do you really seriously believe that wandered
away and went off on her own or do you believe he he
>> I believe I believe that JF murdered
>> What now? What is your hypothesis on this? I'm just
curious. I have not told you to say anything. I'm just I genuinely
want to know what you think
what I think happened.
>> Um you know I think that maybe she was
calling him a maybe um he said it was a delusion that she had
maybe threatening to go tell people and you know like he said
to me he just had to beat her. I can imagine
>> that he was like, I just had to kill her, you know,
and um like I can see >> Wait, I just Wait, what? That's
a way different. Had to beat her. That's a That's a different
one. >> I just had to beat her. I can imagine
>> that he was like, I just had to kill >> Oh, I
imagine that. Sorry, I missed it. >> And um like I can
see him losing it like when he's beating her. Um, I think and
I think he choked her and I won't >> They finally found
the Mama JF body. They did not Kenda. They did not get $10 off.
Find the Mama JF body. This is uh people talking about a new
mistress of JF Gary Epi. Okay. A brand new one. >> Hold
on. We're We're apparently going to watch this real quick. I
do want to see it if it happened. Apparently, we've got um Zora
Mdani disavows Hassan.
Oh, wait. Disavows the comment. Hold And I find the comments
that Hassan made on 9/11 to be objectionable and reprehensible.
And I also think that part of the reason why Democrats are in
the situation that we are in of being a permanent minority. >> So
he disavows the comments which like I don't know if you guys
realize this is a politician running for office in New York City.
That's going to be the opinion. Did America deserve 911?
Attempted prospective mayor of New York City. Did America deserve
911? The biggest terrorist attack in this city's history. What
do you think? No, I don't think so. >> Feel like that's
such a easy move to
that's a that's a crazy that's crazy. That's a crazy response.
That's a crazy >> in this country is we are looking only
to speak to journalists. >> All right. I I I just think
sometimes when somebody tells me he got disavowed, I'm like,
"Oh, Zoron was like, I don't want to be around that guy. I don't
want anything to." But it's just like, no, he just said I disavowed
the America deserved 911 comments. I'll go into why, but there's
a very Yeah. >> You have like you just your own experiences
with him. Did he ever hurt you? Really quick though, I just want
to clear that up. Did he ever hurt like physically hurt you?
>> Okay, good. Um, so you think that he like it got out
of control in >> Okay, Jeff was Jeff was not physically
abusive to 10 out of 10. Okay. Now, next question. Why didn't
Rocky just follow that up with Okay, but did you ever call him
a like did you ever push the line there? Did you even try to
see if he was going to stay consistent or you just letting this
guy say he'll only beat a woman if they call him a You're not
even going to try it? Okay. Well, >> what how do you think
he got away with it? Like, how has he gotten away with it this
far? And and where do you think he put her if you were going
to guess just based on your own experiences with her with him?
Sorry. >> Well, um I don't exactly know like the specifics
of how he would have gotten away with it. I have, you know, suspicions,
but um I when we were driving through out of PEI through New
Brunswick the first time >> Um you know, on the side of
the road >> out to PEI, >> but um I when we were
driving through out of PEI through New Brunswick the first time,
>> we were driving out of PEI through New Brunswick. I
don't think you can drive out of PEI through New Brunswick. >> What
is PEI? >> Prince Edward Island. It's an island. >> Can't
get out of an island by driving through a different territory.
>> Sorry, I just I listen, if you're going to talk about
Canadian geography, you got to got to get things correct. Okay.
>> Time, you know, on the side of the road in New Brunswick
when you're driving through, they're like forest
>> woods. And um JF was being really creepy, creepier than
usual. And he looks at the forest and he looks at me and he goes,
>> he was being creepy. Creepier than usual. He's always
He's always at some baseline level. >> You know, if Allora
wandered into there and killed herself, no one would ever find
her. She wandered like a mile or >> He's such a >> This
guy is sick, though. I totally I totally buy that he would say
that to somebody who knew about the Mama JF situation, was riding
in a car alone with him like a woman. I totally buy that he would
look over and go, you know, if uh if my wife wandered out there
by herself and herself, well, they would never find her body.
>> See you later, Reuben Ruben. Thank you for the donos.
Thank you for the puns. Very good time. Thank you. Thank you.
Have a good night. Jesus.
And you know, it was like
kind of a I don't know the way that he said it and like the way
he looked. It was like a kind of a strong reaction almost like
an >> that's what he drove past wherever she was. Maybe
>> it was >> I think that possibly we did. >> Holly's
chomping at the >> Do you remember the mile marker? We
could find her body. >> Hie's got to tell you something.
Hold >> So during our live stream, he did mention that
cuz we were talking about how well why haven't you gone to look
for her? Why haven't you get narrowed down the area where you
dropped her off, etc., etc. He made the comment. He goes, "Well,
I don't have the time or the resources to go see search a two
square kilometer location."
>> He's very specific about that and it was not that's
not the only time he said that. It's it's happened a few times
>> Two in Brunswick, which >> again, so and you said
too, >> very interesting. Emer Okay. I didn't realize there's
a bridge. >> So, I mean, New Brunswick's still very big,
maybe,
But I mean that could be a lead and I don't know if they're going
to do a lie detector maybe cuz they did ask him to do one, didn't
they? >> Yes, they did. >> Followed up with it. >> Yeah,
but like I kind of know somewhat how his mind works. And like
if you think about it, he'd driven from PEI to Quebec through
New Brunswick several times. So he was like if he did snap and
he was >> uh give us Yanco's the km to mile conversion.
It's 1 to 1.6 1.6 km in a mile. So whatever mile count times
1.6 6 or 1 over 1.6 whatever that is 1 over 1.6 is
uh 62.5%
so 62.5% of the kilometer would be the the value so what it's
2 km squared that would be can I get can I get the answer to
this please 1.25 1.25 25 miles square >> is aware that
there are forest on the side of the highway and like if he's
thinking where am I going to stash her body I mean that's a pretty
good idea that's a good place to put it >> absolutely and
I mean we were thinking about okay because we were trying we
you know we thought of every speculation every everything so
when he you know how he had took three days off to clean the
house and get rid of her stuff which he definitely did not do
because her stuff was still at the house when you got there and
that three days definitely could have been body removal and I
mean he had a three-month head start with the the RCMP >> yeah
and I wanted add something else about the body removal, you know,
like you think, well, how would he drag the body of a 150 lb
woman out in the woods, >> especially if it's physical?
>> Um, I would sometimes walk into the kitchen and he'd
like have bought a chicken or something and he would like carve
it. He would uh dissect the bones out of it and like >> Yeah,
I know. A lot of people think that >> their knife set,
they had pretty fancy knife sets in their kitchen and there were
some big knives missing. Yep. Oh, they were missing. See, we
had a guy. God, Blaine, if you're watching, >> Blaine was
all over that. And I thought like So, the knives were missing.
They were missing from the >> Yes. And when we got to Alberta,
this is also something that kind of
>> dude, this is this is like the kind of fun stuff that
I would do if I if I looked into the JF thing like look for Yeah.
like that. I guarant What is this? Cuz I feel like this is somebody
probably watched a video or like some camera pictures of the
house when it was like getting sold and noticed that there's
like a knife missing from the knife set. I don't think >> just
craft a whole mythology around that >> is normal. Um, we
saw like a dead deer or something on the side of the road and
it looked like it had been by some kind of predator like ripped
apart and JF like looks at the side of the road at it >> like
his eyes kind of spiral and he circles back around and he pulls
up on the side of the road
>> and he's like looking down at the animal talking about
how it died and he was excited. Uh, okay. This gets like really
weird. Apparently JF is just a total psychopath. Okay, >> speaking
of weirdos and excited because this is going to be involved in
the whatever documentary they do about this. You told me the
creepiest thing about JF. I'm sorry to >> She's doing it
again. She's doing it again. She's so excited about this one
detail again. >> In whatever documentary they do about
this, you told me the creepiest thing about JF. I'm sorry to
anybody who if anybody is watching as this as a hobby and you're
a teenager. story, but I think it's creepy. >> So, you
told me that JF was socially awkward as a teenager. >> I
was really looking for information about a head injury. You didn't
have that. That's fine. You didn't have >> I can give her
information about another individual in Canada with a head injury.
>> Dude, that's just crazy how things overlap like that
out of nowhere. >> Well, what you did tell me, what did
he tell you he did as a hobby as a teenage >> He used to
breed fish in his room and he had a bunch of >> Okay, I've
literally done that. This is no longer funny. This is no longer
>> What the [__] does that mean? >> I
I just had a massive aquarium. I had an aquarium that was like
8 10 years. >> What does it mean to breed fish? Do you
mean he just had fish of different genders in a tank and they
would >> automatically like
>> This is a creepy thing. >> Yeah. And if you have
if you have guppies, they'll do that automatically. Like you
literally can't stop guppies from breeding.
Guppies be guppies be Okay. Guppies are what? The goldfish. >> No,
guppies are a little different. Little gupp. You know about the
little
Little gups. Little guppies.
Little guppies like this. They got these fan tails. And if you
get these, this this thing's stomach will swell up massively.
Then it'll shoot a bunch of little baby guppies. Yeah, they'll
be everywhere.
Guppy. Babies.
Where are the little baby guppies at? Show me a little gup. Oh,
look at all the little gups. See, this is how they grow. Look
at the Look at the growth patterns. See, I'm like, N, Dude, this
got too personal.
>> but what does it even mean if he breeds fishes? Fish?
>> I don't know.
Might be totally fine. Might be not weird at all. >> I'm
waiting for the weird part. He breeds them, then he takes them
out and dissects them and
does something, right? It has to be. There has to be a twist
to this. >> Okay. All right. You think there's a Well,
maybe. You never know. as a teenage boy, >> he used to
breed fish in his room >> and he had a bunch of aquariums.
>> And he so he he played God with fish >> and he
would try and like mix a species or what? Like >> he's
such a [__] that's a weird thing for a teenage boy
to have a hobby. Most teenage boys be like sports a Let's be
honest here. They're not going to do breeding fish. >> I've
never heard of a teenage boy.
>> that's weird. >> I don't think that's playing
good. I think the fish do it themselves.
Does she think that he's collecting semen from one fish and turning
it to >> I don't know what he uh I don't know what she
thinks is happening here. >> you can get like there are
some Okay, not okay. >> He's playing God by just having
fish >> I want to get a and just say there are some fish
where like you can actually it's difficult to breed them because
they need like perfect water quality. Okay. Maybe he was working
hard at it, but like yeah, it seems kind of normal. >> But
it's never the situation where like when you breed horses, >> you
can't like Yeah, you can't. >> You literally have to take
the semen out >> No, you just have to fish in the thing.
>> I think that's what she's imagining
>> cuz she's a white woman, so she knows about horse breeding.
>> She doesn't know anything about fish. She's like, they
do they do that to
That's exactly what's going through her >> Jesus. Well,
that's not how it is. Okay. You just put the fish. >> Someone
tell her that.
>> And then he turned around. >> He's putting a finger
up their eye, too. >> I'm sorry. Play. Press play. >> Look
at the dead deer. And got out of the car. >> And yeah,
he was talking about how it must have like been ripped apart
and stuff. It was like its body was in half and he was just like
>> And he wasn't grossed out by it. >> No, he was
excited. >> Yeah. That's sick. Yeah. Nope. See, this is
why I wanted them to bring a cadaavver dog into that house because
there's that tiled area. Like, yeah, he is Mr. Scientist. He
probably could have got rid of most blood. But if blood goes
into one crack, he got blood splattered. It doesn't matter. He's
been beating or severely there would be there would be evidence
there. There still to this day would be evidence they can hit
on if a dead body was ever there, >> right? Even if the
body's been moved years ago, they could still hit. So I wish
RCMP would just take a dabber dog into that house. The owners
have said you can go just do a search. Okay, start there. I don't
>> Dude, this this woman's trying by herself to get JF
prosecuted. Okay, she's like calling the RCMP. Hey, I just got
permission for you. take the cadaavver dog over and the RCMP
is like we not we're not sol you don't you don't tell you're
not the boss of me you can't make me do that >> I don't
know >> well and something something else kind of weird
um the daughter she's
>> not you know not very articulate you know she is delayed
in speech and stuff and um at one point I was just kind of I
guess my curiosity got the bear of me so I pulled up on YouTube
a video of showed her and I just wanted to see her reaction and
she couldn't express herself using words but She became upset
and like started uh >> makes me want to cry. >> She
started stomping her foot and whining like trying to tell me
something. That was what she would do when she was
>> No. She was trying to tell me something. She's stomping
her foot. So frustrated cuz she couldn't tell me my mom was killed
by my dad. You know that that's what's going through her head
right now. >> That's Yes,
that is exactly what And it's like she was trying to communicate
the pain to me. If only this child wasn't so stupid and could
speak a sentence and tell me what happened to her mom.
>> trying to tell me something. So, you know, like that
house is small.
>> Oh, no. The kids would hurt for sure. He was beating
her regularly. I'm sorry, but like the house is tiny. >> Well,
yeah. And you know, the daughter um she didn't say much, but
uh when she would be spanked, she would say, "Hey, don't hit
me." And I looked at JF one day and I was like, "Is that what
you beat her?" And he looked down at his feet and he's like,
"Yeah." >> So she would,
>> I need to play that again." >> And she would be
spanked. She would say, "Hey, don't hit me." And I >> She
would say, "Hey, don't hit me." "Hey, don't hit me." "Hey, don't
hit me. Don't hit me." >> She'd do that voice and I knew
it was her mom. It was he was she was repeating her mom. >> Looked
at JF one day and I was like, "Is that what you beat her?" And
he looked down at his feet and he's like, "Yeah." So she reme
fingers together. Oo woo. Small beam pose. Yeah, that's what
she said when I hit her. >> Looking at his toes. >> Yeah,
that's what she said when I hit her. Yeah, that's right. I guess
so. >> Was painting a picture. Tell us what time of the
evening was. >> She doesn't say very many sentences. So
that was
>> she said hering. >> She said her first complete
sentence at 3 because I've been working with her. She said, "I
see you." >> That's really [__] up. I'm sorry,
but it is like my god. Like at three I mean like I said, kids
were telling me off. Other people's three-year-olds have pulled
me off. They just they like that's not I mean and not again not
making fun of the children that is just JF should have been um
really working on that should
>> 10 out of 10 binge on his kids from the start of this
>> uh his
who would want to steal those kids who would want >> who
would ever kidnap those kids ain't nobody kidnapping your kids
>> priority why does he have these kids if he is doesn't
care like he he's like Mr. genetics. Oh, speaking of genetics,
I didn't do that one either, Holly. But he said to Holly when
he was on our stream, somebody had asked if he had the 10 out
of 10 take genetic testing and that you did take it. And what
did he say about >> He said he uh the the chat came in
um is 10 out of 10 white cuz he's all about the white nationalism
stuff. >> And uh he responded and said, "Oh, yes. Yeah,
I had her genetic tested and she was 100% white." >> Did
that happen? >> Um he didn't ask me to be. I just did
no >> did one of the 23 and me test at one point because
I was just curious about my ancestry. >> Okay. So, he took
ownership for something I had nothing to do with as >> Yeah.
And something weird happened when I did it. Um you know the way
that your uh percentages of ancestry are grouped.
>> Um one of mine was like one of the groups was just kind
of clumped together, German and French. And you can look specifically
at like the sub like I think there were areas that they kind
of indicate you're from. And mine was uh German, but because
it was like German and French, he goes, "You know what? I think
your dad was an orphan from Quebec that got sent to the US."
And like he's like, "I know you're part Cubaqua." And I was like,
"JF, >> well, he he would trick himself into believing
his own
>> wanted to believe it." And >> I rile, is that
real? Can you go see if that's on his substack? So, like he started
this thing and he called his mom and told her like, "Oh, Lindy's
part cubic and stuff."
that's shocking. The whole thing's shocking. I've got goosebumps.
I feel >> Nobody gave a [__] about that story.
She needed to go back to snarking on his kids. Could not care
less about your 23 and me. Move on.
Um, apparently Richard Hania,
I swear to God, I remember like I used to work with this like
with this girl who was like >> you used to work >> I
worked with a girl who wrote this exact article once and I'm
just and she was like this very angsty goth girl, right? And
now Richard Hanania produces an article with the same title and
I'm like, "Oh god, I really hope it's I'm like I'm getting like
PTSD about reading that article back when I wrote read it like
10 years ago. It was crazy.
Why would you produce this? Why was I insulted? The damage of
trauma culture.
Oh my god. He just talked to Aya, didn't he? He's he started
talking to Aya within the past what three weeks, four
Maybe three months tops. He just became aware of Ayla. He talked
to her for the first time and he produced this article. I'm positive
one of the things she talks >> No, because Aya tells a
story where she literally was brutally raped and is like, "No,
I think it was fine."
>> Oh, she's basically like, "Yeah, I was in North Africa.
That's just the way it is there. I should have known." >> Like
other people are seriously questioning, "Oh, this is kind of
assault. Actually, this wasn't okay. This actually violated my
consent." Aya is just I Yeah, that's definitely I don't think
I was I don't feel traumatized by it. >> Yeah. And the
story is like a weird man followed her home. She ran up her stairs
like closed the door and then he busted the door down.
That's like that's the story by the way. It's not like there
was like dubious consent or something and they were drunk. It's
like she got followed home by a crazy guy in like tangers or
some [__] like that. It was like it was a wild story
if you ever read it. Anyway, I'm not actually going to read this
right now. I just I was like kind of confused about why Richard
Ani would produce this article. Um, mostly cuz he's also like
at Culture War basically with the Gropers and I just it seems
like a weird thing to lean into when you're like trying to say
the Gropers are like
are not the group to follow. I feel like you just you lose a
lot of ground with the
read the first sentence. When I was a teenager among my social
circle, there was a practice called teaagging where a guy would
place his testicles on the head of a friend who was sitting or
lying down. This happened to me at least a few times and I never
thought about it again. It wasn't one of the top 1,000 unpleasant
things that has hap or sorry, it wasn't one of the top 1,000
unpleasant things that has happened in my life. Okay. >> And
there's more paragraphs after that. I feel >> there's more
there's more paragraphs after that apparently.
Yeah. Huh. Listen, teenage dudes are pretty gay sometimes. They
could be pretty gay. All right. That's a pretty gay story. It's
a pretty gay start to a story. Sounds pretty gay. >> I'm
sorry that happened to him. They're like upset even though and
I >> back to the JF story. Okay, >> I do want the
chat. You guys, we need to get JF accountable and we can get
to >> He is the one who is deluded. Like he can convince
himself someone is
what he wants them to be. >> I know. You know, >> dude,
he was playing God with fish as a teenage boy. He's weird. There's
something wrong with him. I am amazed though about the block.
Okay, so the knife block, they were expensive knives. >> Um
I would say so. I >> did. You ever ask him where the knives
are? Like when you're doing the dish?
No, I just I I guess I didn't I it was really chaotic,
>> Taking care of the kids and trying to do stuff and >> well,
the whole house was like kind of falling apart, so it would have
made sense if it's not like the house was pristine and then there
was just a miss a knife block with missing knives. But I do find
that interesting. And I did have somebody who was in our wat
group and he was really keen on this this um knife >> block
with missing knives.
>> It's kind of >> I don't know. Maybe I don't know.
I don't know. I just think that there's stuff on that property
that the police need to look at. They never brought anybody out
there, which is so frustrating. They've never once searched the
property where she was last seen.
>> What do you think about the sighting, too, really quick?
What the sighting? The supposed sighting that she was seen in
Nova Scotia or New Brunswick. What What do you think about that?
>> Um, well, I mean, there are ways that it could have
been, you know, falsely
>> right? Specifically, you said something very smart,
though, that I never >> Well, he is a big Bitcoin user.
So, I mean, you know, on the dark web, if I don't know if he
uses a deep web or not, but like if you wanted to, you can like
get on there and pay people in crypto to do all kinds of things.
So, like you can >> Okay, you can pay people in crypto
to do all kinds of things, but like to phone in a random anonymous
tip to sorry to post a random anonymous tip on 4chan. I feel
like you don't need to pay somebody to do that. You could just
>> No, but didn't this theory exist out there that he sold
her on crypto? He dropped her off and the person who most likely
picked her up from that gas station had purchased her. >> Like
he trafficked her. >> Oh, maybe. I I mean I I don't know.
I don't think he would have I feel like he wouldn't I feel like
he wouldn't have given somebody away with his uh with his >> He
got the Epstein connection. He do have the Epstein connection
though. >> Hire people to kill somebody. You know, it's
it isn't. >> Mama JF hated though.
>> I don't know if I don't know if she could be convinced
to do anything good >> Nobody who wants her would be a
>> She's not a child.
>> If anything happens to 10 out of 10 J >> the mind
of a child and the adult of a >> Just no. I will actually
show up at your >> please don't do anything wrong. We're
we're snarking on JF for the memes or the mama JF memes >> if
anything happens to 10 out of 10 JF just no I will actually show
up at your house like so so don't we're not giving any ideas
with uh your Bitcoin >> but yeah he could have well he
doesn't have much left
>> no but he could have paid he could have paid for um
somebody >> he could have paid somebody to like call >> I've
asked the RC to verify I've been to verify if that that sighting
was verified by cameras or was it just hearsay or what? And for
some reason, I guess they're so busy. They're so busy they never
been able to reply. >> And I'd just like to say to the
other ladies out there considering being with JF, he's handing
out bitcoins and beatings and he's all out of Bitcoin.
>> there shouldn't be any other.
That is so >> He's handing out beatings and bitcoins, but
he's all out of Bitcoin. Yeah. No, ladies, this is not the man
you want. >> I cleaned him out. >> Good job. I'm
glad. Good for you. I'm glad because you did it for your son.
I'm sorry, but she's over here like, and if anyone else is like,
you know, trying to go after him right now, please get to the
bottom of why you went after him, why you ended up having a kid
with him
when all you have done is say red flags from like the day you
flew there. >> How much also, how much Bitcoin did she
get from the guy? I'm just I'm curious
>> Not enough to go through this. Not >> Well, you
never know. I mean, it's like three Bitcoin. Maybe it is enough.
I don't know. >> No, I think she needs to be >> I
think it's great >> because people never pay child support.
Um, where's the Allora the Allora thing here. Uh, this is very
important. I should have had this up most night, but whatever.
I didn't. Um, if you're if you have any information, please contact
>> the RCMP. The file number is
And I'm just going to
upload a picture really fast, guys.
say government
a government email. Okay, it's allgc.ca.
>> Well, that's I don't know. It's there, but we're in
the way. How do we get
Oh, right there. There we go. All right. Uh, that's she's 5'
10. She's got sandy brown hair and uh she speaks both French
and English. >> Um, she's eccentric. She is definitely
not hiding in plain sight. There's zero chance of Oh, I'm sorry.
I keep going back. I have another question. you met Allora's
family because a lot of people do have questions like why aren't
why isn't her family speaking out and I've gotten real angry
about it. >> What was her family like? Can you tell us
about that? >> You know, they spoke French and I speak
English so I didn't communicate with them a whole lot but they're
kind of like I got the impression they were detached and like
these hippie liberal boomer types and they just like they have
a Pink Floyd poster up in their
>> Like these are the kind of people they
Why? Why do I feel like she put more thought into what the little
girl stomping her feet at the sight of like a video of Mama JF?
She put more thought into what that child's trying to communicate
than these parents who just speak a different language.
>> Well, they had a Pink Floyd they had a Pink Floyd poster.
Okay. They must be >> They didn't even stomp. So, I I don't
think they cared. >> Like they're adults with >> rock
band posters if that's you know. Did they um did they seem to
buy JF's story? Did they care? Did they seem worried like they
wanted to know where Laura was or >> I don't think they
care.
>> And you said that JF said this is so up. But you said
that JF said to you that and I don't Can you explain was he amazed?
Was he
>> the context there? They're adults
with a Pink Floyd poster. They've got a rock band poster up in
their house. I don't think they cared that she was gone.
>> That is her analysis. I hate this woman.
>> Listen, they just didn't really They were, you know,
hands-off parents. They >> I'm thinking they didn't care.
You could have taken out Google on and like translated, figured
out how to communicate with someone who speaks French and you
just did not give a [__] >> No, this a big
language barrier. I don't think so. I don't think we do that.
That's a lot. That's a lot of work. >> When he told you
about the parents seeing her with bruises, >> Yeah. He
said they would see her with bruises and I think they said something
to him about it and >> you know >> but they didn't
have left it at that. I I don't know. I he didn't say like he
wouldn't tell me if if they >> Right. So well hopefully
they did tell the RCMP but I mean the fact is they haven't been
looking. They don't they don't care. They don't want I'm sure
they care at some level but they're not >> we have been
in contact but they they will not engage. Um, the brother can't,
he showed the most interest out of the whole family, but they
couldn't even tell us one good thing about her that we could
relay in the earlier streams. Um, they have no interest in this,
>> which you know what, I get you don't want to be on stream.
You don't have to go on the stream, but you could say something
nice about your daughter. You could participate in the missing
person's group. >> They don't even they don't see the kids
regularly. You're checking on them.
>> No. JF um told me that like he would send pictures through
email to her parents of the kids and like update them. Um and
her parents don't even respond most of the time. They >> Yeah.
So, so that's why the RCMP I don't think I've been acting is
because she doesn't have a hysterical family demanding answers.
>> So, we need to do that for her. I feel sorry for her.
She couldn't have been more isolated than she was. >> It's
a hysterical wine ants on the >> Yeah. I'm not I'm not
dropping it. I'm not dropping it. I need to know what happened
to her.
>> Drop it. JF told me at one point that her parents hate
her. >> So I don't know. I >> see. This is what I
think. He's such a such a creepy cuz he probably said that to
her too. True or not? Like you know what I mean? Like just like
I just feel so bad for her because she was so isolated. Then
she goes to I could just cry when I say it the whole story. She
goes to a woman shelter >> and she has her own beliefs.
She's allowed to have her own beliefs about a dude in a skirt
taking a bed at a woman shelter and she says something rude and
because she's disrespectful, she's removed and then now she's
missing. Like somebody's going to have to be held accountable
besides JF down the road. If I find out that's true, I will never
let that go. >> Yeah. And like I I do think I have something
good to say about Laura. I think that she was, from what I've
gathered, she was very sincerely interested in right-wing politics.
She was a really big fan of Owen Benjamin, and she would watch
his streams. And to this day, JF hates the Pink Floyd music that
Owen Benjamin would play on his
>> dude. Is it it's it's not a good sign that all these
early 2010s like white nationalist people their biggest fans
aren't actual
like jeez.
>> Oh,
cuz he did say that about remember he said about like stuff and
he would flip out. >> Oh yeah. >> Makes sense. Did
if Oh, and so she used to write to him is what you heard, >> Yeah.
JF told me that Allora would sometimes write to Owen about his
shows and just >> and then Owen did do a stream that is
no longer there that he was just being
>> If anybody can find that stream, I'd love to see it.
>> Owen Benjamin did a stream about um how he thought JF
her and just about what a total slime ball that JF is. He called
him a gamma male, which if you look up gamma male, it does describe
JF. He thinks he's an alpha male, but after reading about gamas,
I have to say he's a gamma.
>> Uh So sad. The whole thing is so sad. And I just listened.
>> Wait, what the [__] is a gamma male?
>> alpha, beta, omega, gamma. >> What's a gamma male?
A gamma male is a term for internet based social or or sorry
from internet based social
describing a man who's intelligent, creative, and empathetic
but not in traditional but not in a traditional leadership role.
I'm a male. Highly intelligent, introspective, and empathetic
man. Empathic man. How in the world does that resp how does that
how
does that
how does that describe him? That's Vox Day's term the blog she
first read about JF on. >> He is compassionate.
>> He is secure in his masculinity. This is a this is a
joke. >> That's not JF, man. That's not JF at
Mr. Girl. I mean maybe, but like no, that's not JF. That's not
JF at all. Dexter is not a gamma male. What do you >> I
love you 10 out of 10. Thank you so much for coming on.
ask you some questions. I think I think I answered asked everything.
Thank you. You rocked on this, by the way. >> Yeah. Um,
so we did get another 10 $10 from Swampy Boy. So, that pays the
bills for the stream for the month. So, >> thank you so
much. Sorry, I got distracted for a second there, >> Swampy
Boy. Guys, this content is amazing. Well done for hooking up
the interview and thank you 10 out of 10 for sharing your story.
It's a It's a ripe kino queen. >> Yes. I don't Yes. No.
Good. No, it And it's amazing because honestly it would be I
think it would be I would be too nervous to do it myself. >> Well,
and at this point like I do feel like I have an obligation to
speak out because that could have been me.
>> Well, I'm so glad it wasn't. Thank your mom. You better
love your mom. Even if she pisses you off
>> because JF is going to tell the next girl that I'm crazy
just like >> he's already started. He's already
I've seen his his his Twitter.
>> Clearly she's not. Oh, speaking of, we've got JF responses
to this. I believe there's a JF tweet about this interview. There's
also a JF video response. He talks about it in his first stream
back as well. Okay, so we will get to that eventually here. We've
still got a little bit more of this interview left to go, but
we will get to the >> pedile allegations. JF, >> I'm
crazy guys.
>> No. And yeah, big ups to your mom. Tell your mom that
the Real Housewives love her for having really good instincts
and taking care of you. >> Big ups and just like, you know,
not being like and punish you by not helping you with a baby.
Like I'm Yeah, you need that. So good. It's great.
>> If Laura had had a mother like that, things would have
turned out very differently in my opinion. >> Yes. Well,
that's why that young girl from Texas was saved as well because
her father stepped up. >> Yes. And fought hard >> and
he fought hard to get her back. So, >> is that is that
the lawsuit girl? Is that who we're talking about there? >> Thank
God. Thank God for good parents out there. >> Yeah. Okay.
We need more comments. >> Yeah. So, I've got a whole bunch
started here and they're from way back cuz we went on a little
further. >> So, this is a talking about the kids. Mezer
Schmidt is wondering if you measured the kids' heads.
>> No. Okay, that's a that's a Morgan that's a that's a
reference to Morgan trying to prove >> No, just don't even
go into that one
>> Measuring the heads. >> Did you measure their
heads? Yeah. I don't know.
>> Is that just a phronology reference? Is J is JF like
a phronology fan? my colleague. Just don't go into it, but I
wanted to share because Messor Schmidt is one of our >> You're
such a He's such a brat. >> He's such a brat. So, thanks
for sharing your story. Did you get any murderer vibes from JF?
And I think we did cover that with the drive with him stopping.
>> We just haven't gotten there yet. >> Yeah, there
were there were moments
>> the person talking about measuring the heads, that's
they mentioned it earlier. He's a white nationalist. >> Well,
he is. Yeah, he's a white nationalist. Yeah, he believes in race
realism and all that, but Phil, >> that's for that guy,
not JF. you know, you got a feeling like sometimes when he was
angry, uh, he would have a look on his face that was that was
pretty scary, like not quite human. Maybe something you'd expect
from Ted Bundy. But, you know, I would tell myself, "Oh, well,
he's intelligent and he just feels emotions more deeply." And
he doesn't mean it, right? >> Oh, God. Women were so stupid
of that. >> Yeah. When we're in love, we tend to look past
a lot of things. >> Yeah. And I really was in love with
him. And, you know,
>> Oh, I hear you. >> Yeah. I will never fall for
that.
>> no. I don't think men's emotions are
>> Always a manipulative ploy
uh meant to control women.
>> I don't think men feel emotion. >> All right.
Well, >> there's a was a bunch of questions about
>> Help, help, help.
>> And you did talk about how um cops stopped by when you
were in Alberta to look at the children and they didn't do anything.
No, >> the CPS cases that they have in PEI and
>> they don't really have jurisdiction in Alberta, but
hopefully they're able to pass information over to Alberta.
>> I think if uh more people start to rattle the cages
of the RCMP and child protective, maybe something can be investigated.
Uh so here's a good question here. Did you ever see JF being
harassed by the police?
>> So So he wasn't like there was like no helicopters in
the sky, SWAT teams. kicking doors in or anything like that.
>> No, he and that's one thing that annoys me. Like he
would make himself sound like he's >> as As a man, I can
tell you that's true, Cherry. Okay. All right. >> Wait,
Giga Giga Chad. She was in love with him, but she never lists
any uh attributes. She >> Yeah, she liked Yeah, she did.
That he made like 7 to 8,000 a month. >> Money, money,
trips, money, trips,
>> She ran up a $1,000 bill at a spot. She made it very
clear. >> She talked about what she liked. is >> she
talked about what she didn't like too. Short, fat, >> short,
fat. >> Um, bad posture. >> Didn't take good care
of his kids. Didn't keep his house. >> Kids couldn't speak
in in sentences. They don't wear clothes. They don't know how
to dress. Dirty dishes. >> Lots of downsides. >> Lot
of them. >> Kind of rough. >> A freethinker who's
being politically persecuted. And that's kind of like one of
the ways I justified it at first. You know, I was like, "Oh,
he's standing up for conservative stuff." But he's really not
conservative in any way in real life. He's pretty liberal in
a lot of his thinking. Like he's not even
>> I get the big leftist vibes from him from when we talked
to him and then his excuses and >> yeah, you know, major
leftist vibes from from one of the only white nationalists who's
ever been like a consistent content creator. Big leftist vibes
from this guy. >> Then him wanting to lean on the government
but yet anti-government was just weird. So >> yes. Um,
so because there's that big story about how there was 10 cop
cars chasing him out of uh PEI. Did that
>> I wasn't there, so I don't know. I was in Alberta. And
another thing, like he complains about single moms getting government
assistance. >> That's what he's living off of. He's collecting
welfare on the kids. Yep. >> Oh, JF, the Bitcoin millionaire
is getting welfare. >> Oh, good for him. >> That's
amazing. >> And then I'm going to include 10 out of 10
you in this as well. Looking gorgeous, ladies. >> Thank
you so much. Um, did you ever report the neglect? >> I
wouldn't actually don't say anything about that. Just just there's
a reason. If she did, I don't want to know. I don't want the
stream to know. We don't want to give JF heads up. I'm sure she's
she sounds intelligent. I would just I think we should just not
talk about that part. Sorry. >> Um, so then one from Von
D because he's hilarious. Does JF have
a couple of these? Yeah.
>> Because I saw I gonna pull up other pictures here. Okay.
>> Here. Is that an air bed with no sheets and no pillowcases?
>> Awesome. Good. >> Cool. Cool, cool, cool. >> Keeping
it classy, JF. Loving it. >> Keeping it classy. Bitcoin
millionaire on an air mattress. Can't even afford pillowcases.
They're $19 at Walmart. Come on. >> And then there's a
really nice picture. >> He's got big boobies. I'm amazed.
>> He's got some >> some big boobies. >> And
that's a >> that's a pronounced tum tum. >> Listen,
I'm a chub muffin, too, but he >> I can't I can't see the
tum tum because you covered it up with this info for the police.
Get it out of here. since they're talking about, you know, women
and he thinks he's like God.
>> I love when fat people call other people
>> Well, I mean, they know. >> Are you sure that
they know? >> They do. She knows she's fat. She might think
she's less fat than JF, which is probably a cope, but >> Well,
I do think I cut her off. She's about to explain it. Like, yeah,
she's chubby, but she doesn't on other people for being fat,
and JF does that. So, you get to just [__] on him
for doing it. >> Yeah. I find it if you if you think a
behavior is bad and you try to find a reason to engage in it,
it's probably not good. I don't fat people unless they on fat
people, which they >> It's like when Pearl calls other
women old and aging and you look like a hag and you're fat and
this is why men don't want you and then she looks the way that
she does. >> She's like begging for people to insult >> It's
Yeah, it's a little rough when Pearl does that. It's true. >> God's
gift to them, but listen, you're not looking like it. >> Yeah.
And I mean, we can make fun of his appearance all we want because
we're on >> because he makes fun of women. He's so he's
trying to be seducing you pose. It's weird
in front of the connects. >> Yeah, it's quite uh big uh
big. >> So you look at the height of the door. >> Quite
a big big She looking at his print right now in those sweatpants
or she's starting to get it a little bit. I can't see. I can't
really >> Is he on his knees closet or is he standing up
on his feet? >> He's standing up. >> Oh. Oh, I'm
sorry. He's a big boy. He's a big boy.
>> And did he have did he have like a Wolverine shave going
on here? >> Yeah, he looks like he's a hotter >> Like
he's got the little beard, no mustache, and then the chops going
on. Is that the the look he was going for?
>> Even she's like I can hear you throwing up in your own
mouth 10 out of 10. >> I'm sorry for for bringing that
back. >> Um Okay. So then there's the comment. He inserted
himself into Rocky Stream and then planted the embryos of this
>> Yeah, he did. He did impregnating everything. And right
now he's melting down because he's like the on the Wizard of
Oz the little man behind the curtain. >> Yeah. And you
just >> he doesn't have much of a career left and like
he's trying to project what little image he has.
>> You know, he needs that narcissistic
>> All right. And some of these questions did get answered
uh throughout that. So I'm just going through that. Uh so then
there's some comments here. I'm sure you'll appreciate it here.
The ins >> what? He calls his the smasher. Pretty insensitive
if you ask me. >> Is that real? >> In context, that
would be offensive. I do not think that's real. >> Will
continue until morale improves.
>> I feel like just like I just feel like there's sperm
all over him every time I think about it. >> Well, his
approach to incimination, it's kind of like on Harry Potter Voldemort
leaving horcruxes.
>> I I have no idea what that reference is because I've
never heard I've never watched it. >> Okay. And then so
I I actually had this question too because
>> never heard of it. What's Harry Potter? >> I don't
trust those now. What kind of [__] on the internet
talking never watched never knew anything about Harry >> They
might have been housewives like or so. I don't know. One of them
is definitely older. No, I can see it. >> In a lot of the
videos that he was on, he was always drinking Pepsi. >> And
then the videos of the house, there was crates and crates of
Pepsi. He's talked about bulk purchasing Pepsi. No. >> Diet
diet Pepsi. He likes to maintain a girlish figure. >> It's
like a middle-aged woman. He's built like a middle-aged woman.
I know. I'm a middleage woman. So many roundies between
I'm Listen, I'm fluffy as I am, but I mean I'm not acting like
a dead zipper model. >> Um, so then Bondie was talking
about the gummy candies. That was mortifying when we talked about
that. And then Rocky that awful video, but let's see. Question
for later. Did JF ever try to sell you on the idea of his book,
The Revolutionary Phenotype?
Um, he's not that into it, I don't think. Like, he makes money
off it, but I don't
>> I he he doesn't I I don't know how into it he really
is at the end of the day. >> Interesting. Because it's
something that he always leans back on is that he's a published
author on his his uh science that he invented. That's amazing.
And it's kind of >> Oh, you know what this is?
>> God, Moonray Murray is so based in the chat, but I can't
highlight his message right now. Go ahead. You know what this
is where she's like, he's not super into
>> I don't think he finds a value in talking to her about
it. >> Uh or also she probably doesn't want to make it
seem like she was into the white supremacist ideas. >> Well,
I don't think he's that into it cuz she doesn't want to paint
like that she went and the white supremacist to get impregnated.
>> You literally showed your 23 and me to >> Why
did you think he was interested in that? What What did you think
he was trying to do? Change the world. Yeah. >> And he
mentioned that to a to a few times when we were questioning his
behavior and he's like, "Oh, I've already changed. I've been
streaming for eight years and there's already stuff that's changed
and it's all because of me." And then he mentions his book and
I'm just like, >> "Oh, speaking of >> you got to
bring up Erit's comments after that. Excuse me. Erits Israel,
>> the um thing after just >> Okay, so um
>> Erits Israel, I believe that's greater Israel. Are we
going to get some greater? You cannot escape the Israel Palestine
commentary. No matter where you go, you're watching some housewives
snark on JF Gary epi in the year of our lord 2025. It's still
coming back to Eritz Israel. Okay. >> And uh I can't remember
what we're talking about, but a lot of people talked about how
um that it hit too hard. Actually heartbreaking. All kinds of
comments like that. I highlighted a whole bunch of those when
um when we were talking about the kids and the condition that
they were in. >> Everyone in the chat in the chat were
just mortified. Absolutely horrified. >> And yeah. Uh
>> um Oh, and this was a good question actually. Uh, so
when you were in the home, were there any pictures of Allora
around like on the walls or or anything like that so the kids
could see pictures of their their mom? >> No. And at one
point, um, I asked like to see pictures of the kids when they
were younger. And, uh, JF like, >> "Oh, JF would not have
been happy about that." Oh my goodness. She's like, "Oh, wait.
Where did he get these? Are these kids even hers? Where did he
get these kids? Can I see some pictures of these kids when they're
younger, please? I want to see you and Mama JF with one of these
kids when they're like two right now. I need to see that stat.
Otherwise, maybe I do need to hold back when the cops are coming
here. Okay, maybe I should be running with you. Maybe you've
maybe you've actually done something >> Rig something up
to show them on the TV screen, you know? >> And he had
purposely like there were no pictures of Allora in there. Like
he didn't want them to see her and >> which the boy was
young, he wouldn't remember. But >> yeah, that's >> interesting.
Okay, that's a good one. Uh and then you we were talking about
how he uses the word delusional and um changes the the conditioning
of words and the words. >> So changing the meaning of words
is one of the um examples of what cult leaders do. Thank god
he's not as successful or charismatic enough to be able to start
a >> Yeah, he would love to. He would love to be a cult
leader. >> Oh yeah, >> he would be kind of like Charles
Manson.
>> Oh, but just chubby and like French. So >> Charles
Manson was at least he was charismatic and you know was involved
in the music industry so he had some connections. Yeah, I'm going
to choose. If I had to choose between two, if it's going to be
Charlie Charles Manson or J, it's going to be Charles Manson.
>> Yeah, cuz Charles Manson didn't want to inseminate anybody.
>> Charles Manson also never anybody himself. He never
had blood on his >> Okay. And this was asked a few times.
>> At what point did you start noticing red flags? Like
at what point did your brain just kind of click and go, "Oh shit."
>> Um I guess in ways they were there from the start, but
the first time like it really was concrete was when um we went
to Quebec for the first time after we were denied um entry through
the border. We decided to go to his mom's house in Quebec and
we were playing with the kids and um I suggested this game called
Monkey in the Middle where we would throw the ball over the girl
cuz she's like they're kind of out of it. don't understand much.
And I was like, maybe it will help her get interested in involved
if she sees us throwing it back and forth. And JF became very
um just snarky, like very cutting. He's like, "You're a little
sick, don't you think, to be trying to manipulate a child using
peer pressure?" And I felt like I'd been punched in the stomach.
And I just sat there and couldn't talk. And he looks at me, he's
like, "Are you okay? What's wrong?" And you know, at that point,
it was like, "Well, that was verbal abuse.
>> I don't like him. Don't like him." And I think he felt
bad about >> he got a little snarky >> it just you
know and and that's why I was like he seems to have remorse you
know and he didn't really >> say anything like that to
me for a long
>> Okay. And uh do you know about no white guilt the live
streamer? >> Uh no I don't. Can I bring something up that
I did discuss with um 10 out of 10 tonight? We talked about it
briefly before the show because I've been thinking about this
no white guilt thing because it's the one thing that doesn't
make sense at all because it does make Laura seem off her rocker
because she does sound like it when she's saying you know he's
tried to kill me. I because I thought that the baby the youngest
one was I thought he was another year older than he was um back
then. I'm realizing now she left when he was or left she was
murdered or whatever happened to her uh was when the baby was
10 months old. I think had postpartum uh psychosis. She never
she gave birth to the baby alone with JF at the house. He never
took the kids to the doctor. She never got follow-up care. >> It
was just her alone. So she was having postpartum psychosis and
all of a sudden starting to think no ideational
and whatever and he's not taking her to the doctor to get her
help. Um, she probably did say that and really did sincerely
mean that, but like I just feel so bad because how terrifying
that would have been for her. Plus, it would not have calmed
her down. Do you know what I mean? And then her allegations to
him and she was because if you've seen someone in psychosis,
it can be crazy, >> right? So, like she could have she
could have done anything if she was going through something like
that without support or medication or a doctor and her mother
would have checked in on her or something like that or she had
friends but she didn't. Something like that would have happened.
Um, somebody would have helped her. This could have all been
avoided, >> right? And the kids have never seen a doctor
ever. They were born at home. He has never taken them to a medical
>> Wait, there's no way that's true. Hold on.
That can't be That can't possibly be true. That's too far.
They've never once been to a doctor. I >> CP CPS came to
the house and was like, "Chill. There are kids who are like eating
at a dog pool. I got to deal
>> I I don't know if you could get away with that. Yeah.
I just don't I don't know if I >> sprinkled their cavities
cuz you said their teeth are rotting from He told me he took
the girl to a dentist recently because I kept at him about it
and he was like, you know, it's just >> it's so painful.
>> He was like, "Oh, it's no big deal. They're just minor
cavities." Well, >> no, no, no, no. >> that's what
he said. The dentist said, >> what a liar. That isn't what
a dentist is going to say. The dentist is going to say you got
to get those things filled because they're painful." >> Talking
I don't like him. >> Well, it can lead to a lot of problems
later. So, some comments here about you, our friend Ten. Uh 10,
consider what you did a service to the community, helping uncover
this mon little monster. Uh 10 out of 10. You are a 10 out of
10. You escaped that dirt bag. And then a question here. Do you
know about Kino
>> Um I I do loosely know Andy Warski's on there and uh
he hates Andy Warski. >> Well, yeah. I think the feeling
is
Um did did he have a job or anything other than the obligations
of the >> when I first started? >> Oh, the guy's
name is Eritz Israel. Oh, me. I thought it was going to be something
else. I thought it was a joke. some kind of comment >> talking
to him. He told me that he was making like 7,000 8,000 a month
doing coding like contracting work online and then later he's
like, "Oh, I got fired." And you know, I don't know what he told
me was if it was true or not. I don't at this point I have to
evaluate everything he's ever told me. >> Okay, that makes
sense. Um, was he Well, there's a question. Was he ever scared
of the RCMP bugging his phone or tracking him? >> Um, I
mean, he's paranoid in general. You should tell about the Lolita
thing. You should tell the movie. That's so weird. He told me
that like we we would watch movies. I was like, "Well, do you
want to watch the lead?" He's like, "No, I would not have something
like that downloaded on my files because of who I >> That's
a weird way. That's a weird thing to say. That's a thing to say.
I'm sorry it is. >> You're not talking like you were you
were talking about the movie, Lolita. Not like >> Yeah.
No.
>> Is that a weird thing to say? >> So, this this
was from the perspective of the audience. So, when you guys were
on the move and you were escaping, he was praising your handling
of the situation. Um, and he was talking about how you were being
so calm and you're an incredible mother for the children because
you guys were on the run from the police and the government.
Um, he he also said that the authorities were testing you 10
out of 10. Did anything like that happened? >> I don't
really think so unless he's talking about like at the border
when the agent said to me, "Are you aware of his history?" You
know, when I was with JF, I just I had to
kind of act calm a lot and just compartmentalize things and you
know >> No, that makes sense.
in therapy. >> I've been highlighting comments because
they're so funny. I'm sorry. >> Yeah, I've been kind of
going down here and then we were talking about the fish. >> you
got to highlight all those, please, because they're so funny.
I want you to read them because these are so great. We have to
make fun of them. We can't just talk seriously. We have to
JF would breed fish while doing the manggina.
>> Okay. And fishery Epstein. >> Possibly. Uh let's
see. His PhD was on lampre before he ate typically moved to >> Is
that true? >> Yeah. So he remember he was talking about
keeping the alive, like keeping the brains alive.
He had the record for keeping the fish alive for the longest.
>> It was unethical. He said he said he crossed lines doing
that. >> Yeah. And he was proud of it being
>> So, okay. So, Messor Schmidt, our our boy here, uh we
were talking about being a kid and breeding fish. Uh Messor Schmidt,
when he was a young man, he mixed sports and into a new sport.
>> I think you got I believe he did. >> I I believe
it too, actually. Um >> I can't believe these guys, they
just like go back and like reread their whole chat after a while.
They like ignore their chat and then after like 30 minutes or
an hour, they just go read all of the chat messages that they
got. That's a very interesting approach. >> Is it possible
they don't have a very fast moving chat? >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Probably. I just
>> praying. So, I'm a psycho because I like to create rare
fish and enjoy nutritionally dense meals.
>> this guy's snoring. >> And so, >> I love
these comments. I'm growing through you guys. There's so many
funny comments. You guys are great. >> We already talked
about No White Guilt. >> Yes, I did. That's why I brought
that up again because there's a few in here. Uh, did he speak
French and English or just French or or just English around the
>> Um, well, he speaks mostly in English. think the kids
mostly speak English because they watch their uh iPads 24/7
>> they're iPad kids and he um in fact at night like they
stay up watching shorts on YouTube and um like he won't brush
their teeth and do things like that with him but like they would
come and wake us up every 5 minutes. The boy wanted us to skip
ads on his phone. And at one point I was like, "Listen, JF, I
need sleep. He can he can sit through the ads at night, okay?"
And JF's like, "I am not going to neglect my child." And I'm
like, "That is
>> This is like the interaction you have with the kids
is when they're like watching YouTube and they're like, "Wait,
come skip the ads for me." I listen, maybe these kids were
they can't figure out how to skip the ads after it's happened
100 times.
Think JF is a YouTube thinks JF is a robot. Gummy bears is protein.
Gummy bears on iPads.
>> the year. I don't feel so bad about the [__]
I made with my children. >> Uh, so yeah, JF, he would always
brag about um how he was a programmer and he used to stay up
all night talking to friends on the dark web because he >> So
he said he did have access to the dark web. >> And now
he's neglecting the kids still because he's talking to hoes online.
>> Well, and Grock, I actually got an email today. Somebody
was concerned about the amount of time he spends online with
>> Like if they were sincere like Yeah. >> Oh, yes.
Allegedly. This is all alleged. >> This is all alleged.
Just like we said at the beginning of the stream. >> Come
after me. I don't care. I got nothing. I've got nothing. >> Okay.
And then uh no justice. So there's a lot of talk about how it
exists yet. >> Yeah. My my feelings. No, they're not. >> I
wish it could do that. It was that would be a wicked superhero
or superpower to have. >> And so there's a comment here.
Uh they took space away from a battered woman who was like likely
allegedly later murdered for a dude address was probably trying
to essay other women victims. >> It's horrible. >> I
can't believe it. Like sorry if you guys want to do the wool
politics. Get a different [__] get a goddamn shelter
for trans people then. I'm not that is I They have got to go.
They've got to pray that that is not true and that that can't
be proven. >> That's uh that's all of the what do you call
it? The that's a bunch of them commenting on her getting kicked
out of a a shelter for not liking the trans person there. >> and
she's saying if you like woke politics, get your own shelter.
>> But if anybody share this around, I don't know. Even
just clip that one part in Montreal. >> I think conservative
area. So
>> Like I have the receipts of everything I've said. Like
I can prove so much. >> Well, that's good. No, and I believe
you. I wouldn't have had you on. Rocky, women have been getting
raped in shelters by men calling themselves trans since they
started allowing them in. It's been going on for over a decade
now. We're going to have a trans debate. >> And I said
that to you when you first I'm so glad you're not like low or
something like cuz I What would you have done? Um Famicazi, I
did not know that women have been getting raped in women shelters
by men calling themselves trans since they started going on for
over a decade. That is and that needs to stop. That like is absolutely
unacceptable. >> That is up and that needs to stop now.
>> I'm going on the record is bad. How brave. But the more
that they talk about this, the more I think, okay, Mama JF,
you know, having problems. I don't understand why they didn't
put her in a
to get evaluated and make sure like she's mentally okay. She
didn't have to go back out on the street. >> I mean, I
don't know if any of this story is true. I don't know who who
this story is coming from, to be honest with you. I have a suspicion
that none of this is at least this story is like kind >> this
10 out of 10. I don't trust her. >> Yeah. I just don't
see it. I don't see it at all. >> So then of course the
you dirty housewives have to bring 10 out of 10 back for appearances.
She is a smart woman. Keeps it. >> She does. She does.
And you're allowed to show your face. You don't have to let JF
ruin that. You got beautiful smile. Fine. And you're fine. So
don't worry. Nobody's going to be like, "Oct, she's like a six."
Like that's rude. >> Well, who knows? Maybe maybe I'll
become a streamer and have a bigger show than JF. Oh yeah, I
think it would be very >> I think I'm more likable than
he is. >> Oh, you absolutely areable.
>> I do think that anybody everybody watching, you could
help Laura by like don't entertain JF anymore. Don't send him
super chats if you are. Just constantly demand him to be accountable.
He needs to find Laura. He needs to do a lie detector. He needs
to show up and he needs to do something. He needs to demand I
want to see him demand RCMP do something. I want to see more
from him as a father of the kids to solving this. Right. Mr.
Innocent, even though he beat her severely on a weekly basis.
>> Ask him those kinds of questions. >> Mhm. And
I think he'll he'll block you right away. So you only get one
chance. So make it good. >> You get one chance. Make it
good. Uh so the question I think we've already answered this
10 out of 10. Are you okay? Do you have support? Yes, she's got
her mom. I can't even imagine going through this. Oh my god.
>> Well, I do have family and friends who support me, which
did not have. So that's her fate was a little different. >> He
knew. He knew that she nobody was going to look for her. >> Yeah.
And of course JF is too much of a coward to show up.
>> I Jesus
comment we don't like the Frenchies down here. JF and the followup.
We like 10 out of 10 models. Well, I think that that I don't
know. Is there anything else that you guys wanted to show or
>> Uh, well, we we already went through the the the glamorous
shots of um our friend >> Uh, we do have Did you want to
go over the letter that he sent to >> really quick? Yeah,
cuz this this I want But just make sure you don't see the Chelsea.
This is a letter JF emailed to 10 out of 10 here while she had
preclapsia. It was in the hospital trying to >> It was
before that part.
it was before the postclia.
It was after he realized I didn't put the name on the birth certificate
>> and it's a it's a breakup letter to his his infant just
born few days old son. >> All right. >> Yeah. I'm
going to read you on screen because it's got some details I'm
going to leave out. >> So, dear child, uh, your mother
kidnapped you at birth and there was nothing I could do about
it. I'm
>> Why did we get primed for this? JF relevancy clips were
circulating a couple weeks ago. What?
I don't even know what that question is. Is that English?
Well, a couple weeks ago, people thought that um thought Mom
and JF was alive, but it's it's this who's been talking in the
background. Uh this woman on this podcast, Rocky, she's been
in conversations with this 10 out of 10 person for a couple weeks
now. So, the rumor just probably started spreading. >> Yeah.
Well, it could have, but I like I think this is a totally different
story. This is somebody like giving insight into JF's life. It's
not even um and JF's like responded to this. It's not even to
do with Mama JF. Although they they do have like a I guess a
really strong inclination towards asking questions about Mama
JF. It's really about this woman who apparently just had JF's
kid. >> I'm writing to you in the hope that she will be
honest enough to show you this letter once you are of age to
understand it. Your mom is a wonderful person who turned into
a monster the day you were born. Before that, she was telling
me that her Christian morals meant that she was honorable and
willing to submit to the will of a husband. I had made three
things very clear to your mom when we decided to marry each other.
So he he actually addressed this email to his child,
his his just born child. >> Did you get married?
>> Okay. Um one, I was already a dad to your brother and
sister and she would have to respect my absolute parental authority
over them. Your two your name would be blank. three blank was
an undesirable position and we would have would one day before
the kids be become adult move to Alaska. Sorry, it's really hard
to read because it's ESL.
Um, your mom was very engaged in these promises.
I regularly brought these subjects back while we were while we
conceived you to make sure that make sure those were the fundamentals
of our relationship.
She would send me pictures of Alaska saying we would have moosees
at our windows.
She put together a onesie for you as a baby and that was marked
as gerpi.
She also repeatedly confirmed that I was the ultimate decision
maker in your brother and sister's life. She took much
>> uh okay >> money and support from me while making
those promises and representations.
The day you were born everything changed. She >> Am I the
only one who's like, "This couldn't possibly have been forged.
This is literally exactly how JF speaks all the time." Like,
there's no way that this could be fake. Nobody could fake JF
speech like this. This is just so >> She also literally
did explain how she ran up a $1,000 bill at the spot. >> Yes.
Yeah, dude.
>> Named you. >> She needed She needed much money
while we were in the courting process. a different last name,
which I believe comes from her psychopath father.
So, >> [__] [__] He's just so bad.
It It just gets worse every second. >> Yeah. And I was
very sincere about moving to Alaska. I've wanted to since I was
young cuz I was a big supporter of Sarah Palin back in the day.
And I had a shirt that said if she can a moose, she can kick
some ass.
>> Well, that's I believe you were sincere in your relationship.
Uh
>> it's all it's always all your fault. >> Yeah.
Congratulations on the psychopath father because a father's position
is to protect his daughter until he's handed her over in marriage
as I stated during our live stream which he can't accept. >> If
anyone wasn't sure 10 out of 10 is
>> she did it in hiding while lying to me about it. She
then admitted that she had lied and admitted that she had reiged
on a past commitment unilaterally.
She also started developing delusions about your brother and
sister. Blank and blank. Uh they were blank and blank years old
at the time. She became paranoid that they would be violent,
underdeveloped, and dangerous for you. None of it was based on
factual observations, just pure delusions.
Finally, your mom suddenly abandoned the idea of >> This
literally dreamed about being Sarah Palin with the moose around
her. Amazing.
Incredible stuff. >> Living in Alaska when two weeks before
your birth, she was still sharing info to me about Alaska and
pictures.
Suddenly, the day you were born, it was like those discussions
had never
I tried extending,
excuse me, I tried extending an olive branch, which if it went
severely against my personal
oh, even if it went okay, God, I can't read his writing. I offered
that I would bring your brother and sister to a competent licensed
pediatrician. >> I'm actually
I don't know why, but I just got another glimpse of Rocky. If
she brings up if she brings up the anti-woke one more time, I'm
going to bury her. Okay. >> Okay.
H >> imagine having to be biting my tongue. >> Okay.
All right. Biting our tongue.
and that she would stop questioning the health and safety of
blank and blank. She started finding excuses for why she would
not accept even the opinion of a licensed pediatrician or psychiatrist.
Quote, "You are trying to set up a trap where they will reach
the conclusion you want them to reach, etc." End quote.
There, I understood that your mom's demands weren't based in
rational concerns. She would simply continue accusing your brother
and sister even in the face of an objective medical expert.
She was just inventing reasons for our family to be impossible
after promising for 2 years that it was impossible.
>> The fact that your mother planned and executed all of
this bait and switch over two years leading up to the birth,
your birth, because she suffers from a psychop psychopathy like
her father. Although I will give him okay over two years that's
kind of right for that to carry on for two years where
am I like
she's basically saying like oh this guy was a total monster and
it's like well you hung out with him for a really long time if
that was the case like a really long time. >> Well I thought
you said she only stayed for 14 months and then left. >> She
only stayed but they would have talked before that. >> Yeah.
No,
she said that she just read about him.
the news coverage. >> Yeah, but she Okay, >> she
went there almost immediately >> and then she was there
for six months in 2024. Okay. Yeah, you're right. You're right.
You're right. >> Yeah, she she's like, "Oh, I'm just hearing
about this guy and that he might have uh his wife. I got to DM
him and see what's up." >> What's this guy doing? >> Women
try to set up situations like this so they can escape accountability.
>> Um I'm trying to think of where we're going after this
guys. I think >> you said JF. >> What's up? >> You
said JF has a response, right? >> He does have a response.
Yes, we'll have to read both his tweet and his thing, but then
I'm trying to think of if I'm going to do another thing after
this. I'm thinking we'll we'll see. I've got quite a few things
in the docket. I might just take some time to do some politics
cuz honestly, I got to catch up on some of the politics stuff.
So, I'll be right back. >> Uh in internally justified that
they are not the ones at fault because they haven't technically
declared the separation, but any fair reading of the situation
shows that they have violated so many of the priors on which
the relationship was established.
that they have effectively voided marriage. This is why Christianity
is not enough. Too easy to fake and sooner or later the church
becomes filled with psychopaths claiming in the name of Jesus
but living in the standards only for the purpose of deception,
fraud and
Another reason women do these betrayals is to test authority
and to exhort
Extort emotionally. >> Exhort. Um, after betraying me on
all of her promises, your mom started complaining that I wasn't
listening to her suffering enough. But how can one continue the
delivery of emotional care while being so obviously backstabbed?
At some point, it is the responsibility of a man to delineate
the limits of appropriate behavior, and I cannot let deception
and fraud be the basis of my family life.
I also cannot go into the US with an immigration sponsor who
has demonstrated that she is willing to use fraud, deception,
and betrayal whenever she had the first chance to do so. So,
>> dude, JF is yapping to this kid. >> Uh, under
her care, she would have put me on the street with two children
on a >> I got to speed it up a little bit. >> I would
have nowhere to go and I would have had to sell my house to do
the move. My house. >> Oh, but it's actually Laura's, too.
Check the title. >> Yep. Uh, your mom knew all that and
decided to use your birth as a negotiating token in trying to
cancel her promises with me. I will always be available for being
your dad. But it is very like your mom will actively attempt
to make it impossible. I believe that fatherhood does not happen
over the phone or in pictures, but eye to eye between families
or between fathers and children who spend life together, not
a weekend or a summer. Thus, I'm extending the invitation to
her for a stable, fair parenting schedule where you will spend
50% of the years with me. I will not accept anything below that
because I believe a father should have at least equal influence
on the raising of a child. Again, most likely your mom will refuse
this and whatever reason she can for why she can't do it. Do
not believe her. She is a lying.
We are >> such a liar. >> We are thus left. It's
actually therefore left with all the likelihood that you will
have to be a young 18-year-old make the decision to come and
live with me if you decide. So, please note that you are a Canadian
citizen by birth. So, it should be no problem for you to pass
the border. >> How is How was that? You had to be >> [__]
just tipped $5.
>> Oh, let's go. I'm Al Harrington of Al Harrington's wacky
waving inflatable arm flailing tube man and I'm passing the savings
on to you. You
>> thank you very much resident for the $5.
Um what JF must have been drinking when he was ready. >> I'm
sorry that that cut off. Listen, I know the family guy ad. I
really appreciate it. Okay.
>> Kickpot can be a [__] >> Paragraph.
Um I hope we get to recover all the time that was stolen from
us. No doubt being raised by a single mom will have caused enormous
damage to your life. But I think you have half my genes and you'll
be strong enough to survive it and do the right thing for yourself.
Your mom will will try to subscribe you to college and stuff
in order to keep you around her. Just ignore her and come to
see me. I'll have the wisdom for you that neither college nor
a single mom can provide. >> He's insane. He's okay. 10.
One more thing. I forgot. You got to tell. Okay. So, she was
before the whole birth certificate stuff happened. The baby is
new. She said she had to go burp the baby because she just met.
Please tell the world what advice JF gave you for your baby,
your infant days old baby. >> He said, "Well, if you feed
it less, you won't have to burp it." >> And he was serious.
And then you said, "I'm not going to do that." What did he say?
What did he say back? >> He said that like
it's at one at one point. I don't >> He said that like
it's good for kids to learn to go without food for periods of
time because it's for survival. I don't think he said it at that
time, but it was previous to that and it freaked me >> Your
baby's still a month old, right? A month old at zero point in
that one month time span. Was that ever an appropriate thing
to say to ever? No. >> JF with the Spartan father strategies.
Let's go. >> We're not going to teach our baby survival
skills. Okay. We're just not >> Yeah. And like when JF
would say this stuff, I felt sorry for him. Like when I read
that letter, I felt sorry for him. I was like, I still hope he
gets help and takes responsibility, you know, and if he, you
know, turns himself in, that would give me a little respect for
him. >> Oh, yeah. He won't. He'll never admit. >> He's
lied too much and it's too deep. And I mean, whatever. J, I get
it. But the fact is, Jeff, you're not fooling anyone. We know
you're watching. Well, JF said about the welfare he draws on
the kids that the Canadian government is paying him to make babies.
>> He's he's But this is the same guy who hates immigration
and all that, right? Like any sense, >> you know, it like
as a conservative, I'm like I I don't think that's the kind of
family value I can get behind. >> No. Just insemination
and welfare >> Yeah. No. Um Okay.
>> It is sad, but he's I have no pity for him. I because
I actually just don't have any I just have pity for Laura, but
I wasn't attached to JF at all. And I understand you were, but
yeah. >> Yeah. No, JF, get the off your ass. And what is
your mother doing? You know, I know she's watching, too. >> Okay,
I think Listen, we've listened to basically this entire thing.
There's like 11 minutes left. It seems like they've been kind
of burned down. They've been burning. They've been burning down
for a while now. I want to move on to the JF response. Okay,
I'll read the tweet first. We got a tweet and then I've got a
video response from him as well. So, give me one second. I'll
find his tweet. Get a response to this overall interview. Okay,
let's uh let's check it out here real quick.
I don't know what these songs are, but okay. Turn it down here.
All right. My >> going to say bless you. >> Oh, God
bless you. >> Thank you. >> You're welcome. My ex
decided to appear on the Alberta housewives to talk about me,
which is her prerogative. Choosing to be a public personality
is anyone's choice to make. It comes with pros and cons. What
she has delivered is her interpretation and beliefs about our
relationship. Some of it is accurate. Some of it is conveniently
hides. Some of it, sorry, some of it conveniently hides what
would make her look bad and some of it is outright delusional.
I honestly do not have much interest to enga much of an interest
to engage on this or to make her look bad. I do simply want to
correct the most obvious lies and delusions. In summary, if you
want my side of the story, this woman contacted me and wanted
to have babies. We got to know each other over months. She promised
me she would love me forever and wanted to form the Gary family
with me. >> Bro, this is just like us. >> Okay. She
then changed her but her mind on the Jesus on the day of her
birth
on the day of the birth of our child changed his name against
what we had agreed and started acting threatening towards me
and my already existing family. Thus, I had $20 for the accent.
You want me to try to do it with the accent? Okay, I'll go back
to the beginning. All right. >> Do you even know this accent?
>> I just I wing it. Okay. My ex >> my ex decided
to appear on the Abuta housewives podcast to talk about I get
Indian after a while. I don't know how to help it man >> to
talk about me which was which is her
>> Choosing to be a public personality is anyone's choice
to make. It comes with pros and cons. >> What she has delivered
is her interpretation and beliefs about our relationship.
Some of it is accurate. Some of it conveniently hides what would
make her look bad. And some of it is outright delusional.
I honestly do not have much of an interest to engage all on this
or to make her look bad. I do simply
want to correct the most obvious lies and delusions on her part.
In Israeli Indian. Okay. Okay. All right. In
>> if you want my side of the story, this woman contacted
me and wanted to have babies.
We got to know each other over months. She promised me she would
love me forever and wanted to form the Gary family with me. She
then changed her mind on the day of the birth of our child, changed
his name against what we had agreed and started acting threatening
toward me and my already existing family. Thus, I had no choice
but to split in particular because I had imposed the respect
of my of my already existing life as a condition fundamental
to our relationship from the beginning. I'm happy in life with
my children whom I care for well and I wouldn't allow a woman
to join my life if it interfered with my existing life.
I did not annoy her about it. If I had, there'd be more there'd
be compromising texts of mine since we were in contact remotely.
After she betrayed me, I asked would she either fix would she
either fix her behavior or I I asked that she either fix her
behavior or stop contacting me and told her she was relieved
of any obligation towards me that we were separated. She kept
trying to contact me for about 2 weeks despite my request for
her to stop. That's all. Much of our relationship happened at
the distance over the phone because she lived and gave birth
in the US and I live in Canada. For those who care about the
details, there are misrepresentations in her interview. Hold
on. Let me here. I'll listen. I'll listen to JF. You guys think
it's not going well enough? I'll listen to JF for a second. Let
me listen.
>> You don't need to be right.
>> Shut up. Shut up. >> Wave
JF. You know, >> I could, but you know, >> Medina
Wells doesn't need game. Really? >> Okay. I maybe I could
get a little more of this. Okay. She claims we immediately
met without getting to know each other. We actually got to know
each other for about 6 months with daily video calls before we
met. She claims that I was pressuring her to have babies quick.
Pressuring isn't the right word. I was arguing in favor of that.
She was agreeing all along and thought she had been too quick
to make babies and regretted that and now wanted me to go quick.
She has all these complaints about our life together and our
encounter, but she spent two whole years
trying to get inseminated by me. It is fascinating how these
micro complaints
show up when she has decided to go on her own.
She describes my other children incorrectly when she has not
met them or seen them for more than a year. Uh, the vast majority
of her claims about them are pure delusions.
Um,
okay.
She called my children.
That's what she did. She called your children. She completely
made up the idea that I would have admitted to her that I used
to beat Allora the hardest I can. That I had no choice to do
it because she was calling me a
>> He's like, "She claimed I said I beat her the hardest
I can. I obviously held
>> That is completely untrue. I have never beaten Allora.
Conveniently, while 90% of our relationship is on phone and on
record, my ex made up a story that I would have admitted that
this during an unrecorded car ride and claims it led to her led
her to believe that I had beaten and killed.
Consider how unrealistic this narrative is.
According to my ex, she would have started believing I was a
murderer, but she still continued getting inseminated
until she could have my baby for months. >> You sound like
an Adam Sandler. >> Toxmosis says you sound like Count
Choula.
Shut up. I'm I'm trying different things here, okay? I'm trying
to find something that works. >> Why are you guys [__]
about it? I'm trying my best to find something that works right
now. Okay, >> it's all working.
>> It's working. Consider how oh we did this part already.
According to her narrative, she would have continued willfully
getting inseminated to get the baby of someone she suddenly knew
was a wife beater and a murderer over multiple months. Unreal.
But that admission
did not happen in this narrative is false.
Dear scene is also false. I did not turn around. We saw a deer,
a dead deer on the road and I commented how it did not look like
a car collision, but rather a clawed animal attack. I drove past
and there were no such moment where I turned around or got out
of the car to look at the deer in amazement.
Lol. Also, Lolita's story is completely false and invented.
Also, I am not on government welfare. I live from savings and
active incomes. And she has no idea of my finances.
>> You sound like Tommy Wiso from the room. Okay, you guys
are saying I sound like a trillion other things. All right. >> Why
does she have no idea of your finances? I thought that's what
bagged
>> Well, he was lying obviously the whole >> Yeah,
I'm thinking >> hilariously. That's this ex admits I have
never physically hurt her any in any way. She has but she has
decided she thinks I am a murderer and wife beater of women of
other women. Women will develop that kind of beliefs when they
need to justify taking your kids.
You would carve chicken with large knives.
Good memes.
He has very little Bitcoin left. And
did he type out? >> He did type out. >> Oh my goodness.
>> He has
>> He literally is like max villaining right now. Or villain
maxing. What would you say? >> Villain maxing? >> Vilifying
himself. I don't know. He's basically always doing that. I don't
know. I think he must have had like a resurgence in popularity
when he did it the first time. Sorry to bring up old memes, but
I went back to catch up on Colorate and that even less guy said,
"That's it." around 20 times. That guy is so cool. That's it.
Okay. Well, uh, nailed the laugh. Did I nail the laugh? Well,
that's good. Okay, he has a video response as well. Let's check
that out for the sake of the YouTube video. Okay, for the sake
of the YouTube video, we should check that out. Give me two
let me find Let me find this real quick.
YouTube video. 3 minutes into this VOD, we've got his response.
>> there's Daily and I'd like to interview you. Well, sure.
You know that anyone can send me an email. >> Well, sure.
You know that anyone can send me an email and uh that is how
we talk in the French like JFK
>> or DM on Twitter. >> I didn't realize you're so
monotone. I thought he had more showmanship to him. >> DM
on Discord. That airline, that's an epic airline. Okay, shut
up. >> I'm always open to interviews.
So
to interview >> Yeah, I've already I've already >> interview
him. >> I've already I've already
Wait, what should I do? >> Interview him >> denial
of some of the crazy stuff she >> but to I'm not going
to do a detailed denial tonight. Tonight I want to drop a truth
bomb
because there's these ways that people lie to themselves and
if you just drop one truth
the whole narrative falls down and her whole story and what the
Alberta housewives has con concocted with her
um it's
>> all annihilated out of existence by a single fact. >> Okay.
I separated from this woman.
Okay. Up to a month ago,
this woman was loving me. Was getting
That Jesus, that was not what he said in that letter. He said
she cut it off.
>> This woman was loving me. Was getting inciminated by
me. >> Was getting inseminated by me. She was getting inseminated
by me. you know, >> was making my baby
through being
married to was about to marry me
uh up to one month ago. So when you drop that truth bomb and
I decided that I was separating from her.
When you drop that truth bomb, you start realizing that, hey,
doesn't make sense that she would have acquired the conviction
that I'm a murderer a year and a half ago.
What? You got inciminated by a murderer?
Wait, you knew he was a murderer, but you stayed kind to him.
You didn't run away. You didn't fear for your life and run away.
No, she stayed with me. Accepted my sperm. Now she's out there
saying he's fat. >> Accepted my sperm. >> Accepted
my sperm.
>> It's as low as this the show. He's fat.
>> Uh, let me drop another truth bomb. The very first time
I spoke to this woman, I said the following. That that was maybe
the first sentence.
Like after hello, hello, how you doing? >> Kind of. No,
it's going to be like uh want to have babies. He's going to say
something immediately. Immediately he's going to say that this
is how he because I know that's how he spit game. Okay. Immediately
he's like, "Yeah, you want kids? You want kids? Got kids? No.
Want >> I want you to know I said this quote quote per
quote. Okay. I said I want you to know a couple of things.
I'm 41 year old. I mean I I was maybe not 41 back then, but I'm
whatever age I was back then. I'm fat. You're gonna and if you
want to have a relationship, >> I'm fat.
>> Listen, I'm fat. Okay, that's it. The ball game. >> He
knows. He knows that his camera cuts off right there and that
when he talks to a woman, he has to explain what the [__]
is below the camera.
>> cuz he's trying to hit
>> ship with me. And I have children already, okay?
And if you want a relationship with me, I can do maybe some jogging
and maybe being with with you and then Okay. I don't believe
him. I don't believe anybody meets a woman who's like, "Listen,
I'm fat now and maybe I'll like lose a little bit of weight,
but probably not that much. So, you got to be in for this right
now." Okay. >> I don't believe that. I do not believe somebody
says this [__] That's crazy. >> Someone like
him, they're going like the Fuentes route,
right? What is that clip from Fuentes? She's like, "No, you have
to deal with me being gross." >> Yeah, I'm going to be
gross. I'm not going to clean up. I'm not going to I'm not going
to lose weight. I'm not going >> That's after you trap
a woman into marrying you. That's not how you get the woman in
the first place. He was like, "No, we're going to get married
and then I'm going to trap her into it." That's way different.
That's like a totally different thing. >> Yeah. That's
a strategy. >> I mean, it's a strategy that people could
put into place. Probably not a good one to say happy. >> Okay.
I'm just explaining to you what he said is way different than
JF's thing of like I'm already fat and I'm going to stay fat.
That's crazy. >> You wouldn't live by this. >> I
wouldn't live by either of those
>> I don't believe in that. >> Mama JF donated $20.
Help. Yes. Trying to kill me. >> He's trying to kill me.
>> Sorry. We got a $20 donation from Mama JF. Thank you
very much, Mama JF. Appreciate the donation. Appreciate the
>> Me so much cheese. >> So much cheese.
Uh, I don't know if we're going to go beyond like uh I'm probably
going to keep streaming because I just I feel like I'm enjoying
right now, but um I don't know how far we're going to go beyond
this. I think it's we've got like a couple minutes of this left
and then I got some other things I might want to take a look
at really quickly. So, we'll see. We'll see where we're going
>> with me. I can do maybe some jogging and maybe being
with me with with you and in love, maybe I'll lose a couple of
pounds, but I will always be fat. I will always have health issues
related to this
and I will always be first and foremost the father of my children
and you will never have a say other than voluntary engagement
with me. Maybe you you have some preferences and I let them in
but I will be the ultimate decision maker of the life with my
children and how I raise them and any babies we make
>> Yeah, true.
First thing you know need to know about me, I'm fat and I will
never change. Second thing you need to know about me, I put a
priority on my kids. >> Yeah. Amazing.
>> That's incredible. That is actually
>> Father of the year. >> Together, you can you can
decide. If we disagree on something, you win.
>> Oh, $20 for the voice. Oh, Smatic. I was not even watching
for the 20 bucks. I just was like, "Oh, people want me to do
the voice. I'll try to do the voice." But thank you. I appreciate
it, buddy. >> But for my existing children,
I will forever make all of the decisions in their lives. And
to the extent that we disagree, I will win.
It was a very very clear deal. So why why why did she get inciminated
for 2 years
by someone who she believed was a fat ugly wife murderer?
That doesn't make sense. That doesn't make sense. And
well, I mean,
I'm sorry, but you were a fat wife murderer and she basically
accepted that. She We ultimately have to figure out what the
piece was that she added in there that changed her mind. It's
It's probably because every woman you knock up is
>> I
It could be that. I'm just saying that like she obviously like
you were obviously fat. You said she you were fat and you were
obviously she thought you were a wife murderer. So like those
were already on the table. It's like he's like Ola. She's pretending
she thought I was a fat ugly wife murderer for years. It's like
no, she knew you were those things. It's like we're trying to
figure out what actually put her off of you. >> It doesn't
make sense. Oh, that's a great point, Smatic. He's not he's not
slinging potent
potent seed if he's spending two years trying to get her pregnant
and isn't getting it done. >> It's because it's invented
this whole narrative that she's been developing
beliefs about me. The reason she is currently coming out and
trying to make trouble is that she wants to intimidate me and
I am currently the victim of crimes. Okay, literal crimes. crimes
that could met that could put some people in jail,
including her and from Iraqi, the Alberta housewives, down to
this morning. I am receiving threats by email and they're they're
showing me videos and pictures of me, including pictures of me
in
uh underwear and with my children.
Wait, were they showing a bunch of other [__] on
there? I saw a few pictures with pictures in underwear >> and
and they're >> that's real >> and I don't know what
the they want. What do you want? You want money? You You want
to stress me? You think you're going to cancel JF with private
You have no idea. You have no idea
what I've gone through. Oh, okay. He was saying idea. I was like,
you have no idea. There's like
>> like picture ID, photo ID, what >> to be here.
I do not submit to
I am a trained agent of resistance
against extortion blackmail.
You will never
with my mind.
I am so ready for more.
You have no idea. And yet they're sending me and here
yesterday I actually took a picture of my legs and I tweeted
it >> because it's like
okay. So so that's
uh hold on. >> Are we going to look up his legs? >> Uh
media post from JF yesterday he tweeted a picture of his legs.
Let's go.
This is the how
dude this is not a good this is not a good ratio. This is like
literally the pear-shaped thing, isn't it? God damn it, JF. Like,
look at how wide his legs are compared to his hips and then compared
to everything else going on here. He's got no width to him. Okay,
he's got no width. What's going on? Where's the width, man? >> Why
did he do Why did he post this? >> I don't know why he
posted cuz he's not He's not going to give into extortion, obviously.
Okay, he can't be extorted. >> Maybe he is a gamma male.
I don't know about the romantic thing. I think he's secure in
his masculinity. I think he's perfectly fine with how short
and
unmasculine he looks.
>> That's the biggest thing you got.
>> maybe just feminine. Not on me.
>> Underwear. JF, I'm going to take a picture of myself
in underwear. Now they send me another video.
You better not argue too much because we have this video of you.
I will describe right here what the >> Did they really
send you a video of them doing a Mama JF impression? That's up,
>> Too much because we have this video of you.
I will describe right here what the video does. So, so it's like
the exclusivity poof is stolen. Doesn't exist anymore.
It's a video of me in underwear.
It's 4:00 a.m. approximately
and I've just gotten woken up by one of my child uh crying
and I step out of bed and I'm like I just got woken up like I'm
hearing I'm hearing ah daddy
>> and I I walk like this in underwear
and
and my son is on the bed. Okay, he's on his bed and and she's
filming. So, how this is filming secretly this scene. My child
is on my on the bed. I see >> This doesn't sound like a
great video to be sharing around. >> He has a dirty diaper.
He just pooed during the night.
And so I'm like I'm totally like I'm almost sleeping awake. I'm
sleeping and standing
and I I open his diaper.
I wipe his butt. Wipe his >> Of course he was going to
say that. >> Everything is clean. Getting the poo out.
Getting the poo out on the side. Getting the poo out. I drop
the diaper.
Put a new diaper.
He's crying now. He's calming down a little bit. Put his pants.
And then I I go back to bed. Like, is this is this >> I
mean, is the point of the video that you didn't wash your hands?
Cuz it sounds a little bit like you may not have washed your
hands, which is a bit concerning.
Just a just a little bit.
>> Is this the worst you got, ladies?
Is this the worst you got?
I'm
sleeping
standing.
I'm barely awake and I take good care of my son
clean as butt.
Is that the best you got? >> Holy.
It's like if you're going to extort me, extort me with something
good. Being sniffed on the ass of a
>> Wait, but do you do that? Yeah. is
>> is he saying that there's there listen go to some of
the things I've actually >> are these confessions >> get
me on human trafficking okay you have no idea how easy it was
for me to get mommy JF back in the United States
this scene that I just described is what a good father does even
if he's half asleep I wouldn't want to be any other person
I wouldn't want to be any other person than this all of this
to Hey,
the representation that is done by this ex on Alberta Housewives
is um
is crumbling once you realize that she didn't leave me. She didn't
run away from me. She was still making my babies up to a month
ago.
She was still loving me and still sending me text messages of
love. >> Saying it is just weird. Okay.
because we've been living uh separately for for 9 months because
she wanted to do her pregnancy in the US now. Oh, I guess Cherry,
that's apparently Tree of Logic's theory. Mackenzie Carter Cameron
just said that's Tree of Logic's theory was that JF trafficked
Mama JF. >> Oh, yeah. Yeah, that's probably where I heard
it from the when I said people were saying that he probably sold
her.
>> I was probably watching a tree of Logic stream. Yeah.
>> Okay. The reason she comes out is she wants to cause
nervousness in me because she wants vengeance for the fact that
I I separated from her. Okay. It's like get your get your little
vengeance, but it's not going to last long. And she she thinks
she's going to cut. She thinks I'm terrified about the Child
Protective Service of Alberta.
I'm not. I'm not because I take good care of my children. I'm
not because when I sleep,
I'm still a good dad. See, when I'm at my worst in underwear,
I'm still a good dad.
And so I I I'm not nervous about I'm not nervous about the the
kind of trouble they're trying to seed or whatever it is. Someone
is telling me, Jeff, we need to ban this guy.
Uh
okay, this
Yeah, let's ban this guy. This guy keeps coming back.
So, let me tell you the real story. of what happens and the reason
I I had to leave her because it's not an easy decision. It's
one I believe it's the first woman I truly explicitly say I am
separating by. So this woman came into my life wanted okay so
so I warned her like look I'm happy in life I have my children
I could die could die in in 20 years from now having accomplished
nothing more and I would still have had a successful life and
so you come in as a b bonus and know that I'm fat I'm I'm stubborn
I'm also a very good father and I will never let you
I will never let you uh change that and so we can live in the
same house. You can even participate as a stepmom to the extent
that you like it, but you have nothing to do with them and you're
not forced and you deliver the services of a stepmom as you wish.
And as far as the decisions goes, they're all mine. They're all
mine. It is my legal right. I have also responsibilities toward
mama JF. I have responsibilities to raise these children
uh in in the the setting and the the environment and the kind
of parental philosophy that both I and Mama JF shared which is
basically liberal libertarian
parental philosophy
which means very
selfinitiated
self-otivated children. Did they selfinitiate the nocturnal sleep
>> Is he's trying? Yeah, his kids vote. His kids voted
and they wanted to be on the night shift. All right. >> Yes.
Absolutely. >> My children are to put money on it. Did
he ex-wife? Um, honestly, I don't know. Like I It seems like
some weird [__] went down with his ex-wife, but I
like realistically I don't know.
I It feels like he knows what happened to his ex-wife and he's
not being truthful is basically what I could say. I couldn't
care less what his rhyme or reason is, what his excuse is. If
your wife is having problems and you just let her wander off
into the woods, you drop her off. You aid in her just being a
nomad. You like you are you're abusive. >> Not unlike his
parenting style. All right. He's got a very libertarian philosophy
for his wife's movements. Okay. Migration patterns. >> You're
a piece of [__]
>> in terms of their grade, in terms of reflect just as
just that >> advancement through the scholar system because
I homeschool them >> and most importantly
they choose when they do school they choose when they do arts
they choose when they do math >> they choose when they
do school >> they choose when they do school >> this
is that's child abuse >> uh it might be yeah >> no
like in the states that's child abuse if you don't put your child
into a schooling program or into an approved homeschool school
regiment,
you are abusing your child. Your child is going to grow up and
unsocialized
and behind for their like developed years. >> that it is
abusive. >> Yeah, I could see that. >> Imagine being
20 years old, not knowing how to read or write because your parents
said you do whatever you want, baby,
and now you're like a legal adult and you have no skills. You
can't even communicate effectively.
Yeah. I mean, obviously giving your kids too much too much choice
is just bad and like abusive on its face. Yes. >> Yeah.
For sure. And at at their choice speed,
they are in advance
on
the the standards on the the average and the what is required
of children in general up to a year in advance
for my daughter. Uh so I take very good care of them and it was
very clear we can do whatever you like. We can inciminate. I'm
going to have a baby with you. We can form a family. But if I
have to create a house with two floors, I don't care. I will
always be their father.
And that eventually is the one condition of my >> floors
have to do.
>> I have no idea. >> To create a house with two
floors. I don't care. I will always be their
>> Oh, maybe like >> he puts the different separation
on different floors. Yeah, I don't know. >> You can live
upstairs with your baby. My babies will be downstairs. >> My
We I'll be their father. Okay. They're my experiment. You don't
get to [__] with my experiment. Okay. >> Or
not. >> My children will be upstairs and you stay the away
from them up there. >> Do not [__] with my
experiment. Okay. This is my >> daughter is going to say
ball when she wants to say ball.
pretty amazing. >> And that eventually is the one condition
of my couple that my ex came to break
and that led me to be forced to separate from her. And the problem,
and by the way, this whole this whole stream, the goal is not
to to frame my ex as bad. I don't care about ruining her reputation
the way she did yesterday. uh the way she did well 2 days ago
approximately when she came out and started claiming that I was
a wife beater. Oh, and by the way, she she acknowledges that
I'm not a wife beater of her. I'm not a wife beater of her.
I'm a wife beater maybe of some other woman.
She has the impression that I may have beaten other woman. Now
consider the miracle
that I have so much as a wife beater and a murderer. I would
have so much self-control
that I was able to do a whole two-year long relationship with
this woman without ever beating her. It's like I'm a I'm a conditional
wife. >> He's like a saint. Yeah. >> So she goes
out to ruin my reputation. She films all these secret videos
which by the way I saw all of this coming. I knew this was in
the I knew when she started converting toward more threatening
behavior, I knew that she was gathering evidence on me. And so
that's one thing to know, guys. Uh when you're in a relationship,
understand
there's months of relationship at the end where she's not even
interested in you anymore. She's just gathering evidence. And
you have to you have to outplay them on that.
The real the real issue that happened in this couple
>> is that this person, my ex, is socially
And I'm not even saying this
to
shame her.
I find this the cutest thing about her. I'll be honest. The cutest
>> he loves.
>> This is
bizarre,
>> I don't know. It's weird. Is it weird? >> Sweet
summer child. You don't know anything. You're like you're like
a child in your brain. I'm >> interested in that. >> I
was [__]
>> She's socially in a way you can't
like Mama JF was a normie in terms of her understanding of
social relationships compared to this girl. So, we're talking
about some >> Jesus.
God damn it. I just went to take a bite of his food, but he just
said
was annoy me, dude. Okay. Okay. Was is Okay. The tense is like
a little bad >> I was just laughing that he's basically
saying she's even more than the woman who was like visibly.
>> No, but he also referred to Mama JF in the past. >> You
did? >> Cuz he knows that he killed her. And you know what's
crazy is still is calling your dead ex-wife
Mama JF still. That's like a pet name, isn't it? >> I don't
know. No, she's still the mother of your kids, I guess. I don't
know. I don't know. It is a little weird. >> Someone who
has such a a a deep autism and it's such a specific autism
that she is unable to process context.
Okay. Cutest thing about her,
a lost artist of the US who's coming to get inciminated by JF.
But she has this
she has this deficit
>> deficit deficit >> emotional deficit >> you
know >> this deficit >> he probably loves those [__]
on the whatever podcast who can't grasp a
>> who can't tell you >> he donates for Andrew Wilson
to ask the question so you can go like oh she couldn't get it
all right let's try to let's slide in those Insta DMs >> see
if she wants to fly out
which to me has always been
very minimal. Didn't bother me. I found I found it cute. Sometimes
she you know when you're in a conversation and everyone knows
what people are feeling, where people come from, she would be
on some discussions. She would be totally
beside the track like not understanding innuendos, not understanding
how the other person feel, not understanding maybe that the other
person is joking.
So all of this very cute, very heartwarming. Yeah. >> But
eventually this feature of our mind
>> came to
break
our relationship
and it happened about
10 months
between 10 months to a year and a half ago. I started seeing
signs that unfortunately this ex was an unfit
>> I'm not saying she's not able to care for a child. theoretically
some other child, some child of hers,
but her lack of understanding of other
made her role as a stepmom more and more bad for my children.
And >> and I was >> the socially woman that you brought
in that doesn't really pick up or perceive what other people
are feeling. not a not very good at raising your stepkids
or her stepkids. Yeah. Kind of a problem >> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Was and to give you to give you the example because
we're not she wasn't dangerous to my children ever and she didn't
hurt them. Okay. But just to give you an idea of the those were
very small issues, very small emotional issues that would have
been easily fixed. But for example, you know, my children are
you
>> goes to a father who let lets them set their schedule.
So my children, they expect when they wake up, papa, I want to
do schooling today. Papa, I want to do math. I don't care about
math today. I want to do art. And it's like, you know what? You
got it. They are they are, "Oh, papa, I want to to do some cakes.
I want to to bake today. I want to
I want to go to the park. I want to see our friend.
>> So that's how my children live. And this ex came in
and I >> That is crazy. Instilling no sense of like discipline
in your kids at all. You just like let them do whatever they
want to do whenever they want to do it. >> Had I had very
great hopes that she would be >> a potentially good
>> I'm sorry. You've seen his body. He doesn't have any
discipline. Yeah, but I mean it's your kids. Your kids have to
have some discipline. Okay. >> You have to discipline yourself
to be able to teach discipline discipline to >> Uh no,
you don't have to have that much
>> But you get to make the rules. Okay. Autocrats can teach
discipline in other people without having themselves.
>> When you make the rules, you're like, "No, no, no. All
you have to do is have more discipline than the kid." >> That
Well, here's the thing. You actually can't teach discipline to
a kid when it demands that you be disciplined and sit there and
make them do it yourself. You can if you sit there and do it.
>> And most people when their ego is threatened, like if
you're an adult telling a kid what to do, they can sit there
and pretend to be disciplined at
>> Yeah. I think you could do it very easily by even bad
parents could teach their kids some kind of discipline. >> Yes,
Maddic. I think he he's doing like childled parenting, which
is not a >> This is like why you should put your kids in
actual school as well, is they can learn it from other sources,
too. You have to do it all day. >> This is why kids grow
up and hate their hippie parents. Yeah, >> but stepmom
or that at least if it didn't work that she could be neutral
and stay away. Just don't just don't mess up this beautiful
father child relationship that we have going because my children
they they're never in crisis when they're with me. They're never
in
in in having their needs not met. They get everything they want
with me and not in a kind of crowning king or queen treatment
style. Why? >> I'm I'm laughing at at DJ Denkkey cuz the
kids they don't speak in full sentences. So, it's got to be what
this guy is saying. He goes, "This dude is talking to his daughter
like she's lassie. She's yelling ball ball over and over." And
he's like, "Oh, you want to do organic chemistry?" >> Hey,
Johnny fell down the well, Lassie. Lead the way.
Okay. Okay.
>> But in the libertarian philosophy of parenting style
where okay, you have a need, I'm going to address it
and oh, if your need is capricious or if you're demanding stuff
that doesn't make sense, no, then there's a no. The stepmom came
in with her lack of social understanding
and she confronted my children with a completely different parental
And these children they they I'm at the center of their lives.
I am their only remaining parent. Okay.
>> And
it created it created an emotional clash because there they are
like, "Oh yeah, papa, I want to do uh I would like to eat chicken
nuggets." But my ex comes in and no chicken nuggets. We're doing
the Christmas tree. And my children were like,
"I want chicken nuggets.
Let's do the Christmas tree later. I want chicken nuggets."
>> Why did they speak like that? Why did he do that, boys?
Are his kids extra?
>> Uh, why is he doing the mama jam impression? That's
crazy. >> Can you rewind? >> Oh my god.
>> No, no chicken nuggets. We're doing the Christmas tree.
And my children were like,
"I want chicken nuggets.
Let's do the Christmas tree later. I want chicken nuggets." Those
kids are definitely JF and Mama JF's kids. Okay. I'm sorry. I'm
sorry. >> And my ex would be like, "No, no chicken nuggets.
We're doing the Christmas tree." And I understand that with some
uh with some children
that would be okay. Some children will follow you on
on this type of behavior, but not with my children. My children
are habituated to a completely different lifestyle than this.
And I would say we were at the two extremes
of this continuum between libertarian and authoritarian.
I'm not an authoritarian. Never been. It's never been in my heart.
And so, so like basically
if his kids come and and they haven't eaten in a while and they're
like, "We have chicken nuggets." He's like, "Yes, I I must make
you chicken nuggets now." And then if they if they only just
had chicken nuggets a little while ago, they don't eat them.
He'll say, "No, okay. Otherwise, it's no, go do whatever you
want." And the the stepmom or this, you know, 10 out of 10 girl
is like, "Hey, we should make a Christmas tree." And they're
like, "No, chicken nuggets. >> Not make a Christmas tree.
Put up a Christmas tree. Decorate the Christmas tree. Whatever."
Okay. And apparently these kids can't be told what to do. JF
only ever lets them tell him what they need at any given moment
in time. He does not tell them what to do. >> Well, the
the thing that I want to know is because he says she's not a
good stepmother because she's socially she can't pick up on what
people want. She can't pick up on the what the kids want. And
she's over here saying they don't speak in complete sentences.
Do you think they're like saying
they're not saying I want chicken nuggets? Are they saying like
non chicken non like what are they saying? How is she and not
picking up that they want chicken nuggets?
>> Yeah. Who knows what this communication looks like?
No, we want the chicken nuggets now. Not the not Christmas tree
>> Cuz you could be putting chicken nuggets in the oven
while you start decorating Christmas tree. Yeah.
>> I This sounds weird. I want more details about this
specific story. I I started noticing those signs. Uh >> you
should interview him for that. >> Yeah, we should >> reach
out to him. I want to know more about the Christmas tree chicken
nugget >> Okay, please tell us, Jeff. Tell us more about
your libertarian philosophy on parenting, you know, a year and
a half >> And I'm like, you know what? I'm going to give
a chance first. I try to explain to to this new stepmom. Look,
look, pay attention to what she just said. She wants the chicken
nuggets. So, she's not going to be interested in doing other
things. Why don't you meet her need of chicken nugget or let
me handle the chicken nuggets? But don't try to force her into
an activity that she doesn't have her mind ready for. And unfortunately,
and this is this is the big fatality of this relationship.
instead of just changing her behavior or accepting to step back,
the stepmom
developed an absolute psychotic sets of beliefs
about
my children. And this is when you know they're they're becoming
dangerous
she started having the concept. >> It's not completely
wrong.
>> These children are broken. There's something wrong with
these children. They're always yelling at me. There's something
wrong with these children. They're tapping on the floor. There's
something wrong with these children. They don't like Christmas
trees.
But she misunderstood.
It's not that they don't like Christmas trees. We do we do colleges
and art arts every day right now.
>> They like it and they love >> Wait, did you hear
that? >> She's she's misunderstanding. She's not perceiving
correctly. She's like they're tapping on the floor. That was
the daughter. The daughter is stomping on the ground when she
saw the video of Mama JF. She was communicating. She didn't have
the words. She can say, "I want chicken nuggets." But she can't
say the words. He Mama JFed.
They will love doing anything. >> But you have to choose
your moments.
>> Well, this is what they said about Mama JF as well.
Shut it down. And I don't know if we could really believe that.
There's clearly something going on with Mama JF that was a little
concerning some of the time. Okay. >> Our self >> none
of these people. They're all but they don't deserve this. >> What
do you mean? >> The women that >> go to him, the
women that he pick, they are but they don't deserve what he does
to them. >> They don't deserve it now. >> Self motivated
beings. I made >> Nobody deserves to be inseminated by
JF. Okay. That way I habituated them to this and coming to break
this dynamic
was the stepmom who unfortunately has a special she's very intelligent
very intelligent capable of doing a 2hour podcast about me you
know
and speaking in eloquent sentence but she has a very specific
deficit
she doesn't understand emotional contextual processing
so When my children were like, "No, no, I'm not doing this."
She reacted by saying they >> I don't She never said that.
She said they're underdeveloped.
>> right. This one is nonverbal. This one's slow to communicating.
>> She was a little more specific. Yeah. She didn't just
call them. >> Doesn't know how to put on clothes. This
one just learned how to say ball. >> She said they were
She didn't say they were Yeah.
buffer from a serious
mental psychiatric
problem
that needs to be fixed by medication and a doctor and it's like
you're with the wrong guy. You're with the wrong guy. And by
the way, I call her a [__] lovingly here.
I never call her [__] in person, but I'll call her
a [__] now that she now that she claims I'm a murderer.
You're the >> What did he mean right there? >> You're
with the wrong guy. Is it because he loves like I'm not getting
that >> I don't know. But he's just like now that she thinks
I'm a murderer. It's like no, she got attracted to you because
she thought you were a murderer. That's like literally how she
found you.
>> What are you talking about? He's like he's like totally
twisted this. He's like, "Yeah, now she now she says I'm a fat
murderer." It's like no one you said that your first move when
you started talking to her was I said you said I'm >> and
that's how it is. Okay. I'm never >> I'll try jogging,
but it's always going to be like this. >> Yeah. I'm always
going to be fat. Okay. I'm always going to be unhealthy cuz I'm
>> We could try jogging. It's not going to change it.
>> And two, and then and then you knew that she found you
through an interview that somebody else did about you killing
your wife, like content other people did about you, your wife.
So, she thought those two things from moment one. >> But
she is with the wrong guy. And that's why he's laughing here.
You with the wrong guy. Cuz the second thing after I told you
about me being fat was
you're not going to tell me how to raise my kids because I think
JF literally is completely fine with having kids. I think he
would make them.
>> he's got like a fetish for it. >> Maybe maybe
>> which is child abuse. He got he got money from Jeff
Epstein and he got invited to some parties and he wasn't into
the same thing all those other people's were and he was like
you know
those kids I could totally go to Epstein's island but they need
a kid. Okay, cuz I can't do I'm not doing anything with those
normal kids. I need to make a kid.
>> I think he just wanted to just >> I think he wanted
to remake whatever happened to the Island Boys. >> I'm
like so tired. >> Those two came out for sure. >> Oh,
the Island Boys. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> Uh that was a thing
for a while. I forgot about those guys for a second. >> They
are still around somewhere. >> Are they? >> Hi. Definitely
>> doing Only Fans together still. >> I God, I hope
not. >> God, I hope not. >> You You tested the wrong
guy on this. The fact is I believe I do believe that certain
children have certain major diagnostic problems. They need to
get diagnosed and they need to get fixed medically, psychologically,
psychotherapy, whatever. But uh but this this this
issue
that I've talked about
uh is absolutely misunderstood by her because she cannot acknowledge
her fault.
She thinks that they must be wrong to her. She can only be right
because she has the authoritarian mind.
She she doesn't study the possibility that hey you know with
a little rounding of your behavior with a little chicken nugget
here and then then we'll do the the Christmas tree all of it
wouldn't have happened. You wouldn't have confrontations like
this.
Now there are some people who are good inside and who are capable
of saying okay you know maybe the these children need some different
handling. And by the way, what I was demanding of this uh
what I was demanding of this uh stepmom
is absolutely minimal a minimal understanding of these things.
And let me tell you the the the average human out there, the
average old female. When I go to the church, there's a beautiful
old lady. She cares for the children.
I hinder my children
and she doesn't have confrontations with my children. Why? Because
she understands
normal children emotional interaction.
She understands that there are certain children. >> She
literally got your kids for like 2 hours. Shut the up. They're
literally designed to just give them food and give them toys
to play with. That is so much. You don't compare
that person to like the stay-at-home mom.
>> This guy is socially >> No. Come on. >> No.
His His social skills are underdeveloped. Just like his legs.
>> You don't say. >> You can't just say you're going
to do the Christmas tree.
>> Some up social skills right there.
>> Why did I just go back to this? Whoops. Here we And
so
what I'm demand what I was demanding as a minimum level of emotional
maturity
is out there. 98% of the females are prepared and capable of
doing this. And in fact, if they're too stubborn or too authoritarian,
they're able to step back and say, "Look, Jeff, those are your
um
just fa just handle can you handle the chicken nugget situation
and I was happy to do it. So so that is the fundamental thing
that happened about 9 to 16 months ago approximately
that led me to say okay we have a problem here and we're going
to have to work on this. Now the fact is this was time delayed
uh and
I had the opportunity to give it a lot of time because I knew
that my ex the stepmom
would go back to the US to give birth to our child. She wanted
to have her health insurance and her health services in the US.
Okay. So I knew that okay I I knew that there was a family problem
here. minimal, you know, not not something that that led the
children to suffer, to be harmed, nothing major. But I knew there
was a fundamental problem. And I thought, you know what? It's
good that she's leaving because then we're going to be on the
phone and we're going to be able to fix this. I'm going to teach
her some elements of, hey, that's how that's how my daughter
react. That's how my my son reacts and it's going to get better.
But it didn't get better.
It didn't get better. So, I let her go back to the US. And what
happens on the phone? She she she goes into psychosis and ruminating
about her experience with my children
and she starts developing paranoid beliefs and things that she
she's not even seeing.
Like, I'll give you an example of these paranoid beliefs. Um,
my children are friends. They're very good friends with
with two individuals in our in our
Okay, final story from JF and then I think I'm going to call
it for the night, guys. Sorry, I'm uh we're getting around. It's
been a bit of a long stream. 8 hours 30 right now. Damn. >> I
let the individual's
going to my house friends with a >> two two people who
are friends with his kids. Okay.
with two individuals in our in our
I let the individuals come in my house and they play together.
They they do all sorts of thing. Train, train, train. And they
they hold each other by the hand. They dance. They they play
about buses. And she's like, "Come with come with me in the buses.
We have to drive quick." They are doing all sorts of games and
plays together.
I celebrate this. I call the stemp mom and I'm like, "Hey, it's
super great. I mean, they they're finally attaching with with,
you know, deeply with a specific individual and that's their
friend. That's their best friend. It's great to see."
Stepmom goes [__] insane. What are you doing with
other children
in your house? Are you a You're going to her? Is that what you're
going to It's like, oh man,
because I'm a male, I cannot allow children in my home with permission
of their parents and they're just playing in the playroom. It's
like, give me a break, bro.
It's like I believe in communities to an extent. I mean, I'm
kind of, but I I do believe in minimal community building and,
you know, children of the neighborhood trusting each other, loving
each other, and I'm not going to become a at 41
after a whole life without crimes.
I'm not going to become a
all of a sudden. Okay.
So, so that that was the
relationship where it's like, "Oh, I don't want you to do this.
this with them.
I want you to do that, this and that.
And she was trying to work to deprive me of normal relationship.
And you know, I'm not a normal guy. For me to have normal relationship
is actually it's actually something I I need to actively seek,
you know, and I was actively seeking and I'm still I'm still,
you know, living by all standard a very normal life with my children.
But she was opposing to this and she started, "Oh no, I don't
want you to have other kids in the house." It's like, "What the
This is my house. Get the out." And so I tried. I tried. I tried
and the spontaneous the the the shreddinger
>> I don't get that.
>> Yeah. So >> what is Schwarzinger? >> She
So psychologist took over her. >> You're about to be so
disappointed. Cherry's about to have chips. And I think whoever
I think it was me. I put the the clip on the chips.
Didn't do it well.
Chips are a little stale to be honest.
>> No, I put the clip. >> These are crunchy. >> Oh.
Oh, they are crunchy. What the are those different chips? Oh,
maybe just the chips at the top are not crunchy.
>> Same man. I took the rest of them, too. >> Okay.
Well, it is what it is. And she started believing all sorts of
things like this like you're and it was always in relation to
my children. There was all it they were always the seed of her
The fact that I had a normal relationship with my children and
even with other children of the neighborhood
um it was driving her crazy.
And so what happened then 9 months ago. So, she's pregnant. She's
in the US. And I'm like,
um, it seems to put you in a state of nervousness when I update
you about my
How about I don't update you about my children anymore? How about
you concentrate on your pregnancy, make this new baby together,
I will completely cut you out. I'm not going to keep you updated."
And I keep doing my life. and you go on and you keep birthing
our baby. That's what matters in the end. And then in 9 months
from now when our baby is born,
uh you can come back and and we can work on these uh we can work
on the >> I just I don't think something in my mind is
like I just don't really believe that he was like, "No, you should
go back home for the pregnancy and then when you have the kid,
come back and live with me. Go do the hard emotional part all
by yourself and then when you pop out my baby, come back here.
>> These uh >> then we can work on it. No, >> very
weird things that you have to improve.
And that seemed to be the most rational thing to do
um because then then my children would be protected and then
she could concentrate emotionally on her pregnancy.
I didn't want I've never I've never demanded that she be anything
of a stepmom. I've always thought you can be a stepmom to the
extent you want. You can get the level of engagement you want,
but I'm ready to be a 24/7 single father even in a relationship
with you.
did he say earlier he broke up with her a month ago or something?
Well, he said he broke up with her when he realized she didn't
put his name on the birth certificate. But I don't know if you
would realize this, Black Ice, I think you would realize this.
Okay, her not putting the name on the birth certificate probably
means something. It's probably a big deal. I >> I really
don't care. You You
responsibilities with them, I will do them happily. And you can
see in the videos that she's threatening me with, you can see
that I'm a happy father.
>> like you can see that even if I'm half asleep, I'm like,
"Let's change this diaper. Okay, let's clean the butt." The fact
that I stopped informing her about my children led her rather
than improve the situation. Unfortunately, unfortunately,
rather than improve the situation, led her to develop more psychotic
beliefs. Oh, you're you're not doing this.
You're not doing this with the children. H you're not brushing
their teeth. It's like, wait a minute. Don't we agree that I
was stopping to inform you about anything? >> Are kids
young enough to be wearing diapers? Well, one of them is three.
I don't know the ages on them. One of them is three. That's probably
a little old to be wearing diapers, right? His son, who I think
is three, that's probably a little developmentally delayed, right?
To be wearing diapers, not be talking in full sentences yet.
>> We got children. >> When you're getting potty
trained, you would still wear a diaper over like while you're
sleeping. >> You would. I would. I just think you're probably
Aren't you I think around three is when you're you are toilet
trained,
>> I don't know. >> Three, four. That's like before
kindergarten. months ago.
>> So, she started using her abs. >> If you sounded
like this, I would not be with you. That's disgusting. >> Yeah,
Quebecqua accent is not attractive. Um, it's just not a French
accent could be attractive. The Quebec accent is just not doing
it for him. >> He has everything going against him. >> He
had every single thing going against him on top of his ex was
missing and possibly rumored to have been killed by him and this
flew the out. All right. Um, yeah, I think that's
he's a he's a testament to human perseverance. Okay. >> No,
10 out of 10 needs to be studied. >> Possibly. All right.
It's uh it's super late, guys. I'm going to probably host here
and we'll see what we're doing. I think Rei was live.
Uh I don't know if Rei He's live. I'm not exactly hosting it
to the the prime content. Although maybe you guys want to do
that. He's playing 40k tabletop right now. So, good luck. I love
you guys. All
>> Go enjoy Really Tabletop Gaming right now and I'll I'll
we'll be back tomorrow.
More content. Um I haven't gotten to any of my politics stuff.
I probably need to start doing a lot more politics cuz I'm falling
behind and I don't like it. >> We should do the President
Sunday thing. Remember when he used to have like two different
donation bars? >> Oh. To switch between the types of
>> Drama and politics content. Yeah, we could do that.
>> We could do that. Feed the the theory the theory octopus.
Is it the theory octopus? I think. >> Yeah, but you need
something different. Yours can't be an octopus. >> I probably
wouldn't just wholesale steal the octopus. That would probably
not be great. Yeah. All right. Okay. I'm hosting rally, guys.
We'll be back tomorrow. Have a good night. We'll see you guys
later. Bye. Bye. Bye. Good night. See you.
>> See you. See you. Seal.